whether it's deep cleaning clumps of ear
wax from airpods zapping s from a home
damaged by fire or cleaning out dust and
roaches from inside gaming consoles
there are specialized cleaning experts
for every dirty job imaginable the work
these professionals do helps keep our
homes electronics and even mass transit
and iconic landmarks running smoothly
and safely here a 51 cleaning jobs you
didn't know
existed First We Take a look at a team
of real life Heroes fir fighting is an
honorable job but it can also be a dirty
one Mike Matos and the team at Red Line
gear cleaning specialize in deep
cleaning gear for First Responders so
that their uniforms stay clean despite
the extreme
conditions my name is Mike Matos I'm the
owner inventor and founder of redion
gear cleaning we are a mobile on-site
gear cleaning company today we're going
to be taking you through the entire
process of what is involved in cleaning
inspecting and putting firefighting gear
back in service one thing I wasn't
really aware of when I took the job as a
firefighter was the cancer problem
that's plaguing the fire service over
the last 20 years 66% of all firefighter
line of duty desk has been related to
cancer it's not if I get cancer it's
when I get cancer that particular risk
and exposure is something that we really
want to try and mitigate if the
environment is toxic or you have to wear
your air pack that's an exposure cuz if
your lungs cannot handle the exposure
your gear is absorbing all those
exposures into it and that needs to be
cleaned and washed so the mobile
extraction unit is actually a patented
design that allows the truck to come
directly to the fire station to be a
mobile laundry facility that specializes
in cleaning firefighting gear contains a
water our electric big commercial
extractors rers equipment to clean
helmets and air packs all specialized
equipment needed to clean firefighting
gear specifically first step for us is
to assess the firehouse and what that
means could be going Locker to Locker
looking at at the gear determining how
exposed the gear is determining what's
in the guy Pockets determining what gear
needs to be
cleaned this helmet is what we like to
call in the fire service salty this
helmet is gross it has seen a lot of
smoke it has seen a lot of contaminants
a little older guys tend to call their
gear salty gear as a badge of honor and
they look at this gear as something that
shows experience and shows they went
through a very hot very involved fire
and they got really dirty that is
something that at Red Line we're really
trying to change that culture the badge
of honor they wearing is causing cancer
to these guys we're trying to tell them
that clean is the new salty this is our
ultrasonic machine so as you can see
we're loading the helmets in and this is
what has often been referred to as our
deep fryer for
helmets we use a Degreaser we also use a
sanitizer in here that's going to clean
disinfect and sanitize your helmet to
the point where it comes out we just
have to wipe it
down the helmet is probably the most
important part to a firefighter in terms
of his gear red lines all firefighter
own firefighter operated so some people
like to say we washed away all their
experience I like to think we added a
few years of life to
there we take a lot of time washing and
cleaning helmets and that's probably the
most controversial thing we do as a
company because some people believe that
helmet should never be
touched this gear is particularly very
dirty uh really needs a good deep
cleaning from both the helmet Hood
jacket pants liners all the gear really
needs a good heavy deep cleaning because
this gear has seen a lot of
exposure once we've determined what gear
needs to be cleaned that gear has to be
inspected it has to be separated between
the outer shells and the inner liners
completely separated keeping those wash
Cycles completely different so we don't
have cross contamination between the
cleaning but while we're doing this
we're inspecting the gear we're looking
for any rips we're looking for burn
marks we're looking for holes in the
gear we're looking for anything that can
get a firefighter
hurt here we have taken the inner liner
put it on our hydrostatic testing
machine this is a process that would
test the moisture barrier of a
firefighter suit to make sure that
there's no leaks or any problems with
the moisture Bearer to make sure that
water isn't going to get to a
firefighter's skin and cost you
Burns The Next Step would be to hand
clean the gear we use a product called
Decon 7 that we scrub gear to the point
where we get most of the contaminants
off the gear
initially this is an important part for
us as part of the process to get rid of
any bulk contaminant that would be on
that gear whether it be insulation or
anything else they might run into in the
field
a firefighter's gear needs to be cleaned
after every exposure as you can see it
gets pretty
nasty after the inspection the inner
liners are then separated out they
turned inside out so this way we're
washing the part that is against your
skin first those would then go into our
commercial extractor and be washed
through our five cycle program we use
cold water for wash and gear this not
only helps the cleaning process but at
the same time it keeps the colors and
stuff in the fabric true we can fit six
sets of firefighting gear into these
machines cuz they're so large that's 12
pieces of gear going into each extractor
after both the inner shells and the
outer uh shells are clean through our
extractor they then go into their resped
dryers we're able to dry both the liners
and outer shells in 1
hour we lay out the boots that have to
get hand scrubbed and we are also
fogging them spraying them with a
disinfectant it's going to neutralize
it's going to kill it's going to
disinfect anything those boots might
have come in contact with one of the key
elements to a firefighter gear is the
hood they wear underneath their helmet
and go through that protects their ears
that protects their helmet people forget
to even clean these anything that's
going to be exposed and touched to your
skin should be washed the same way as if
you would the liners that are next to
your
skin the water that comes off this
extractor is like a sludge like a mud so
anybody who believes the cancer problem
in fire surface isn't real I encourage
you to see the waste waterer that comes
off this gear it is nasty it is black it
is like mud so at the end of every job
it's important for us to show what the
waste waterer and what the situation is
like in terms of what's coming off the
gear this is the stuff that's coming off
your gear this is the stuff we just
cleaned just now that has loaded with
soot loaded with chemicals loaded with
stuff that's causing cancer to these
guys and we make it a point to show show
these filters to all of our customers to
all the firefighters to know just how
dirty their gear was and how important
cleaning their gear
is our filtration process is so in-depth
that it allows us to take really dirty
water filter it run it through a number
of filters run it through a full process
that makes that water completely clean
reusable prevents us from putting toxic
products back into the environment and
makes it a sustainable solution that we
can keep using and be very environmental
safe after we clean very toxic
gear today the fire service is made up
of a lot of chemicals in the form of
combustion at a fire every single room
is now has Plastics has particle board
has different materials that are burning
it's causing the fires to burn hotter to
burn more violently and smoke is thick
nasty black smoke so while the fire
service has been around for years the
makeup and the exposures of the fire
service are very different
[Music]
nowadays
our final product is taking all 10
pieces of gear that was cleaned putting
it back together putting it in a gear
bag ready to go boots on bottom pants
jacket hoods and gloves tucked in the
side helmet on the top as one complete
package ready to
go we can't control the dangers of the
job but we can control the exposure rate
of what these guys are exposed to from a
cancer causing substance that's really
killing this fire service I don't need
to see soot and dust all over a guy's
helmet and gear to know he knows how to
do his job I want to see a guy who's
clean got his uniform in shape
everything is properly ready to go he's
able to perform his job to the best of
his ability that's a salty
firefighter this isn't an ordinary paint
job Jordan aay is the grounds Keeper at
Soo stadium in Los Angeles and it's his
job to spray paint the field for the
Super Bowl here's how he cleans and
prepares the field for the big event hi
my name is Jordan Shay I'm a
groundskeeper of professional football
today I'm going to guide you through the
process of deep cleaning and preparing
an NFL field for the Super
[Music]
Bowl I started groundskeeping for the
Los Angeles Memorial Coliseum in USC in
2016 from there I went on to Sofi
stadium in
2021 when I found out the Super Bowl is
coming to Sofi Stadium it was very
exciting to know that I would have the
opportunity to be a part of such a big
event
when you're working in a higher scale
setting uh such as professional football
there are a lot more fine details that
go into all the planning and the
execution when it comes to events and
preparation as well as
cleanup the first step to Preparing the
field for the Super Bowl is removing the
paint from the previous
game so the machine that we use to clean
the field is called a p-rex and what it
does is they're brushes with very strong
bristles in a circular shape that go
down and scrub the paint off after we
spray down a
solution we have somebody driving each
and every one and there are a few out
there on the field after the game
ends once the paint is starting to break
up and be liquid there's a vacuum that
sucks the excess paint into a
tank these machines have something that
sprays the tires in order to remove the
paint from them so there's no tracking
and that way we don't get paint in spots
that we don't want it when it's time to
get new brushes and drain the tank then
we drive into our wash station we start
the cleaning process of the
p-rex so right now we're removing the
used brushes spraying them off to get
all the paint off storing them off to
the side so they can dry and putting a
new brush onto each p-rex in order to
send it back out and start cleaning
again it's time to fill up the tanks
with water and the paint removing
solution we dumped the tank tank that
filters the rubber out of the used paint
and then from there we dispose of the
paint so the brushes on the p-rex go
down onto the turf and spin as well as
the operator drives the machine back and
forth in order to remove paint from a
certain area mixed with the solution I'd
say the removal process can take
anywhere from 2 to 4 hours we just keep
going until we don't see any more paint
on the field and it's good to go and
ready for the next paint
day now that we've finished removing all
the paint from the field and it's clear
to go for the next paint day we can
start the process of
painting the process of painting for the
Super Bowl is different from any other
game because there is a whole other crew
that is also involved in the
painting so the preparation process for
the Super Bowl starts at least 2 weeks
ahead of the actual
game when painting for the Super Bowl
there are different logos that we've
never used before new stencils so we
have to map out where everything goes
and measure the spots for these specific
stencils that may be in a spot on the
field that has never been painted
before so while we paint these logos we
want the lines and edges to be straight
we have straight edges and we have
flimsy boards that can be set on
specific spots in order to prevent the
paint from getting into a spot that it's
not supposed to be
in so after we get done painting it's
time to clean the equipment these boards
we take to the back washroom and we use
solution to get the paint
off so this paint board is caked in
paint with multiple layers so we need to
spray scrape and use solution until we
get it all
[Music]
off paint does splatter paint does get
everywhere so we need to make sure the
entire machine is clean takes a little
while in order to get all the paint off
but once it's clean it looks great and
it's worth
[Music]
it so it's important to clean the paint
machines because one you want to take
care of the equipment that you use make
sure that it can last as long as you
would like it to last you don't want
paint built up in certain areas on the
machine because then that can start to
limit the functionality of the
machine watching the confetti rain down
on the field is sural and I would not
trade that feeling for the world until I
realized that we were going to have to
clean it up so to clean this confetti up
we're using as many blowers as we have
in order to bring all the confetti to
one side of the field in one area so we
can shovel it up and pour it in the
trash can remove and just keep doing it
over and over and over until it's all
gone once the confetti is cleaned up we
use a machine called a litter cat to
remove excess debris from the
field the litter cat is part of our
daily maintenance but it is important to
use it after the games as well because
there are a lot of pieces of debris that
get onto the field the first part of the
machine is going to suck up the lighter
debris and the back end of the machine
is a magnet that will remove all the
metal from the
field when we're removing the debris out
of the litter cat we tend to find a lot
of screws from players helmets small
pieces of metal small pieces of plastic
as well as sunflower seed
shells my favorite thing about being a
ground grounds keeper is a team aspect I
work with a lot of great people it's fun
to be around them and to work towards a
common goal of making sure playing
surface is working great for something
of such magnitude being a part of the
Super Bowl process is something that I
wouldn't trade for the world it was a
surreal feeling and I'm excited to watch
this year's Super
Bowl over the years and with frequent
use the inside of a Playstation can
collect layers of dust Louis Maria
repairs phones in video game consoles
for a living and his job often involves
deep cleaning the gadgets to get them
running properly hi my name is Luis I'm
the owner of Lucky repairs and I'm going
to teach you how to clean your
Playstation part by part at lucky
repairs we specialize in fixing anything
from phones to gaming consoles even
miscellaneous things like hair clippers
and speakers sometimes I really try to
fix anything that I
can it's important to clean and maintain
your game ging console because once it
builds up this dust it blocks the air
flow inside of it causing it to overheat
once it Play Station overheats it either
shuts down or the fans start spinning
faster that's where you get the jet
engine sound
from this PlayStation right here is one
of the dirtiest that I've ever worked
on it's built up a lot of dust in the
fan area which prevents air from flowing
through it
properly
for this PlayStation the first step that
I am doing is removing these three
screws to pop off the bottom
housing once the bottom housing is off
you can see some of the dust that has
collected especially in the fan
area next to get deeper into the
PlayStation I take off the power supply
it could be a little finicky to take
this part off you kind of have to pop it
off of one side then wiggle it out
carefully even then it's still connected
by a wire so before removing it
completely we have to disconnect that
wire the power supply is where you can
often find roaches because this is one
of the warmest parts of the
PlayStation roaches tend to hide out
inside of PlayStations because it's dark
and also because of the heat once
flipped over the left side covers the
hard drive it actually comes right off
without any screws you just got to slide
it to the left there's one actual screw
that keeps the hard drive in place once
that's removed you just slide it right
out
with the bottom removed there's a lot of
dust that built up inside of it so we'll
grab a paper towel with some allpurpose
cleaner and give it a good
wipe some PlayStation will have more
dust build up than others the dust can
build up easier especially if you have
pets or if you have it tucked away
inside of a cabinet
area before I can access the motherboard
there are a few cables and screws that
have to be taken
out then we can pop off the motherboard
and pull it away at this point we can
see more of the dust that built up
inside the
PlayStation I use compressed air and
brushes to clean this section off along
with some
alcohol
underneath the motherboard there's even
more build up because this is where the
fan blows air
through removing this top metal piece we
can see one of the most important parts
the heat sink this is where a thick
layer of dust cakes up that you have to
remove this is the part that causes the
PlayStation to choke because the air
flow is
blocked
[Music]
to clear this up I remove the debris
with a pair of tweezers to get the bulk
of
it then use a brush to Dust Away the
rest finally I take it outside to hit it
with some compressed
air once the heat sink is removed and
clean we have direct access to the fan
this is probably one of the most
timeconsuming parts of the cleaning I
use a Q-tip to dust each one of the fins
individually and with this method I have
to clean both sides of the
fan if the debris is really bad a
toothbrush can can help break it
up I also use a toothbrush and
compressed air on other parts of the
PlayStation like the power
supply once the bulk of the Dust has
been blown off outside then we can get
into the more detailed part of the
cleaning I use alcohol and a paper towel
to wipe it all down then to reach the
smaller crevices and parts I use a Q-tip
and brushes to dust it all
[Music]
away some people think it's a little
excessive to clean it this deeply but if
I'm not this thorough then you may not
even tell a
[Music]
difference another very important step
to maintain your console cool is to
replace the thermal paste thermop paste
helps with the transfer of heat from the
Apu to the heat sink thermal paste
doesn't tend to last more than four to 5
years once it starts to age it gets very
dry and cracks those cracks create air
pockets between the heat sink and the
chip which causes it to overheat and you
never want that as your console could be
damaged if it gets too overheated too
many times this is a perfect example of
old thermal paste as you can see is very
dried out and has a lot of
cracks this is one of the main reasons
why a PlayStation and
overheats to clean the old thermal paste
off I use a Q-tip with a little bit of
alcohol on it to carefully remove
it this is one of the more controversial
steps of the repair is the amount of
thermal paste that one adds I add a
psize amount and I've never had any
issues so once it dries out and cracks
it is very important to put a Fresh coat
on because this will cause your your
Playstation to
overheat now that we are done and it's
put together again we wipe the outside
done and it's ready for
gaming it's always satisfying seeing the
before and afters of these PlayStations
with the way the original PlayStation 4
is designed cleaning it isn't as easy
because there are a lot more layers that
you have to remove to access the heat
sink they also tend to build up more
dust compared to the other consoles and
that's why I tend to see a lot more
PlayStation 4s at my shop than
[Music]
others I've been interested in
electronics since a young age it started
off with the PSP making it open like a
iPhone or even the iPods jailbreaking
those those were my middle school years
and going into my high school years
that's when I actually started messing
with the hardware replacing screens
speakers and stuff like that
some problems that people have with
their PlayStations are that it won't
turn on or the fan sounds like a jet
engine also you can have the disc drive
acting up where it won't accept or spit
out the
disc I love what I do because it helps
people and I get the satisfaction of
fixing the
problem now we head to the 911 Memorial
in New York City an important Landmark
that draws millions of visitors each
year these are the people who keep it
looking spotless each
day this is Jim he's cleaning the
reflecting pools at the 911 Memorial in
New York City Jim and his team are
working beneath a 27t tall waterfall in
near total darkness vacuuming every inch
of the pool their goal is to do it
without missing a SP spot it's a
physically demanding job but that's not
the only challenge I've never actually
marked how many miles it is but you do a
few miles in there and it could be humid
and you come out of there and uh it feel
like you walked on the moon
almost the pools are nearly an acre each
so it would take hours to finish the job
before the sun comes
up while he works inside the pool other
crew members work on the bronze panels
above ground
these routines happen 5 days a week and
are essential for keeping the memorial
in pristine condition for the millions
who come to pay their respects
here they start by shutting off the
waterfalls and over the next 8 hours Jim
and his team work tirelessly to deep
clean this
pool the hottest part is it's it's a
long test the pool is Big it's it's not
a uh a swimming pool you know it's a
200x 200 Giant
pool I'm going to pull the hose out and
then bring it back or whatever just you
don't have to use the whole reel we have
too much hose we usually have three men
through the pool so two guys be in the
pool and one guy will be outside running
the the pumps which collect the uh
debris and return the clean water back
to the pool once we're set we're on our
way I go and vacuum generally and I I
have whoever's with me that night
brushes behind come on hurry up sorry we
got all day
here all right the vacuum will capture
most of the debris and the person
brushing will knock up some of the other
loose debris that doesn't get caught and
it will be caught into like some of our
filters that we have running
downstairs now I'm trapped in the hose
here I'm going to trip
myself and we'll be on America's
bloopers the workers generally clean out
dirt leaves and algae from the bottom of
the pools they also remove larger items
that visitors drop or throw in they
don't always know what they'll encounter
in the pool each
night we find kids to boys little small
items depends on the the crowd one night
I actually found a a bat in there and
I'm not talking about a baseball bat I'm
talking about a bat it was pretty wild
when it flew away from me when when I
realized I was grabbing a
bat depending on the cleanliness of the
pool it could take anywhere between 6
and 7 hours and sometimes if we feel up
to it we could do it a little quicker
some people treat this place like a uh
wishing well so we do catch some money
and unfortunately I think some people
being that it's so far removed from the
original 9/11 I think some people are a
little uh uneducated about this place
and some people treat it like just a
regular Fountain and they're throwing
garbage in here sometimes too you know
people have to learn that this isn't
your uh Mall fountain I knew few of the
uh Brokers that passed away a whole
whole uh a whole group of them had a
meeting in one of the towers
unfortunately and uh except for one one
Traer all of them
perished I I think about them
often because we go up top where the
names are and brush near the name plates
the troughs and uh on the North side
they're all all on one panel I see I see
their names just about every day total
waste of uh lives that you know could
have been doing good good in the world
now while Jim and the team finish
cleaning the pools below Ryan is
tackling the bronze name panels above
the panels honor the
2,983 victims of the attacks on the
World Trade Center both in 1993 and
2001 Ryan will have to strip the top
layer of metal and use a blowtorch to
remove a carving someone etched onto the
plaque without damaging the rest of the
Memorial this confuses me why you want
to write something
[Music]
here for a mark like that you have to go
pretty deep get all the way down
otherwise you can't really get rid of it
if you don't go down far enough you'll
see it when you refinish it the further
down you go the better sometimes I've
seen nice things written but you know
you they don't understand you just you
can't just write whatever you want on it
it after briefly assessing the damage
Ryan needs to remove the protective bars
so he can reach the entire metal surface
to do this he props up the bars with a
wood Plank and unhooks the brackets
holding up the
panels now what I'll do is uh rub it
down with a NAFTA it's almost like a
paint thinner it just kind of takes the
wax off so I'm not burning
wax if I can open it
and it shouldn't take too long once I
get the torch on
it there's so much in the prep and then
the finishing the torch is
actually not that bad after sanding down
the top layer of panel and neutralizing
the wax Ryan is ready to blowtorch the
damaged area to melt the metal in the
patina so he can repaint the color layer
and restore the panel to its original
state this is what we use
and it's basically just a patina in a
solution oh I haven't used you in a
while prep
them so I'm basically getting up to the
right temperature if it's too cold it
it'll go on spotty if it's too hot it'll
kind of evaporate off or it'll get
burnt in the summer months the longest
part of the job is waiting for the
burned panel to cool before applying a
new layer of wax and an acrylic top coat
to finish the restoration
process we're going to put the acrylic
spray on
it just kind of like a clear coat helps
it kind of adhere a little bit
better the last step really well besides
buffing the wax off so I'm just going to
put the wax on real nice not too hard
not a lot you don't need a ton
just put it on
lightly the wax will go over the finish
and make it look once I polish it it'll
look brand new got a little bit of heat
but that's cuz it's still
hot but it was right
here now all Ryan has to do is buff off
the excess wax using a white scotchbrite
pad and then once it gets smooth you
know you're done
when people do something like that I
wouldn't say it makes me angry I get it
some of these people might not have even
been alive when it happened or they were
too young to get it my uncle was a New
York City firefighter and he was hurt
really bad here but uh luckily he
survived we got we got a little
lucky after a strenuous 6 to 7 hours of
cleaning Jim and the team are ready to
head out of the
pool by tomorrow morning a new batch of
visitors will see sparkling pools below
rushing waterfalls and most of them
won't know that Jim's team was even
here when we uh finished the pool most
of the time we just were just ready to
really get out of there and most of our
inspection we you know we're fairly
confident that we did the proper job
there's always a little fail Factor but
you know not too
bad my father work worked in these
buildings almost his whole life and my
father was here for uh the 93 bombing
and that was before cell phones and
everything and he was the he was on the
30th floor of the uh second tower when
he was there he was like the floor
Marshal he came home full of soot but he
stayed there because there was people
that couldn't get down the steps so he
made sure that he stayed with them so I
I think on 9/11 day you know if he was
here uh we probably would have have lost
him because he wouldn't have left he
passed away a couple of years
ago he was always so proud of the job I
I probably had chances to do other
things in this building but even if I
wanted to do another job I wouldn't
because of him and I and now you know I
I love doing it so I do it this layer of
black sht is the result of fire damage
and it needs to be cleaned thoroughly
Kevin Harrison is the owner of project
laser in Western Australia and he shows
us how he uses specialized tools to get
the job
done my name is Kevin Harrison and I'm
the owner and operator of project laser
which is a mobile laser cleaning service
in Western
Australia lasers are really good at
cleaning sort of basically any hide
substrate so that can be a wooden beam a
steel beam a painted wall paving stones
bricks all sorts of surfaces whe whether
it's really smooth or porous we're
sending thousands of light pulses every
second into the surface contamination
this is getting absorbed into the soot
and it's basically vaporizing it or
popping it off the
surface on this day we were called in to
help out remove smoke damage from a home
that had a Molotov cocktail thrown into
it there was Smoke Filled throughout the
home on both stories like really really
dark black soot we had to remove smoke
damage from every single surface so this
was within the kit lounges bathrooms we
used a large laser for this job cuz it's
got the 15 M hose we parked the vehicle
right next to the house and then just
extended the fiber optic cable through a
a door that had been kicked in and that
gave us access to the majority of the
house this was a really long process
basically work from left to right once
we finished laser cleaning we did wipe
down the Walls just to ensure that
there's no vagrant soot on the surface
we use a pulse laser which is basically
a tool to remove thin layers of surface
contamination so the benefits of a pulse
laser it has no abrasive power so no
matter how hard we try we can't profile
scratch or damage a surface porous brick
is going to absorb more of the soot it's
got all the cracks and crevices where
soot will sit and you may have to clean
at certain different angles whereas if
you got a nice smooth painted surface
it's all even there's no such hiding in
different cracks and crevices here we're
doing smoke damage removal with our
small 200 W mobile laser
on a rammed Earth wall if You' run your
fingers over the wall it was all crumbly
and falling apart so if they chosen to
use High Press water chemicals and
scrubbing brushes they would have
removed lots of material this was a bush
fire that basically came up to the home
and licked the wall and then caught the
trusses on fire so there was also some
smoke damage cleaning inside the house
that we had to carry
out when you're using a laser cleaning
machine you need to take safety very
seriously it is very easy to mitigate
the risk firstly that can be done by
wearing the correct safety glasses so
for us that's wearing safety glasses
that protect your eyes from the 1064
infrared laser pulses secondly we've
spent an uncomfortable amount of money
on respirators so everyone who operates
the laser we'll be wearing a respirator
the beautiful thing about using a laser
cleaning machine is you can really
adjust the parameters depending on what
you're cleaning if you want to clean a
larger area quicker you can have a beam
that goes for example 100 mm wide or
about 3 and 1/2 in if you wanted to
doing large areas you could turn the
power up and have a large Beam at the
same time you could really wind the
power down if you wanted to remove soot
off a chandelier or a bathtub or the
side of a TV you really could wind it
down enough to not damage even Plastics
if
necessary with our smaller laser it's
got a really defined focal zones an inch
or a couple centimet so if you're not
with perfectly within that focal Zone
the laser is not going to be effectively
cleaning the beauty of the laser is you
can just move backwards and forwards
slowly and you'll hear when the laser is
at its loudest which is basically when
it's chewing through the so you could
laser clean with your eyes closed and
just use your ears once you get used to
the sound on this job we're using our
500 W laser cleaning machine to remove
smoke damage from a pull pump that
caught on fire once we arrived on site
we saw that we could easily put our
fiber optic cable over the fence
unfortunately there was a lot of heat
with this fire so there was a bit of
area where the bricks were permanently
oxidized so there was a fair few spots
where there's actually permanent damage
on the bricks we took off all the old
plug points screws they were still stuck
in the wall this just enabled us to
really clean the whole wall properly if
we need to protect any hoses or cables
when we're laser cleaning put blue
masking tape over the surface or ideally
you put aluminium foil tape aluminium
reflects up to 95% of infrared light so
it's really easy to to stop the laser
pulses yeah laser cleaning is very
different to traditional cleaning
methods for removing soot externally
they would use High Press water intern
surfaces you're generally using a
Degreaser a bleach countless Rags
chemical gloves be spraying the chemical
onto the surface be wiping it off and
then you'd be using more clean Rags just
until that surface was clean enough that
they could apply another paint over the
top lasers are basically a single pass
there's no water there's no chemicals
getting used it's defin the cleanest
process both internally and externally
laser cleaning is a brilliant technology
it's really only getting started in the
the sense of being mobile so the
technolog is really growing rapidly
every city in the world is in the next
few years is going to have a laser
cleaning company that specifically
targets smoke damage it's a good feeling
to be one of the first companies doing
it and and doing it
well this 1978 start darling Nova was a
Dusty mess after sitting in a bond for
over three decades the professionals at
WD detailing use their expertise to get
it looking like new my name is Brent
dezar I'm one half of WD detailing and
today we're going to be cleaning a 1978
Sterling Nova that sat in a barn since
so Sterling Nova is a kit car which is
on a Volkswagen Beetle chasis and engine
and it's really unique because of the
way it looks and the way that the top
opens there's no doors on this car the
way that you get in and out is literally
by the whole top lifting up we had to
take the top off of this car because it
actually couldn't hold its own weight up
and we didn't want to risk it falling on
one of us as soon as we took the top off
of the car we found this mouse Nest
right on the back side of the dash it
was made out of insulation or carpet or
parts from the seats any random fibers
that they can find in the car they'll
take and make a nest out of and then we
sanitize the area afterwards with
triclean which is a cleaner that will
kill all the bacteria cars attract mice
because they know that it's a dark space
and when these cars sit in a barn and
nobody's touching them for 30 plus 40
plus years they're not going to be
bothered so they're going to take
advantage of that and then after that we
were able to take the seats out and
really get in there and clean everything
we found that these carpets were
completely disintegrated and they're
definitely going to have to replace them
and we actually haven't really seen
carpets this bad before so if I had to
make an assumption on why this happened
It's a combination of them sitting over
time and the mice getting into them and
eating them up and under the car carpet
as soon as we pulled it out I looked
down and found a nice surprise of a dead
mouse we disposed of it off camera but
we just had to pick it up with our
gloves and toss it in the garbage can
there's no nice way to throw away a dead
mouth we started vacuuming the floor
pans and then we sanitized them again
with our Tri
clean
and then we used our steamer behind it
to kill anything
else and then we wiped it all away with
microfiber
towels so this dashboard was covered in
dust completely and at this point we're
still using Tri clean to clean the
interior because we want to disinfect
everything we knew that this car isn't
going to be started for quite a while
because it doesn't run and it needs a
lot of repair work so if cleaner gets
inside the buttons or inside of the
switches it's not going to be the end of
the world because it'll definitely dry
up before there's any kind of
electricity running through this
[Music]
car so if you want to get a barn find uh
a good way is searching on Facebook
Marketplace the people that we work with
specifically search for these cars and
then they bring them to us because they
sat for so long a lot of it's word of
mouth so for these seats they were
covered in anything that the mice could
put on them so the first thing that we
do is vacuum them and then we'll go go
ahead and extract them so we use our
extractor soap and then we'll use our
drill brush to agitate the soap and
really work it into those fibers and
then we'll use our extractor which
shoots hot water into the fibers and
also sucks it away at the same time so
it's a vacuum but it's a vacuum with
water the exterior of this car was
covered in dust from front to back and
then there was some wood chips and other
stuff in the headlight crevice which I'm
pretty sure on this kit there's supposed
to be a headlight cover but for some
reason they were missing on this
specific
car and here we're vacuuming out some of
the jams which we like to do before we
pressure wash off the car because if
there's any wood chips or anything it
might scratch the
paint so on the wheels they were covered
with some sort of green substance which
I don't know if it was mold or not and
to clean this tire we'll go ahead and
pressure wash everything off of it
first and then we'll use our pns brake
Buster on the tire and the rim and then
we'll use an assortment of brushes
usually soft bristle brushes and a tire
brush and then we'll pressure wash it
all
away
the paint on this car was in pretty good
condition the only thing that we noticed
was deteriorating was the black paint so
what we're spraying on this car is a
paint saf de Greaser so we can loosen up
all that dirt before we pressure wash it
away and what that's going to do is
minimize any kind of swirl marks or
scratches paint chips can be damaging to
a car only because it can cause rust to
form if there's metal underneath where
the paint was but there was no rust on
this body at all because it's made out
of
fiberglass so we're starting to film the
car here using our pressure washer and
foam Cannon and this is the part that a
lot of people find the most satisfying
in the whole process and there's two
reasons why people use foam cannons the
first one is as a pre-o so they can
loosen up all the dirt that's on the
surface of the car but also instead of
just putting soap in a bucket it helps
you put soap over the entire car which
makes the process safer for the paint
and
easier and after foaming the car we'll
use microfiber mitts on the entire car
to wash it
down
and now we're using our rup has buffer
to take any of the oxidation off the top
layer of the paint which will make it a
lot shinier less dull and give it that
overall wow factor at the end so this is
just like a paint correction when it
came to the black paint we didn't even
polish it at all because it was starting
to come off of the car and we didn't
want to ruin or take away any of that
paint that was already there there
wasn't too much that we could personally
do it's something that would have to
either be redone or just left as
is and after the whole car is cleaned
and we're ready to do the finishing
touches we'll do a tire shine and as
that dries it leaves the tires looking
nice and matte black and it just gives
it that overall wow factor for the
customer and the absolute last thing
we'll do is spray a ceramic sealant over
the entire car it'll protect the paint
just a little little bit but it also
give it a nice shine and just complete
the detail and that's
it I was super happy with the way that
this car turned out I actually
personally want to buy it myself we'll
see how that goes in the near future
when it's done being fixed
up when it comes to cleaning barn finds
if I can give any advice it's just to
take your time and really do your
research that way you don't make any
super detrimental mistakes because the
last thing you want to do is find
something that has original paint or an
original interior and damage it but also
have fun with the
process even when covered pot tubs can
quickly become mercy and muddy without
routine cleanings that's where
professional pool Engineers like miles
Laughin also known as the pool guy step
in my name is Miles aka the pool guy and
today I'm going to show you how to
professionally clean a hot
tub all right this is probably the worst
hot tub I've had to work on there's
literally slugs spiders the water's
black and the smell is just
disgusting so the first thing I done
when I got there was taking the cover
off for the actual job was yet to take
the cover off inspect it out it was we
took that off and stood it up on the
grass and that got jet washed um and
brushed down and there's a lot of like
creases in the cover so there's slugs in
there as well still trying to hide and
like sort of stay in their home but they
all got cleared out so it was mostly
water with the jet wash um and then you
had like a little bit of um cleaning
solution uh with the cover that took
around an hour to
[Music]
clean
on the Sid there's a lot of like black
markings like slime and dirt and there's
still a lot of slugs sort of like um
slivering around like 100 slugs on this
hot tub and the guy said he hadn't used
it for like 10 years so I just started
off with a jet wash and they sort of got
jet washed away at first there was like
so many and to be honest with you I
don't really fancy picking up slugs
so
[Music]
so the white tube there that's connected
to my submersible pump which I'm using
to pump water from the hot tub down the
drain uh so I got the broom out um
because you got where where you sit down
in the hot tub it's quite it's a bit
like a bowl so it'll hold a lot of water
and what I'm just doing is just pushing
it into the middle so the yeah the
submersible pump can drain it out
easier
[Music]
at the bottom of the tub you just had
like a little bit of dirty water and a
little bit of
grit so underneath here you've got the
main circulating pump you've got the
heater for the hot tub all the pump
equipment's kept underneath the hot tub
so I pulled the panel back and and which
all needed to be cleaned out as well and
I used the Hoover to get all
that so hot tub flush is a chemical
which you will pour into your in through
the where the filters usually sit and
then you turn on all the all the Jets in
the hot tub so yeah once you put the hot
tub flush in and it starts reacting with
all like the um fats and anything that's
caught up in the in the tubes inside the
hot tub it creates like a foam and then
you can also see in the foam you can see
the dirt which is coming out of the the
pipes as well so you can see it's
working once it bubbles up you can um
get a net and just net them out so they
don't cuz what happens is it will start
sticking to the sides cuz it's like an
acrylic
um material so it will stick to the
sides um and if you don't scoop it out
you'll have to then scrub the sides
again um so it's just easier just to get
the net net out the foamy bits and all
the dirt on the foam um and it'll make
it easier for
yourself um so I've got this hot tub uh
filter here and it's looking really
black there's a lot of dirt all over it
and I'm going to give it a rinse down
just clear it so it's filtering properly
again most pools have sand filters
whereas hot tubs have cartridge filters
so what happens is obviously while the
filters are collecting the small
particles if you don't take them out and
rinse them your water will start to go
cloudy uh so it's basically just dirt
and then obviously anything that comes
off like your body um like dead skin
anything you can get caught up in the
filter as well so you can rinse them
down with your garden hose and then you
can spray them with um filter cleaner
which just disinfects any bacteria
that's on
them um and then put them straight back
into the hot tub and then they're ready
to go
again on hot tub you can get like a
little floating dispenser um and it just
floats around on the water just slowly
releasing chlorine or
bromine uh that's a chemical test kit um
and on the left will be to test for the
bromine or chlorine level and on the
right I am testing for the pH level
you're looking for the middle color
which is around
7.2 so with the hot Tu it was looking
after I'd finished with it it was
looking brand new nice and blue again um
the customer was really happy with it
and it just looked like a new hot tub
rather than what it did like 5 hours ago
that was definitely the worst hot tub
I've ever worked on and actually seeing
the final product um with it nice and
blue water in it again nice and clear
and everything working on there I was
pretty happy with
that horsse Hooves need constant
maintenance and it takes an expert eye
and lots of experience to know exactly
how much to trim here's how Sam dracott
a farer in the UK gives riding horses
pedicures to prolong their lives my name
is Sam Draco I'm a farer and I want to
show you the cleaning process and the
shoe process of a
horse the main thing I'll do is riding
schools there's a lot more science
behind it that meets the eye so what
you'd need is the anatomical sort of
understanding of the horse's foot with
tendons ligaments arteries veins bones
columns how they grow also we need to
have some blacksmithing skills order to
construct the
shoe anything that needs to be done to
help maintain the horse's lifespan
really so the actual condition of this
foot is is pretty good it's just been 6
weeks and it's just grown so that
triangle bit in the middle was known as
the Frog this is is known for helping
grip and aiding blood supply around the
foot so I've got my straight blade I'm
actually cleaning out the sole as you
can see it's of going to crumble out and
then this will help me aiding in how
much foot this hores actually grow and I
just trim it all
back as the hoof grows it's almost like
a giant fingernail so it's always
constantly growing so you need to trim
that back reset the shoe back so the
bone column of the structure of the leg
is actually set in the correct Place
rather than if it's too long it will be
under a lot of pressure for attendance
so imagine almost wearing a huge pair of
shoes for yourself it makes it very
difficult for you to walk so to have the
horses regularly trimmed will help
actually maintain the lifespan of the
horse and the function of it doing
whatever discipline it's
in as you take the sole out it will
start to become slightly waxy it won't
crumble out quite so easy and that's a
good indication you'll get in as far as
you should go and then you should be
able to just trim that bit off off the
excess hoof and that's it so you want to
trim from there
really so i' use these giant parona
Cutters really and you'll just start
trimming the foot off nice and level as
flat as you can the bit I'm actually
trimming is exactly what a toenail made
out of so it's millions and millions of
strands of hair actually bonded together
so it's exactly the same keratin protein
as a fingernail would
have
there is actually no nerve endings on
the bits that I touch the horse fills
the sensation so imagine having a shoe
on and somebody Taps the bottom of your
shoe you'll feel the sensation of it but
it doesn't actually hurt you it's pretty
much exactly the
same the Giant nail file is actually
what we call the rasp and then you would
use the rasp to get it lce and flat
because these horses actually walk on
their fingernails unlike us so this has
to be flat to help them walk evenly on
their joints because if you did one side
higher than the other then they'll be
walking unevenly and it would put
excessive strain on their joints and the
tendons so the idea is to get it as flat
as you can so almost
perfect so say if it wasn't quite 100%
perfectly flat the shoe would actually
finish that job for you so every foot
that I do is completely unique there's
no feet there two the same I buy these
sort of factory made and to a standard
size and then we put them in the Forge
to heat them up to make them flexible
manable enough to make them custom for
the horse so the process would start
with getting the right size of the horse
sort of by memory in a lot of practice
as you're trimming the feet you sort of
see the shape that the horse's feet you
have so you might see it's slightly
straight on one side quite flare on one
side you would clock that in your brain
automatically get a rough size and shape
that you would need and nine times out
of 10 I would get it pretty much bang on
straight
away I'm now sort of looking to make
sure that the shoe fits the foot this
doesn't hurt the horse's foot at all if
you hold it on there for a long time
then the sensation of the heat will
travel up the foot they will eventually
feel it but I'd say five six seconds is
probably all you
need and then this will make a mirror
image from the shoe to the foot surface
so as you burn it on it it makes it
perfectly flat so it's like perfect snug
fit once they're fitted and they're the
right shape for the horse needs you need
to cool them down so a bucket of water
is good old fashion way of getting it
down to handling temperature so you can
pick it up and use it with your own
hands the nails probably only go about 2
or 3 mil into the hoof wall and then
they would go up the hoof wall and then
come out out the side so as you nail it
in it curves out so then you can flick
it over and clamp it onto the
foot and I'm using my clenching tongs
these actually flick over the end of the
nail and push it back into the foot so
it grips and stays on to create what's
know as clenches and then I would use a
rasp and that would um buff the foot up
make it all nice and smooth you don't
want any sharp edges for the horse to
catch itself so this is the finishing
process to make it all basically nice
and pretty
and what people would consider as part
of getting their nails done
really as you filed the hoof wall off
you actually taking like a very very
fine layer off the outside which
maintains the moisture in the feet and
it's protective layer so you replenish
this with a grease or any oil or
anything shiny
really if you're malnourished or
anything like that fingernails and hair
are the first thing that would show that
same as any animals you know with dogs
cats any that hygiene you know is a big
factor if you got poor hygiene of a
horse you know in a stable that's not
cleaned out poor maintenance of its feet
not being trimmed or looked after will
eventually affect a horse or any animal
in the wild horses are actually meant to
live as long as we allow them to live
normally as they get to an age of it
could be 10 to 15 depending on type
breed environment and the Predators that
they would naturally have they would
slow down and the Predators would get
them so we have them in such good
posture and maintain them so well they
live actually a lot
longer the Georgia Aquarium is the
largest aquarium in the Western
Hemisphere and one of the largest in the
world every day specialized teams gear
up to clean the hundreds of exhibits
across all eight of the aquarium's
galleries this is Rivers he's waiting
through a pool of waste beneath one of
the largest aquariums in the world
Georgia
Aquarium it's a filthy job but that's
not the only challenge there's a lot of
waste to manage when this Basin is full
it can hold between 5 to 10,000 gallons
of poop that funnels here from the
aquarium's habitats and it's the
culmination of many routine cleaning
procedures that happen at the aquarium
each week without which the safety and
health of the animals would be at
risk by the time rivers and his team's
work here is complete the waste water
from this Basin will be cleaned filtered
and reused as topof water for the
aquarium's largest exhibit ocean Voyager
and the cleaning cycle will begin again
but before Rivers can do his job several
other critical procedures have to happen
first every day specialized teams gear
up to clean the hundreds of exhibits at
the
aquarium one of the first you'll see
when you enter the aquarium is the sea
line exhibit which is home to this guy
Toby a 200 79 harbor seal before a team
of divers can begin cleaning his habitat
Toby and the other sea lines need to
vacate their pools staffers use this
time to do their weekly weigh-ins and if
we're talking about Dirty Jobs he just
urinated on the scale and now we got to
clean it side effect of the
jump this pool it's all sea lion poop
it's all sea Li poop everything that
she's vacuuming from here is going into
that way Basin so whatever we do in here
LSS or life support team then has to
clean up from their end Megan Wade leads
the pinnipeds team to clean the decks
and assist the dive operations team as
they clean the pools before guests
arrive this space is home to 14 sea
liines and three harbor seals the sea
lines can eat 5% to 8% of their body
weight making the sea line exhibit one
of the dirtiest in the aquarium every
single morning we come in first thing
and prepare their food and this is
restaurant quality fish they get
numerous species of fish about five
different species and every single
morning one or two people will come in
and inspect every single fish so we're
looking for missing eyes missing fins
gills scrapes Cuts anywhere where you're
going to see that can breed bacteria so
that fish automatically get sorted out
and we don't use it at all we weigh out
their food into buckets and then we'll
look at it again one last time before
feeding it to the animals once a week
every Wednesday it's wayday Wednesday
follow me this way we have our blue
scale right here and then where the
green is lit up is going to tell us how
much they weigh so each sea lion will
walk from their habitat down this
hallway we'll get their weight and then
they'll walk back to their
habitat after the sea liines are fed
weigh and out of the main spaces Megan
and the team start working on cleaning
the deck areas her team splits up
between the back pools and the main
Gallery where they detail every nook and
cranny as soon as you come in in the
morning you can usually smell uh that
they have been sleeping overnight we
have high up platforms that they like to
sleep on the rocks and when you're
sleeping and you don't get up to go to
the
bathroom it all just sits there so if we
didn't clean every single day it would
be really stinky kind of an ammonia
smell also there's feal matter as well
well we are going to detail this whole
area it gets cleaned every single day
but we detail it once a week every week
three male sea lions and one male harbor
seal all slept out here last night so
it's probably going to be pretty messy
the chemicals that we use are to really
break up that oil that's on the surface
that the sea liin secrete so it's just
soap in water and then we'll use some
chlorohexidine to disinfect the area
afterwards
and then down here Gail has a like a
nice little hand brush and she's
actually doing one of the dirtiest jobs
she's cleaning the drains all of this is
going to always be hosed to a drain away
from the water the sea lion swim in
she's taking the grates Off cleaning
inside the drain so that everything
flows nicely each day that we
clean so the drains are part of the
detailing the removal of the net and
soaking that's part of the detailing sea
lions when they breathe sometimes shoot
snot out of their nose so a lot of times
in Sea Li habitats you'll see brown snot
on the walls so we'll need to scrub that
off too my favorite part about cleaning
the deck is getting to net the poop out
of the water because I it just so
reinforcing when you do a good job and
you get good at it so I just love doing
it after Megan and the pinnipeds team
work on the main Gallery deck Alex Glick
and a team of divers work on everything
below deck at the sea line exhibit today
you're going to start in pool two and
then do pool three this one's vacuuming
and uh floor scrubbing and then pool
three will be vacuuming Rock work and
then a final floor scrub so we do this
dive on a just normal scuba even though
it's only an 8T pool we still do scuba
diving so that you have freedom of
movement this is our vacuum hose they
actually plug this in in the water and
we have to make a radio call to our life
support system and they'll turn the
vacuum on so we drop the vacuum head in
the water with the hose attached to the
diver and then they will Prime the hose
to get all the air out of the line this
pool it's all sea lion poop you want to
get as much vacuumed up before you
started scrubbing before this scrubber
is one of the key tools the divers use
to thoroughly clean everything under the
water a hose pump water through the
engine which Powers the scrubber this
high- press water makes cleaning the
floors and walls much
easier the single scrubber has hard
bristles and is used for rock work while
the double brush scrubber is used to
clean the walls and painted surfaces
once she's done vacuuming I'll give this
to her and she will then clean the floor
and she's holding the trigger down and
she's just swimming back and forth doing
kind of like a lawn mower motion
cleaning one side to the next to get
every single inch of the
pool if she comes across an area that's
particularly dirty she might slow down
and spend a little time on it to get up
whatever scum is on the bottom and then
move
on animal debris doesn't just settle on
the habitat's floors and surfaces it
also collects in grates and skimmer
boxes these outflows help manage waste
between routine cleanings by separating
animals from some of the debris in total
it takes Alex and his team of divers
roughly an hour to complete their work
in both pools
on the other side of the aquarium is
ocean Voyager the largest Indoor Aquatic
exhibit in the United States it holds
6.3 million gallons of water it is home
to whale sharks mantay and thousands of
other fish this space is largely
dependent on an advanced life support
and filtration system but still relies
on teams for maintenance and Hands-On
cleaning in ocean Voyager we have two
whale sharks there's yon which is the
larger whale shark and then there's
tooco common misconception about whale
sharks would be that they're dangerous
the most intimidating thing is they're
just big they just are big and so like
if you're in the way you just got to
move they're not out to hurt you like
their throat is only the size of a
quarter they're very very docile
creatures and they just want to cruise
along we usually have have four to eight
divers in our everyday maintenance dive
we clean the windows so we need our
suction cup we bring what we call a
diaper otherwise it just looks like a
rag when we clean the acrylic windows
with that and then usually we're doing
hand scrubbing they are scrubbing off
the algae and they're kind of basically
wafting off all that sand substrate that
cakes on and falls over onto those rocks
all that stuff that can grow on there is
potentially harmful for all the fish so
the whole goal of cleaning and upkeeping
the exhibit isn't necessarily to keep it
pretty even though that is also very
beneficial to keep it pretty for the
guests but at the same time there is the
purpose of doing it for the health of
the exhibit this is a monster exhibit so
if we didn't do it every day it' be
pretty much impossible to up the blitz
Dives which are our night Dives that's
our essential deep
clean so it can be a couple hours long
just to get everything we can done we
can run up to four of those Armada
machines and clean different areas of
the exhibit
while ocean Voyager is being cleaned
Carolyn Murphy and the Aquarius team are
over at the river Scout Gallery getting
ready to dive into these three
freshwater tanks the smallest tanks
measure 4 ft tall by 3 ft deep and the
team spends 1 to 2 hours every week
cleaning the windows and maintaining the
underwater Gardens here so despite the
size of these tanks we actually do
manage squeeze some people in there what
we are going to be doing is something
called hookah diving so the divers are
getting in very carefully they're kind
of sliding in the top of the tank and
they're going to be holding themselves
up in the water column by pressing their
feet to opposite sides of the tank or
putting them on the outside the top rim
and they'll kind of hold them themselves
with their core strin kind of up in the
water column to do the work they need to
do so we're focusing on the algy that's
growing on the window and the plant
leaves and then also the detrus that's
building up in the tanks and that can be
feal from fish or leftover food the team
goes into the dive with a few core tools
a scrub brush trimming tools and a fine
plastic scraper to clean algae off the
windows the most painstaking part for
the aquarists in this tank is cleaning
out the beard algae so it is so annoying
and it is something that we tediously
tried to keep under control so you're
seeing these little kind of black Puffs
that's what she's targeting right now
when she's scraping it off and
immediately removing it from the system
cuz it will just spread over
everything the divers use a gravity
siphon to clean out the loose debris
that's settled in the gravel this isn't
powered by electricity it relies solely
on gravity to suction up and separate
the waste from the
gravel algae covering everything doesn't
look great but it also can cause
problems for your fish so algae blooms
in the wild can kind of take the oxygen
that the fish need out of the system so
it can cause some harm for them that
way all the waste and debris from each
of these cleanings ends up here this is
cleaned out every 3 to 4 months to
ensure the Basin doesn't overflow it
doesn't create water quality issues and
all the systems continue to run smoothly
as you can see we've got just piles of
poop and debris and extra food stuff
that didn't get digested properly stuff
that didn't get eaten got pulled into
filtration most of it is just animal
waste there is a little bit of sand
probably about 10 5 gallon buckets
yourself the equipment we'll use to
clean the Basin is a fire hose and a
snow shovel cleaning this space takes
roughly 2 to 3 hours and is done in
stages they'll remove the poop clean the
floors and then shovel all the sand out
once we've gotten the sand out then
we'll go around and inspect the walls
make sure there's no cracks make sure
the waterproofing is still good so where
all the discoloration happens is about
where the Basin gets roughly 55 to
60,000 gallons to a full Basin but other
than being gross the hardest part is
definitely getting the sand out just cuz
we got to lift it 25 ft in the air so we
really only want to fill them about half
full um if they were to get too full
they might Splash and they're also just
really
heavy once this Basin is full we will
then rece circulate all this water and
clean this water to reuse it for top off
water for our ocean Voyager exhibit
after the recovery all this water is
Crystal
Clean over time engagement rings can
collect hair lint and dirt Gabby Davis a
certified diamontologist shows us how
she deep cleans two dirty engagement
rings I'm Gabby Davis and I'm a jewelry
specialist at Jared the gallery of
Jewelry and today I'm going to be
showing you how I clean both a diamond
engagement ring as well as a beautiful
amethyst statement ring as
well both of these Rings here I would
call extreme cases normally there's a
lot of lotions from people who aren't
removing their rings when they're
applying their lotions or their hair
products so for the most part when a
ring comes in needing a cleaning it just
more so has like a hazy look to it or
maybe some slight Caked Up of soaps and
lotions but hair is definitely not
something that I see every single day
the very first step before I even begin
cleaning it is using the fine tip of the
needle to actually check the stones
looking at this ring here it looks like
it has been at least 6 months if not
longer since this ring has been cleaned
now with the style of this engagement
here which is called a split shank where
it has these openings along the side it
really has a owed a lot of this hair and
this buildup to become caught in these
openings of the ring so I'm going to
start out by using my tweezers and
needle to be able to extract all of this
hair that has gotten caught up in all of
the openings and crevices of this ring
here the guest who brought in this ring
is actually a hairdresser which really
helps explain why there is such an
excessive amount of hair and products
stuck up within this r and how it has
built up so
much so what I'll do is push the hairs
out from both directions I'll be able to
go in through that split chank in the
top push it down into the ring where
I'll be able to gather it all together
with the tweezers to be able to pull
this
out it looks like the reason all of that
hair is kind of staying and clumping
together within the ring is more than
likely due to all the other product that
she comes into contact with through
being a hairdresser like styling creams
and conditioners and everything that
she's using because as I'm pulling out
these hairs they are really like gunked
and caked together it's not just loose
strands of hair they are all compacted
together not only has it gotten caught
up in the openings where it's actually
visible while it's on her hand but as
well as the part of the Ring that's
called the undercarriage so that opening
up underneath between the actual setting
and your finger
has become completely caked up as
well so with the amethyst ring one thing
that I do have to be cautious about is
being a little bit more precise with
using the tweezers or using the needle
versus on a diamond ring is the amethyst
is a bit of a softer Stone so I just
want to make sure that I'm not rubbing
this metal up against the stone to risk
scratching
it with this this amethyst ring in the
way that it's set down into the metal it
doesn't leave much of the stone exposed
up to the top which means there is a lot
of space for things to build up within
this ring it wasn't until I took the
needle actually around the inside
crevices of the ring that I noticed all
of the hair that was coming out of
it so I start with using a toothbrush to
remove the rest of the debris caught up
in the ring and then I realized that I
can't quite get into those tighter
spaces within the ring so I grab a
jewelry cleaning brush which actually
just has really fine hairlike bristles
that make it a lot easier to be able to
get into those tight spaces after
checking all the stones and pulling out
all the debris I take it over to our
polishing wheel the abrasive powders
that are in that compound is what will
actually work to remove all of those
surface scratches and leave the ring
with a nice shiny finish so after
polishing it there's a lot of the
remaining Compound on the ring so that
is when I'll bring it over to the
Ultrasonic Cleaner the solution that's
used in the ultrasonic it's mostly water
then just mixed with a mild alkaline
type solution that helps break down the
Polishing Compound that's on there as
well as any other buildup that's on the
ring the alkaline solution is gentle
enough to be used on the precious metals
like the silver gold but it's power ful
enough to be able to break down that
Polishing Compound as well as shampoos
conditioners lotions soaps other things
that are built up onto jewelry since the
ultrasonic solution is so hot I am using
a pair of tongs to both place the ring
in there and pull it out of the solution
as well what really helps clean them in
the ultrasonic is not only the high heat
of it but also the tiny sound waves or
vibrations that go through the liquid
which is what helps break down all of
the residue on the ring by removing a
lot of the buildup before actually
putting it into the ultrasonic saves
time from it having to soak in there
leaving it in there for extended periods
of time can actually cause the stones to
come loose with the diamond engagement
ring I let this one soak for about 3 to
minutes since it's not quite as durable
with high heat I only let this one soak
in there for about a
minute
so now to finish off I'll bring the
Rings over to our steamer which is just
High pressured extremely hot water which
is used to get off any of those last
little bits of hair in this case or any
other debris that either myself or the
ultrasonic missed out
on one thing that can happen when you do
have a lot of buildups stuck in a ring
is that can actually act like a glue
just because we don't want that pressure
to be so high that it is able to p push
out those stones and have them falling
out so a few tips that I have for
keeping your rings looking good in
between professional cleanings would be
to make sure that you're removing them
anytime you're doing things such as
cooking gardening applying lotions
getting into the shower washing your
hands so one thing that I do recommend
is bringing your jewelry in to have it
professionally inspected and cleaned at
least every 6 months which is actually a
free service that we offer at all of our
Jared locations where we will check your
Stones as well as give it a deep
cleaning looking at this filthy rug it's
hard to believe it was once white the
team at Mountain rug cleaning was in for
a big surprise with this job my name is
James from Mountain rug cleaning and
today I'm going to be cleaning a rug
infested with
earthworms the rug was just completely
saturated in mud soaking wet and then on
further inspection I could see what
looked to be little maggots inside the
rug turns out it was probably earthworm
larv it was a rug that somebody didn't
want anymore so it was just discarded in
their Garden basically I just wanted to
see if I could clean it test my skills
essentially and and see you know what I
could do with
it essentially I'm just rinsing the rug
with water so it's just a high powered
hose and it's just pushing water out
onto the rug to just rinse out as much
of the of the mud as possible it's not a
pressure washer pressure washer has a
lot of power but it doesn't necessarily
shoot out a high volume of water onto
the rug and essentially what you want to
do in the beginning is just get the
water on there as quick as possible I
have a pump attached to the hose just so
it gives enough pressure and power so
it's not like trickling out really slow
slowly it it's powerful enough that you
can sort of blast the top of the the rug
and it will just sort of wash away any
sort of um surface soils from the top of
the rug you're going to be using brushes
on the rug and the water alongside with
the shampoo lubricates the rug to
prevent any kind of damage from from the
machines that you're going to be using
on it all sorts of leaves and Twix and
soil and things are just blasting up the
top of the rug as well as the earthworm
that were in there I wanted to make sure
that I got those washed off the top of
the rug because I didn't want to turn
them all up into the rug so I wanted to
make sure that I got those all off first
before I took any more
steps I'm using just a watering can with
a mixture of shampoo and um oxygen
booster in it and then I'm just using
that to just get the shampoo um
distributed over the top of the
rug so that's the Rotary machine it has
a rotating brush on the bottom of it and
that is used to essentially get the
shampoo mixed into the rug so it's
easier to then wash out I'm using a
special fiber shampoo it's quite a mild
detergent pet safe wool safe it's not
very strong it's just enough to break
down the soils in the rug and and make
it easier for you to sort of wash it all
out the oxygen booster just helps break
down the soils a lot quicker it can make
things whiter it can bring the colors
out reduce odor and yeah just
essentially make it easier if you to
remove the
stains is in the rug so it's better to
just avoid using the
bleach
it's cold water you don't want to use
hot water on rugs because they tend to
have a problem with shrinking so you
just use cold water and that just
eliminates any kind of potential
problems that you might have with
cleaning
them you then use what's called a
squeegee essentially like what you use
to clean your windows and you you scrape
off all the dirt and foam from the top
of the
rug the next step is flipping the rug
over and then cleaning the wash floor
underneath cuz a lot of the dirt and
stuff is still underneath the rug so I
think it's a good idea to just wash all
that away before you then put the rug
back on top that you've just cleaned and
then again it's pretty much exactly the
same process as as doing the front just
start off with getting getting the rug
saturated with water adding the shampoo
and an oxygen booster again and then
just cleaning back of it with the rotary
to get as many of the stains out as you
possibly
can always clean the back and the front
because when you clean the front it
pushes a lot of the dirt through into
the back and then also on the flip side
when you clean the back it then forces a
lot of the dirt and stuff which is deep
in the rug out from the opposite side if
you see what I
[Music]
mean I usually then use a crb machine on
the on the top of the rug it looks a bit
like a vacuum it's like a gray box it's
stands for Contra rotating brush head
inside it's got two brushes that revolve
in opposite directions and then as they
roll up they they sort of pull the
fibers of the rug up into the machine so
kind of gives you a much deeper clean
but it also lifts the pile of the rug
making it a bit more
fluffy I'm adding more products to the
rug to sort of break down more soils
that are still left inside you do it
until the water comes out as clear as
possible you'll never get a rug 100%
clean there will always be some dirt
inside a rug you could be using
thousands and thousands of liters of
water unnecessarily for very very little
gain so there's a point at which it's
still getting little bits out but it's
just not worth wasting so much water in
order to get it
out at that point I'm adding acidic
rinse to the rug it neutralizes all the
chemicals that you've previously used
and it helps to wash them all out it
also helps prevent cellulosic Browning
which is a process at which the natural
fibers in the rug can can turn
brown that is called a Gandy groom it's
used to remove the pattern left in the
rug but it's also to set the fibers to
help it dry
quicker I'm vacuuming out as much
moisture as I possibly can so so that's
basically a wet back and it's sucking
out the moisture and then it's going
into a tank it's quite an important
process cuz it is obviously removing a
lot of the moisture from the rug then I
put it in a centrifuge which gets about
95% of the water out of the rug you hang
the rug in a warm room with fans and a
dehumidifier and then that just gets the
last remaining bits of the moisture
out
I mean don't leave your rug in the
garden for a
start um but yeah biggest tip I've got
for taking care of your rug is is lots
of vacuuming the worst thing that
damages a rug is probably the dry soils
that in the rug for long periods of time
it kind of can wear down the rug so lots
of vacuuming and and regular beating I
didn't really feel comfortable with then
giving it on to somebody else so after
cleaned it rather than just throwing it
in the bin and wasting it I thought a
good thing to do would be to give it to
a dog shelter so that's what I
did all this accumulated algae doesn't
create a healthy environment for fish
Sam bites from Grassroots Pond and
Garden walks us through how he safely
relocates koi to dewater the pond for a
deep
clean my name is Sam Bates I'm a koi
pond specialist at Grassroots Pond and
Garden my family's business and today
I'm going to be showing you how we do a
deep cleaning on koi pons koi pons can
get pretty dirty and this is for a
number of different reasons one of which
at least here in Michigan where we are
from we have a lot of deciduous trees
that drop leaves into the pond they then
break down that organic matter can turn
the water either brown or sometimes it
helps make it green this one over here
is what we call Carpet algae it's very
very difficult to get off the bottom and
the sides of the liner but it's actually
beneficial to a pond to have the carpet
algae this typically comes with age the
carpet algae can get as long as shag
carpet and also it houses bacteria and
acts as another biological filtration
system within your pond that you didn't
even have to pay for when we are
removing koi from ponds we use what's
called a sock net it's very silky smooth
so it's very delicate on the fish and it
has two open ends which makes it easy to
hold and the fish can't escape and also
you you can release the fish through the
bottom or the backside of the net so the
fish really doesn't undergo much stress
during the transportation process when
we're cleaning koi ponds we keep the koi
goldfish frogs and such in separate
collapsible containers they hold 5 to
600 gallons of water and leaves plenty
of room for the fish to hang
out ponds that are overtaken with algae
whether it be microscopic algae which
causes green water or string algae
getting a deep clean to the very bottom
could be a good
restart this Pond here represents what
we typically will find when it comes
Springtime in time to open up a koi pond
the water is green that is the suspended
algae the ammonia breakdown from any
organic matter whether that be sadly
maybe a fish that passed away or it can
be tannins in the water which Leech from
leaves pine cone sticks anything like
that and these things should be cleaned
out really once a year
we use this hose connected to typically
a 6,000g per hour pump that we submerge
at the bottom of the pond to remove the
water now where does the water go well
it really depends on where we're at
sometimes it goes to their yard
sometimes it goes out to the road it
really all just depends some ponds only
need to get pumped out once those are
the easiest and then others it can be
anywhere from two to a dozen times when
ponds are full of gravel at the bottom
you have to rinse in between the gravel
and you'll often find a lot of mud and
debris that's hidden to your eye but we
try to remove it just because it can
still affect with water chemistry
typically when cleaning ponds we find
all sorts of stuff but the regular
things that we find are bullfrogs green
frogs toads lots of toads and we also
find dragonfly larvae
turtles in all of this muy stuff that we
find at the bottom of pond it ranges
from really a cocktail of tree leaves
sorts of needles and sticks and mostly
fish waste and it smells awful there's
really no other way to put it the
smell actually varies by Pond some
barely smell and then some make you just
want to run away but you have to go
through it and you have to get it out
this Pond was so large in surface area
with a flat bottom to where we couldn't
rinse everything to one end we're using
a squeegee to actually remove all of the
excess water and debris that is stuck in
the bottom of the pond on their carpet
[Music]
algae the rock the liner can be covered
in string
algae if your lawnmower is aiming in the
wrong direction and it's kicking grass
clippings into the pond or sometimes
even sprays like herbicides or
pesticides can raise the ammonia levels
in the pond and that can cause just a
whole world of issues causing algae and
even killing some of the pets within the
system so you get as close as you can
with the right bit on the power washer
and you remove the algae then you rinse
it to the bottom and then we use a shot
vac to clean up all of the sludge and
nasty stuff that we left at the bottom
as well as vacuuming out the skimmers
and the
filters it's important to clean out the
bottom of the filtration system because
this is where all of the heavy sludge
and fish waste particularly like to set
and stay
stagnant when refilling ponds after a
deep cleaning uh we typically just use
the client's garden hose and we will run
it until we have enough water for the
fish to be released we add the
chlorinator usually right at the
beginning and we will aate the pond to
ensure that the decorin nator has went
thoroughly through the existing water
before we release the fish we make make
sure that the water is splashing into
the pond opposed to just filling from
the bottom and staying fairly stagnant
creating those bubbles helps push that
chlorine out of the system and gas off
to make it healthy for the fish this bag
of what looks to be dirty water is
actually beneficial bacteria that helps
break down fish waste and helps with
Pond Clarity throughout the season this
is something that we add weekly and our
clients often ask what is that bag of
brown water and what's in it all I can
tell them is it's bacteria because
that's my grandfather and my father's
secret recipe for years so I can't let
you in on
[Music]
that all the gunk that can accumulate in
an iPhone speakers can cause reduced
volume but Arley pickles from ey doctor
in the UK can clear out any type of
debris to get phones working as good as
new I think the most difficult part of
cleaning an iPhone is just knowing that
you touching somebody else's Grime and
mock it's disgusting really when you
think about
it I can already see that we've got
quite a lot of GK in the ear speaker and
the speaker grills themselves so
hopefully there'll be some GK in there
to see and we can give it a real good
clean out as
well
lint builds up from inside somebody's
pocket and over time when the charging
cables inserted taken out reinserted all
that happens is it just compacts into
the charge port itself and leaves this
sort of mess behind and all this lint
over time it just compacts every time
you put it on charge it just compacts
deep down into the
port when you start noticing the Earp
can becomes quiet the microphone people
can't hear you or it's it's not charging
correctly you might have to stand on
your head and do a back flip just to
make it charge that's probably when you
need to start thinking about cleaning
out that charge port or the a
speaker I'm using this little BGA
scraper which is typically designed for
scraping the uh resin overfill or
underfill from logic boards but it
doubles up as a really really useful
tool for cleaning out these charging
[Music]
ports the stuff what usually find in the
charging ports and crevices of the phone
is mostly either Pocket Gun or fluff
from the bottom of handbags I mean I'm
not a forensic scientist but I'm going
to guess there's dog
a dust fluff I I don't really know how
to describe the
uh the fibers are in there other things
that we found in the phones rice is
quite common when phones are become
water damaged because they'll stick the
phone in rice that doesn't work work by
the way we did find some weed in one of
them and it looked like they must have
been keeping the stash in the pocket and
it the same thing again there was weed
inside the charge
port so this iPhone 7 is coming for a
battery replacement and you as you can
see it's absolutely full of dust lint
hair wood chip feathers you name it it's
in this phone well I can see that the
screen's been replaced before I think
they've probably just never replaced the
dust seal what's on there this is really
common because believe it or not not
many repair places will replace that
dust and moisture seal the best way to
clean something like this out is to get
all the thick stuff probably with the
dust
blower
there is definitely a risk that this
dust could cause a short circuit on the
on the motherboard it's going to put
lots of strain on peripheral Hardware
like the loud speaker it's going to be
quiet the vibration motor is not going
to work very well or you're going to get
funny sounds from the vibration motor a
lot of people think that it's just for
moisture it keeps a seal between the
screen and the chassis of the phone
which out of the factory is designed so
that it's sealed away from elements like
dust and
dirt ear speaker cleaning is one of the
things what we get all the time where
somebody's phone's really
quiet 10 to 20% phones what we get in
actually need cleaning
out the easiest way to clean out an
iPhone ear speaker is using some
isopropyl alcohol the customer last for
a ear speaker replacing but in reality
it just needs cleaning out and even if
we did replace the ear speaker it
probably would still be quiet because
that mesh is just bunged up and gunked
up then we loosen up the gunk with a
toothbrush make sure that it's not the
toothbrush that you've used this morning
to brush your teeth and then we play
this sound which plays a 165 htz sound
which acts as a sort of ultrasonic
cleaner for the most part I think that
the most common thing that gets in ear
speaker is probably ear
wax I don't really want to think about
what else it could be what's getting in
there because it's yeah it's
[Music]
gross
we use two different types of brushes I
for for the softer brush we use a
toothbrush and then a slightly more
stiff one is this small HSE hair brush
the vibrations act as an agitator and it
it loosens the dirt what's in those tiny
little gaps in the a
speaker so the cloth over the speaker we
add a little bit of alcohol onto there
and the way that that works is just
adding a finer lay layer of cleaning
stuff just to get any remaining bits of
dust out of
[Music]
there so for this one it's a iPhone 11
Pro and it's got a little bit of gunk in
the speaker Grill at the bottom which
would make the phone pretty quiet this
is very similar to what gets built up
inside the charge port it's just pocket
Gunk the best tool tool for this one is
the shop pointed BGA scraper
again the debris in these holes will
often look like a brownie sort of beige
color whereas the actual speakers are
black so you'll know that you've got it
in
[Music]
there
f
I sort of got involved with fixing
friends and Family's phones sorting out
technical problems for them and once I
started learning about phone repair I
just got deeper and deeper into it it's
like a rabbit hoer and just got fully
sucked down
it we received about 20 iPhones per week
in the post and we probably take in from
Walkin customers between 5 and 15 phones
a
day you get lots of instances where
somebody might bring a phone in and it
might be a minor thing and they say oh
look my phone's completely dead and it's
it's really good to see people very
happy once you've repaired their
devices
the professionals at WD detailing walk
us through how they deep clean this
abandoned car which previously belonged
to a hoarder the car was covered in
grease and garbage and infested with
bugs my name is Brent dezar I'm one half
of WD detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning an extremely dirty car that
used to belong to a hoarder who's now in
treatment when we first got this car we
actually had to leave it out outside of
our shop for over a week just to let it
air out because it was one of the worst
smelling vehicles that we've ever been
brought only because there was so much
Grime and grease in both the carpets and
the seats and there was just a ton of
garbage
everywhere the first thing we did was
use the OZO machine the OZO machine
removes air pollutants and odors while
also killing bacteria and viruses inside
the car which makes makes it a lot safer
for us to work in
there after taking the seats out the
first thing that we do is take all the
trash out and completely vacuum the car
that way we can really see what we're
working with so when you see a car in
this condition it doesn't always make
too much sense to save it but this car
was brought to us by a really really
nice gentleman named Parker he reached
out to us and told us that he wanted to
clean the car and give it away to
someone who really needed it that really
touched us so we were instantly in
as we were vacuuming we found a pile of
dead bugs that were just sitting on the
carpet right next to the back seat and
it was mixed in with some hair and just
some of the goodies when when you're
detailing disaster cars when people
leave food or anything of that sort that
starts breaking down that's when the
maggots start appearing in their cars
they vacuum up pretty easily as long as
they don't splatter all over the carpet
but but even then you can just extract
them this garbage was so stuck on we
literally could not get it off with our
hands even a power washer isn't good
enough to get it off so we'll use a
flathead screwdriver occasionally it
helps get stuff off of the surface that
we otherwise wouldn't be able
to it actually wasn't sticky or oily it
was kind of like a rough feeling like
velcro it's almost like that rough
feeling that's how how bad this carpet
was if we didn't pull the carpet out of
this car there was no possible way we
were going to get it completely clean
especially with all the stains on it you
would normally want to replace this
carpet but we were trying to keep the
budget as low as possible as per Parker
that's what he wanted to do so the
original color of this car's carpets
floor mats seats was a gray and when we
got it they were almost
black the stains in the carpet came from
I don't even know honestly we were just
assuming that it's like grease and dirt
and everything mixed
together we have this carpet brush that
will get any hairs out of the carpet
because this carpet also had what seemed
like dog hair in it as well and we got
all of that out with a vacuum and our
brush
we used a Degreaser instead of an
extractor soap only because Degreaser is
a bit
stronger and then we went ahead and dral
brushed it into start getting it to work
into the fibers of the
carpet we ended up having a power wash
and extract this carpet four
times after you spend 20 minutes on the
same stain or half an hour and you keep
working at it and you can tell that that
it's not changing color it's not coming
out anymore and there's really not that
much more you can do you know as a
detailer it's kind of time to just call
it I would say 85% of the stains and the
dirt were out of the carpet and about
15% that was just complete damage was
never going to come
out we hung it up inside of a closet
where there's a heater so we actually
had to let it dry for 2
days so dyeing the carpet was actually a
last minute decision that I ended up
making myself the first step is to spray
dye on the carpet we use a brush to
brush it into the carpet to make sure it
doesn't just sit cuz if it sits then the
carpet will become like hard bristly
texture and then you'll go back and
you'll spray over it again and then you
just let it sit and dry and that's
really it the only things you want to be
careful about are are inhaling the fumes
so we wore our respirators and because
we're in a parking garage we have a
really big exhaust fan right next to us
and we had that running the entire time
and we don't do this on normal carpets
or honestly ever but when we saw that
some of the stains weren't coming out we
wanted to make sure that this is going
to really change someone's life and
they're going to be happy when they
receive
it embedded in the seats are grease and
there was so much of it after we did the
entire extraction the first time we let
it dry overnight and we came back the
next day and it was completely covered
in grease again so everything that was
farther in the seat came to the surface
so we had to clean them a second time so
after we spray our extractor soap we'll
let the soap sit for about a minute or
two and then we'll go ahead and use the
drill brush to agitate the soap into the
fibers and then we'll clean it out with
the extractor the extractor has a little
nozzle that sprays hot water into the
fibers of the seat and then it also has
a vacuum head so as it's spraying the
water into it it's sucking the water out
at the same time that way it can clean
it we have a clear head on it so we can
actually see all of the soap all of the
dirt coming out of the seat and when
that water coming through is completely
clear that's how you know when the seat
is
clean so now we're cleaning the back
seat of the car which was also one of
the grossest parts of the car and the
first thing we did was use the tornador
to spray off any of the dirt and that is
simply just an air compressor tool that
shoots out air in a tornado formation
and that'll get a lot of the dirt out of
the deeper fibers of the
seat and then after that we'll go on to
the extracting
process
the tornado is best for getting any kind
of microparticles out of the carpet or
out of the seats and then Dust or dirt
or anything that's on like the topical
later as well so at this point we're
taking apart the center console so we
can get it out of the car and pressure
wash all of the disgusting grease and
mold and everything off of it dirt
definitely gets behind both the radio or
any of the knobs on the center console
because that's where your hands are
touching a lot so by disassembling those
things and cleaning behind them we know
that we're sanitizing and doing the best
job that we possibly can sometimes the
torador can't get things that are super
stuck on if they're gooey or anything
like that almost like a glue substance
to Plastics the air is not going to do a
good enough job so you have to scrape it
off and power wash
it
we wanted to give it a good exterior
cleaning too it did have a thick layer
of dust on the exterior the engine bay
was dirty the wheels had brake dust all
over
them surprisingly enough dirt or dust
actually acts as a protectant to paint
so when a car is Dusty or covered in a
layer of dirt it protects it from the
Sun's UV
rays
so the first thing that we do is we
spray our Degreaser all over the paint
CU it's paint safe and that'll just
start loosening up any of the dirt on
the outside and then we'll use our power
washer to get the dirt
[Music]
off
so after we wash the car we go ahead and
we spray the entire thing down with a
ceramic sealant while it's still wet and
that just gives it a little bit of
protection and also a shine after we
wash it and then we'll go ahead and
spray it down again before drying
it after we were done with it he
actually needed to take it back to his
home home shop and do some mechanical
work on it to make sure it's safe for
the people whoever owns it next we were
really happy with the result of this car
but what meant the most to us is how
Parker reacted because this was
something special to him and the fact
that we got to be a part of it is why we
did it in the first
place we do all these details absolutely
for free so we took this on because we
wanted to make a change and we wanted to
help a family that needed
it
this massive pet hair was lodged in a
dry event Aaron cotton and sfia jordano
Scott from dry event superheroes of New
Orleans show us how they deal with
extreme cases of drier vent buildup my
name is Aaron cotton and I am the owner
and operator of dry vent superheroes of
New Orleans my name is Sophia jordano
Scott I am the co-owner and business
manager of dryvent superheroes of New
Orleans today we're going to look at how
to clean out a Dusty dryer vent the main
thing that gets basically conglomerated
in the vent pipes is a lot of either
dead skin cells pet hair children's
glitter regular hair just dust dry
detergent anything that can stay and
stick on our clothes that can come off
in the
wash the worst is always going to be any
pet clinics you're cleaning towels daily
and you're not just cleaning towels but
you're cleaning towels full of pet hair
which is usually thicker and coarser and
sometimes more oily than um human hair
the metal brush not only breaks it up
but it kind of catches as well so it
caught all that hair and you can see as
I pull it out it's just almost a whole
dog that it seems like I pull out it was
literally just mounds of hardened pet
hair and lint inside all the way to the
exit and then that exit had about 4 feet
of bird's nest just compacted at that
end because there was no vent cover on
the end it was just an open tube so took
us about 2 hours to clean the vent in
entirety get everything out we scoped it
with our little camera about six times
trying to make sure we got every little
piece out of
[Music]
there as the lint just gets stuck in
there and it builds over time the Heat
can't get out so the heat just stays
there and accumulates right there and it
condenses and that's actually how a fire
will
start part of our inspection when we
first go in is to make sure is this vent
connected Ed within the wall we only use
these types of vents they are metal but
also flexible but they're the only type
of connection hose vents that can
actually contain a fire as opposed to
the foil vents if you look on the back
of your dryer most dryers will say don't
use a foil vent and most people just
don't read that warning we get behind
the dryer and we take the metal tube
that's behind the dryer and we take it
off and we inspect to make sure that uh
the inside is either dirty or clean
because you either want to clean it out
or replace it
the Second Step would be to put our rods
with the brushes into the wall with the
camera we can see inside the wall of
what's going on and customer can see as
well of either how dirty or how clean it
is you can definitely tell almost how
long it's been because if it's only been
like a year or two maybe like a little
or nothing at all but when we're getting
to like the three to 5 years or plus
you're getting literal mounds of stuff
that's coming out you know it's almost
like from a mole hill to a mountain of
stuff that you're getting out and you're
like wow it gets really gross if it's if
it's 10 plus
years so after we inspect it and see how
dirty it is then we take our brushes
with our rods so that goes inside the
wall and our drill basically just cleans
everything
out we call this the vent polisher brush
it has this metal teeth at the end so
when that goes through your vent that's
going to polish your vents as well as
clean it so it's going to make it even
harder for lint to stick in the future
when we take our helpit filter vacuum
cleaner we make sure that no dust gets
in the air for either us or the customer
to breathe
in no Cleaning Solutions or chemicals
just the the brushes and the HEPA filter
vacuum cleaner really does the
job and then once all that's done and
clean we turn towards the inside of the
dryers we uh get all the length that
might have be stuck in there we uh go
back and we take our aluminum tube here
and we put everything back from from the
wall to the dryer we do use heat safe
tape on all of our repairs or connection
hoses we do also use clamps the reason
why we use both is because you want your
dryer vent to be able to be unhooked
every year and cleaned and we push the
dryer back and then we check under the
lint trap we definitely found a lot of
weird stuff coming from the dryers
especially under the lint trap I've had
one employee as we were cleaning he
pulled out a whole silver chain I found
money uh like $5 and a couple $1 bills
and then of course we get the not so fun
stuff bird eggs and wasp nests that's
usually towards the outside of the house
not like in the dryer itself also storm
damage whenever we have a bad storm
hurricane and um something gets impacted
in the vent or the roof comes off or
something you're probably going to get
water in your vent in which case you
need a professional to come and take
that out cuz it's going to be really
nasty water mixed in with all that
land so we've had uh multiple customers
tell us I've been in this house for over
10 years I haven't even thought about
cleaning it out and they're like why are
my clothes still wet a lot of the times
it's not your dryer it's that the line
is just clogged up with all the lint and
hair and everything the most important
thing to do with keeping up your dryer
vent is definitely to get that annual
professional cleaning but um in addition
to that cleaning your lint trap with
every use is the biggest
one I would say the most satisfying is
leaving with the customers all happy and
smiling and and knowing that they're
safe uh that their house is safe and
that their product is going to work as
they want it
to this swimming pool has become overrun
with algae so much so that the bottom of
it is covered in sludge miles Laughlin
isn't afraid to go deep hi I'm miles aka
the pool guy and I'm going to show you
how I professionally clean the bottom of
a pool today I'm going to show you a few
different pools and how I clean the
bottom of the pool
Grandma's Paul definitely was the most
challenging um the sludge on the bottom
it was like six Ines of sludge like
across the whole pool it looked very
abandoned because obviously it had been
left for 15 years so that was like when
I first got into the pool obviously
there was a lot of the water had been
drained down quite a lot there but as I
stepped in it was really soft branches
may have fell off of like the the bush
that are around the pool um and then
just sort of like they could have
started growing like bigger as well
while they were in the pool as well so
so we had to shovel it into sort of
buckets and then and then someone would
put it in a wheelbarrow and then take it
down to the Heap at the end of the
garden and it just created like a
massive pile of just sludge I'd say
there was probably like a ton or maybe
two tons of sludge um so yeah get like
draining that down and uh scooping all
the flge out of that one and just the
time it took um yeah that was definitely
the the hardest one but uh we got there
in the
[Music]
end oh my God so recently I've been to a
job um and the pool has been left for
like eight years but the water weirdly
was like clear but the alga in there was
really like blanket like and there was
loads of it and you could see like I
move it around you can see it looked
like really weird like an underwater
sort of like Forest of like algae it was
like really bad um and that pole
definitely had to be um drained down
okay so when I first go to a pole and I
see that it's green what I'll do first
is get um a pull brush out and then I'll
brush the whole pool all the surfaces
disturbing all the algae off the surface
normally algae will just like break up
like you put chemicals in and you brush
the the pole um and it would just break
up into like really small particles and
then you can just like Hoover it but
like this type of algae was just like
really like stringy and just like solid
together um yeah it was a weird one um
and then again there's like sludge on
the floor with just like brushing the
sludge to like a pile and then like
scooping it
[Music]
out that pool had been left just sort of
like gone a couple of days without
chlorine and cuz it was sort of like
indoor it had like sort of like in a
greenhouse type so it got like really
hot in there when the Sun comes out and
just the algae just attached itself to
the tiles like so badly it looked like
it had been left for like years people
thought they were actually green tiles
on the steps and it was really tough on
the tiles it needed something quite
aggressive to sort of get it off and
then what I got was just like some H
chloric acid and mixed it with water and
uh sprayed it over the tiles and it just
started reacting with the um the algae
um bubbling out
um and then I started brushing it in to
disturb it all off the
surface then I've got the the hose and
start watering it down and it all clean
cleaned off come up nice and blue and
then rinsed it down and that literally
took like 15
minutes
the woman who earned the pool she didn't
she only called us to come and open the
pool in like August had like the whole
summer just sitting there doing nothing
so like we took the the cover off and
there was like mosquito ly in the pool
and there was mosquitoes like flying
everywhere literally so bad I had to
like run away from the pool and she
actually didn't want this pool emptied
she just wanted to try and get it around
with like chemicals get some chemicals
out shock and chlorine granules we used
on this one so like when I shock a pole
that basically kills off all the algae
and all the contaminants in the pole
basically what it does is combine all
the small particles and what it relies
on is like no movement in the water so
it's combining all the particles and
then they become like heavy and then
they just sink to the bottom yeah after
a few days come back and it was like uh
the water was crystal clear just all the
de I think was just on the bottom when I
came in and like just hoovered it up and
it was just Crystal Clear ready to go
sort of
[Music]
thing so if you've got an outdoor pool
you're going to want to maintain it like
once a week at least no so I get a lot
of people do say to me why don't you
drain the pool before winter but what it
is is you got to take into consideration
like the structure of the pool so if you
have no water in there if there's water
in the ground surrounding the pool it
can pressurize the walls and then cause
damage but you have to keep water in the
pole um what you do have to do is check
your pole at least like once a month and
add the correct chemicals and then when
you come to open it in summer it's going
to be nice and clear still when a
washing machine looks this dirty you
might question if it's actually getting
your clothes clean Derek Dennis from RR
appliances needs to fully disassemble
the machine to deep clean the mildew
mold and rust that's built up
inside hi I'm Derrick Dennis I
specialize in repairing and cleaning
washing machines dryers any major
appliances the two main types of washing
machines that I work on are top loaders
and front loaders I'm going to show you
how I clean
them so this topload washer is I would
say between 15 and 17 years old this
machine here hasn't been cleaned I would
say ever since it was purchased the
biggest problem with this the abundance
of buildup from you know excessive use
of detergent fabric softener all the
buildup you see that's what causes this
big ring around the top the water
doesn't come up that high that's why you
see the different levels and then you
know the buildup of mold the perfect
ideal circumstance for for mold and mil
buildup is moisture dark heat so common
buildup in these machines due to overuse
of high efficiency detergent and fabric
softener which you don't need this big
buildup you're going to get rust you're
going to get mold
mildew two tablespoons of high
efficiency detergent and no fabric
softener will make your machine last
ages longer than if you're dumping a cup
or two of fabric softener it doesn't get
your clothes any cleaner I highly
recommend cutting out fabric softener in
your laundry r
the reason that I'm so against fabric
softener is when you use fabric softener
the reason that it works is the reason
that it's bad so it builds up like an
oily residue because those enzymes have
been trapped inside your shirt and so
that's what causes it to smell so it's
not because of you but eventually the
overuse of high efficiency detergent and
fabric softener will cause your clothes
to smell even if they're clean so
anytime we maintenance the machine we
want to make sure that we're unplugging
it from any power source and it's good
to cut the water off so so generally we
start from top to the bottom the main
thing is removing the tub and cleaning
the inner and outer baskets that's where
all of your smell comes
from with these direct drive machines a
lot of times we have the legs are Rusty
and we'll either scrape them down
repaint them make sure we knock the
cobwebs out all that kind of stuff
sometimes we'll find a little baby stck
you never know we like to use
toothbrushes different um different
style brushes you have pointy brushes
flat brushes they all have different
jobs but brushes are are are very key
they're vital to everything we do so the
brushes really help to get in there and
you know kind of get in the corners and
the crevices to clean all this milde and
mold
out sometimes the pressure washer
doesn't get inside the balance ring and
we have to some bristles in there and
kind of really put some elbow grease in
it my favorite cleaner is Pine saw
bleach Lysol vineger is more of what I
recommend for people to use through a
washing cycle white distill vinegar has
acetic compounds that help kill some
bacterias when we pressure wash first we
store the outside we can get a lot
better into the balance ring a pressure
washer the water Finds Its ways into all
the crevices and it does a much better
job at pushing out all this mold and
mildew and detergent build up and fabric
softener build up all the way out the
holes in we can just rinse it out of the
inside and we have pretty much a brand
new basket so the steam cleaning comes
usually comes after the pressure washing
just because we want to get kind of a
final clean the best thing about is you
know the water comes out at a super high
temperature and that helps to
effectively sanitize any of these
crevices or cracks or anything that we
can't just clean with a pressure washer
or
bleach so with the front load of the
cleaning process it's similar but it's a
lot different in the disassembly and
just the orientation of the basket I
can't remove a basket all the way from a
front loader I can only clean the front
half the old school top loaders are
built like tanks the front loaders are
not but they clean your clothes better
they generally don't need as much
cleaning as a top loader because of the
orientation and the way the water uh
spins inside and the water actually
keeps the tubs cleaner uh the biggest
part of the smell that we see is from
pump building up lint and debris in
there and people not clean it out and
then you stay with a smell or because
people don't wipe out their uh their
door seal every time they use the
machine they keep the door closed closed
and then that just builds up a Milo
smell as long as you keep the door open
and and wipe the door seal out and you
know run a wash and a washer cleaner
tablet through once a month or so white
distilled vinegar it's not going to
smell I can guarantee it so with this
front loader it actually has a cleanout
spot for the lint this is what protects
your pump and this is what keeps helps
keep the smell down internally pull the
door down we drain the water out of this
little this is the drain hose that
actually pulls whatever water is left
inside the pump and then we take the
filter out clean it out and that's it I
recommend doing this every 30 days at
least every 6 months and this is going
to prevent odor it's going to keep the
it's going to keep your washing machine
lasting a whole lot longer the average
lifespan of pretty much any washer is
two and three years before the bearings
go out you know just because of and that
really comes from the overuse of of
detergent so when a detergent breaks
down that oil and grease it'll cause the
bearings to get rusted Rusty and then
your washing machine will sound like a
jet plane taken off that's bad bearings
it's really hard to get to if you can't
physically tear these things down and
clean them yourself so the best thing to
do is preventive maintenance 2 tspoons
of detergent no fabric softener at all
but if you have to use it make sure you
dilute it by 50% you know when I sell a
machine to somebody I want them to have
a faith that I have sold them the
cleanest used wash machine that they can
possibly
buy this soupy mess might look like a
scene from The Swamp but it's actually
the carpet of a very moldy car Brent
dezza at WD detailing demonstrates how
he and his team miraculously get it
looking as good as new my name is Brent
the chezar and I'm half of WD detailing
and today we're going to be cleaning a
super moldy car that has grass growing
in it mold water and all of the above it
was absolutely
disgusting first we put the ozone
machine inside the car it basically
pumps oxygen to the third degree into it
or ozone and it suffocates the bacteria
and kills it and then we'll pull the
seats out after we do the ozone
treatment so we can actually get to all
the the spots that we need to and then
the first thing that we'll do is vacuum
it try to get all the debris or in this
case the mold and the water out of it so
we can really get in the car and work on
it so here we're working with where all
of the water ended up going the water
was only on half of the car and I think
that's because of where the leak was
located so what you're looking at right
now is US vacuuming up all of that water
the last time that this car was plated
was in 2015 so it ended up sitting for
the last 6 years and just about 5 months
ago the owner noticed that there was an
issue with the sunroof where it wouldn't
close all the way and water was
continuously getting in there but we've
never seen anything like this
before for a car like this it's actually
recommended to remove the carpet throw
it away and replace it but for some
reason in this specific car it was
stapled down completely to the point
where if we were going to remove it it
wasn't going to go back in and sit the
way that it wouldn't need to for this
car it was definitely a different
process than when we would normally
extract a car because the carpet was
basically stained with that green mold
and we had to try to figure out a way to
push it out of the fibers of the carpet
and see if the carpet would revive to
the white color that it ended up being
so the first thing that we did which we
normally would not do is use the torn or
attachment which is compressed air that
shoots out in a circle like a tornado
almost you have like a little
compartment where you put allpurpose
cleaner in mixed with water so you
dilute it and you attach it to an air
hose on an air compressor and it really
gets into the fibers of that cloth and
kind of blows out anything that might be
in there so we blew out the entire
carpet with it after vacuuming it and
then we'll go ahead and we'll use our
extractor soap on it and spray like a
healthy amount on there and actually use
the extractor which shoots hot water
into the carpet to get the carpet a
little bit more wet because when we use
our drill brush we want to try to reduce
the amount of friction that we're
putting into the carpet because if
there's too much friction if it's not
wet enough then it can actually damage
the carpet we'll use our drill brush to
agitate all of that soap so we'll go
over it a few times get it really into
the fibers and then we'll use our hot
water extractor which only has water in
it we don't ever recommend putting any
kind of soaps or anything in your
extractor because when you're blowing
the water into the carpet you want to
suck everything out and if you have soap
in it it's just going to add more to it
and it's not going to be completely
clean I actually filled half of of shop
back full of water so I think I actually
got probably 95% to 99% of the water
out when you do the doors it's the same
thing as doing any of the other Plastics
in the car in this case we used Tri
clean which is made to kill bacteria and
all that stuff inside of cars While most
all-purpose cleaners do kill bacteria we
wanted something that is a Little Bit
Stronger especially because in this case
there's a lot more mold than you would
normally see in a regular car and then
use the tornado or attachment or some
soft bristle brushes and really get in
every nook and cranny and make sure we
clean it
out so for this part he's actually
drying off the door and getting all the
liquid out of the nooks and crannies so
that is the torado door attachment but
that's a different one than the one that
is used for specifically cleaning so
This Tornado door attachment doesn't
have the canister that holds any kind of
cleaner and this one just blows out air
so you use that to get into cracks and
crevices where you normally couldn't
with a brush or with a microfiber towel
or you use it to get under
seats when we do leather seats that have
been sitting in mold the first thing we
do with any seat is vacuum it just to
get any kind of free especially in the
crevice where the bottom and the back of
the seat meet we'll use an all-purpose
cleaner or a leather cleaner they're two
different things a leather cleaner is
more suitable for high-end leather and
then he'll spray it on there use a color
lock brush so it's like a really fine
strong brush to get into all of the
pores of the
seat when we're cleaning leather seats
we don't use too much pressure just
because you don't want to damage them
you could leave scratches you could tear
them spray it again use the steamer to
kill any bacteria and then wipe that
away
too when we do the wheels the first
thing we like to do is pressure wash
them off and get any of that initial
dirt or grime off of them we have some
heavy acid that we'll use if it's really
bad but we don't use it on painted
rims and go ahead and we'll agitate it
with a brush and we'll use a few
different brushes to really get in both
the wheel well on the tire inside the
rim in the drum of the rim and then
we'll go ahead and pressure wash it
away so for the exterior because it had
been sitting out for so long over time
if you don't clean it Grime will get
attached to the paint and start growing
mold because we did the exterior of the
car first we weren't too worried about
water getting in since it was already
full of water so we just went ahead and
we pressure washed everything out we put
paint safe de Greaser all over the paint
because it just had a really thick layer
of both mold and Grime on it that
wouldn't just come off with an initial
pressure wash we let it sit for about 2
to 3 minutes and then we pressure washed
it again and then we'll go ahead and
we'll use the foam Cannon so the foam is
just a car soap and you just put it into
a foam Cannon and you attach it to your
pressure washer it acts as a lubricant
for any dirt that's on the car so when
you go to wash it you're really
minimizing how much scratching can
happen to the paint and then we'll go
ahead and we'll use our microfiber mits
to wash it and then spray it off
the absolute best way to store a car if
it's going to be outside is with some
sort of car cover or a tarp that way no
water is going to get on the top of the
car and find its way into the car it'll
keep the Paint clean and away from all
the elements if it's going to be a car
that you're not driving for extended
periods of time you still want to look
in it and make sure nothing's going
wrong because seals can give and if they
do and water starts getting in then
that's a whole world of problem so the
best way to stop mold is to be proactive
and check on your car before it actually
starts
growing when it comes to detailing I
believe it's best to maybe get a full
detail once to twice a year maybe three
times I always tell people to vacuum it
if not every few weeks at least once a
month this is Mac he specializes in
cleaning the homes of people with
hoarding disorder and is used to waiting
through heaping piles of
clutter but this job presents an
unusually large challenge ma will be
cleaning a six-bedroom home in Illinois
and it's the biggest he's ever tackled
this is just a
nightmare uh I we're fighing food from
2013 we've got paint cans that I no
longer have the strength to
carry MAC often cleans solo and does
much of this work free of charge but
this job is so daunting that he's
invited two other cleaners to join him
over the next 3 days they'll work
together to to declutter and clean as
many rooms as
possible normally uh I'm dealing with a
totally different type of cleaning in
other hoarder houses I'm dealing with a
lot of insects and mouse droppings and
pet urine and just a lot of stuff that
you definitely want to have PPE on in
order to even enter the house this one
was just piles upon piles of stuff it's
the most stuff that I've ever taken out
of a
house
this house belongs to a family of four
who declined to appear on camera due to
privacy reasons one of the family
members is believed to be living with
hoarding disorder although he's awaiting
an official diagnosis but even with
treatment experts say relapses can occur
this is the fourth time cleaners have
worked extensively to declutter this
home the last attempt was 5 years
ago rooms in hoarder houses we will
often find rooms that have never been
entered in a decade and one of the
reasons that happens and it's really
common is you have a room that no longer
has a purpose so in this room it's the
living room and the purpose is to watch
TV and to relax if a room loses that
purpose because they start piling things
up then the purpose of the room becomes
this is where we throw all of our stuff
this place is not what I'd consider a
hazard or a biohazard it's a hazard for
tripping and it's a hazard for fire cuz
they've got an open fireplace in here
and they've got so much clutter that it
becomes a danger hoarding is defined as
persistant difficulty discarding or
parting with possessions regardless of
their actual value it's estimated that
somewhere between 2 and 4% of the
worldwide population have hoarding
disorder it's only day one of this
ambitious project but when Mack and his
team arrive at the house they discover
things already aren't going as planned
so they have clean a bunch of stuff
before we got here which normally I
wouldn't like I wanted the big mess and
I wanted to be able to go through the
whole house and make it pretty myself
this is I think a 30 yard dumpster they
filled two of these already over the top
and we're getting ready to fill the
third one if we had more time we would
probably fill 10 of these from this
house so even though I'm a little
disappointed I'm really thankful that
they did have the help Mac and his team
plan to stop on what's typically the
hardest room to clean the kitchen
they'll need to pay special attention to
this space to ensure it's sanitary
enough for handling
food then they'll move on to the rooms
on the main level of the house and
finally tackle the basement which hasn't
been entered in 3 years the key tools
Mac and his team use are an emulsifier
to cut through grease a homemade
allpurpose cleaner scouring pads and
razor blade
scrapers so when people people asking
why this job takes so long because we
have to check everything like if it's
expired or not or still good
no I'm going to get you okay no a big no
for the old
pancakes
no beer we never waste any beer
no holy crap that was a lot
yeah that's pushing an easy 200
lb Max says the biggest challenge of
cleaning a house like this is knowing
what to keep and what to throw
away there are a lot of people who will
say you're fine to throw away absolutely
everything but they don't really mean
that they mean you can throw away the
junk but you have to decipher what's
junk and what's not there's also the
urge to throw away large armfuls of
stuff and most of the time there's going
to be some stuff underneath that that's
important all right I got one counter
done I'm done beautiful back to the
hotel although cleaning the home will
make it safer and more livable it can be
distressing for people with hoarding
disorder to see their space transformed
people who hoard tend to have a deep
connection with their objects and
removing them can create an experience
of loss which is one of the major
contributors of hoarding behaviors he's
going to come home to a very very
dramatic change and it's going to be a
shock to him and even though most people
will come home and see the change and
think oh my God this is so great you've
cleaned my house he's probably not going
to feel that
way as day one comes to a close Mac and
the team have finished most of the
kitchen which they will continue to
clean for the next 2 days
on day two Barbie and Bonnie will also
tackle the sun room and living room
while Mac Ventures into the
basement I'm going to go down to that
basement and do as much as I can on the
basement today and that is going to
completely wear me out if I can get that
out of the way today then that means
tomorrow we can do things like the
dining room and uh get this floor
done
I'm going to attempt to tackle this area
this whole area there's this part of the
basement there is a room to my left and
there's a room over here and they all
look like what's behind me this is going
to be extremely difficult because there
is a lot of things that need to be kept
Mac discovers an abundance of stockpiled
food and supplies including countless
jugs of water jars of marinara sauce
bottles of hydrogen peroxide and 5
gallon containers filled with something
unusual all these 5 gallon buckets those
are all filled with
food yeah I thought they were pain kind
like that one says macaroni and
spaghetti or something so I'm just going
to stack them all together and they want
to keep you think it's still good
probably not people can inherit
characteristics from their parents that
make them more likely to develop
hoarding behaviors grief and loss can
also contribute to this over the years
Mac has noticed patterns in the kinds of
items he finds while cleaning they Stack
Up air filters and medication and
antibiotics and hydrant cide and alcohol
and all of them are unopened and all of
them are there just in case and they
just keep building and building as Mac
continues sorting through jugs of water
and medical supplies he stumbles on one
item in particular he's learned to never
throw away I've thrown away shells twice
and in both occasions people were like
have you seen a big bag of shells that
was one went to Myrtle Beach or Florida
or whatever on a family trip but they're
never displayed as a collection they're
just stuffed in a bag in some random
spot but I've learned over time that
shells are always a momento for somebody
unless they got their house Infested by
clams in which case they're good go much
of what Mac finds in the basement needs
to be lugged upstairs to the dumpsters
and so many trips up and down the stairs
with heavy bags is starting to take its
toll right now my neck is just throbbing
and my right arm I'm pretty sure is
injured I have to be super careful today
on what I lift and how I lift it and how
much I lift it's a little scary because
uh if I tweak my back anymore I'm out of
the picture and I don't want that to
happen back upstairs Barbie and Bonnie
are finishing the kitchen and starting
on the living room and the sun
room I wish I had time to clean all of
this
but priorities
the owner used to sit out in the sun
room every morning and to have you know
scrambled eggs and toast and coffee and
just she likes to bead and I like
knowing those details about the owner
because it lets us know where
emotionally this cleanup is going to
affect them in a positive way as the
crew begins to wrap up for the day the
wife of the person suspected to be
living with hoarding disorder becomes
emotional at the sight of the progress
they've made she was on the second floor
of the house looking over the banister
and just seeing what Barbie had
accomplished and she wasn't even fully
done with the room uh she broke down in
tears just being able to see the floor
again so if your partner has boarding
disorder there is a resentment and a
frustration and an anger that builds up
and then finally there's a release point
where everything just comes out and
that's what happened there she's um very
happy to see it opened up up uh she's
been in the house for 13 years today's
work was way more exhausting than
yesterday it's a different type of
cleaning though because it's less it
takes less of your mind to do it I guess
I'm not really looking at having to
sanitize and to get out tiny little
stains I'm just looking to get things
out of people's way and so it takes less
mental effort but man it takes a lot
more physical
effort It's the final day of the crew's
3-day cleanup and this is the their last
chance to organize and declutter as much
of the main floor as possible this is
the day where we have to be basically on
our game and moving quickly we're
wrapping up the kitchen we have a dining
room which is just stuff that needs to
be
moved despite the exhaustion Mac is
experiencing he returns to the basement
and makes another
Discovery God it's like old rotten
garden
seeds and uh
they're not dangerous but they smell
really bad garden seeds when they go bad
smell like raw suwage you have to
breathe through your mouth when you're
putting it in otherwise it'll it'll make
you
nauseous you'll be able to see the story
unfold as you go through layer after
layer of old stuff the deeper you go
into a horde that's where you start
finding the really rotten stuff and so
it always gets worse before it gets
better excessive acquisition occurs in
the vast majority of cases
often times these items are on sale and
therefore are bought in large
amounts so instead of just getting one
they see the deal and they'll get 20 but
there's even in a big house like this
there's not room to put them all so
you've got this giant pile of shop
lights and you're probably going to find
that with everything from craft supplies
to just random kind of
stuff Night Lights there's an entire
rack of Night Lights what's really
frustrating about this is there's so
much stuff that's necessary and has
legitimate actual use that's actually
real really rare for a hoarder house at
the end of day three the crew has
successfully cleaned the kitchen sun
room living room dining room and
basement and they've removed enough
stuff to fill three 30 yard dumpsters to
the brim we're almost done now compared
to other hoarder houses it's just me
with three of us working here in order
to get the entire house every single
room top to bottom clean we would have
needed a crew of probably 10 plus people
for at least 2 weeks after Mack and his
team leave the family will finish
cleaning the remaining rooms they'll
also hire help to maintain the home I
like seeing a house that is so covered
up with stuff that whenever you get all
of it put away and where it goes and you
get everything cleaned up seeing the
house as it was intended to be seen is
really a cool thing to me and I think
that's part of my my brain that thinks
of rooms like jigsaw puzzles but what
keeps me doing it I think is more the
stress relief that you see happen on the
owner of the house you can see the
stress come off of them at the very end
whenever you leave this one was just
exhausting in every measure just because
of the sheer amount of stuff but it's
it's worth it especially whenever we get
to look around the house and see holy
crap we did that we all did
that earwax removal is best left to
professionals like Connor Boland an
audiologist and earwax removal expert at
Durham hearing Specialists he
demonstrates the tools and techniques he
uses to remove debris from a patient's
ear canal
[Music]
now my name's Connor I'm an audiologist
and I'm expert in ears and today I'm
going to show you some earwax removal
videos there is liquidy soupy ear wax
hard brick-like ear wax and a particular
fungus called ASP regillus niga earwax
is roughly half skin a little bit of
sebum which is like a fatty oily
substance and something very special
called camonis secretion and camonis
glands secrete this kind of sweaty
liquid but it's got special molecules in
it which fight bacteria and and try and
keep your ears safe you only ever need
to remove your ear wax if it's bothering
you so if you have hearing loss or your
ears feeling full or uncomfortable or
you feel like there's an obvious
blockage or pressure that is abnormal
and you should go and see your doctor or
audiologist or practice
nurse so this is something I would
describe as sort of the superp kind of
Quagmire type wax so you can see
actually that the debris has sort of a
texture to it like a wavy texture and
wavy lines in it so that means that it's
basically dead skin that's sort of
emulsified and it's been treated
essentially with fizzy drops so sodium
bicar ear drops probably and what that
does is it makes the debris liquefy and
then and then slide further down the ear
canal and then against the drum and that
really does cause quite a significant
hearing loss and feeling of discomfort
and what's happened here is that it's
kind of lost a little bit of its
structure which is quite difficult to
deal with because usually this type of
ear wax is quite resistant to
suction the machine I'm using is called
a Guardian Project basically you have a
tank is that hurting and you have to
fill that tank with water which should
be body temperature about 37° C and if
it's too hot or too cold then it will
induce a caloric effect which is where
basically you're heating or cooling the
fluid inside your inner ear and that
causes unpleasant vertigo which is like
a spinning dizziness like you're drunk
so you put it the instrument in the ear
canal and you aim the water at the roof
of the ear canal so never straight down
the ear never aim it at the eard drum
and that's really when accidents happen
potentially perforation of the eard drum
so you aim it at the roof of the a canal
and you sort of move it like a sort of
window washer and what that does is it
creates these sort of vortices and the
water and a gentle sort of swelling
effect sort of goes into the ear and
then flushes straight back out into the
cup so it's on the lowest setting and
it's just kind of squirting into the ear
and we just kind of leave it there and
let the water do the work you know most
people find it quite
[Music]
Pleasant there's a little bit of debris
or or slime left on the eardrum in that
situation we probably go in with suction
or maybe continue the irrigation for you
know for a little bit longer if the
patient can tolerate it you'll
definitely want to have some ear wax
left in there certainly not you know up
against the drum or anywhere near the
eardrum so a nice smearing or slick of
wax around the ear canal will leave the
patient protected against the ear drying
out protected against infection itching
and obviously protection against foreign
bodies as well so that's a pretty nice
looking eard drum right
there when I first saw it I thought oh
this will be an easy job because you
know the wax is right there you can see
it with your naked eye so it's all good
but then as soon as I tapped on it with
the probe I thought right we're in for a
heavy ride here the only way I can
describe it is sort of really like a
brick it was extremely tough and I
started with the suction but you know
that was for all intense and purposes
pointless so in this particular case I
used something called a corthorn hook
number six and it's basically a very
very very small metal right angle
essentially the end is perhaps a little
pointy but it's not needle
sharp this was extremely impacted the
reason it's dark dark much darker than
the previous cases because it's old the
older the wax is the darker it is and
that's because it
oxidizes I try to be very very gentle
the corthorn hook is small enough such
that you can kind of get the hook around
the debris and sort of disturb it and
sort of Leverage it out so really to put
it bluntly digging it out with a metal
instrument was was the only way really
you tend to find with this very hard
impacted sort of brick-like wax that you
can have pain as well when the patient
tries to self treat with water-based
drops the plug will actually expand a
little bit so it'll absorb some of those
drops and then and then increase in size
temporarily and if the plug is very deep
in the air Canal that can really really
hurt and cause a tremendous
[Music]
ache the thing is you always have to go
in stages because if you shove the hook
in and then pull just in one go you can
cause bar aot trauma which is basically
damaged bya pressure and that is
excruciatingly painful so you really
have to go very very carefully and tread
[Music]
lightly what we can see here is the the
sort of yellow Frills that are coming
off the main plug that that's just dead
skin when we see an impacted plug like
this there's usually uh you know sheets
and sheets of dead skin enveloping it
sort of like like a lasagna basically
and then the sort of darker brown bit
that's very very dense dry hard ear wax
which is just formed over a long period
of
time it's impossible to say how old it
is but but yeah it's it it's definitely
been in there a
while the scientific name for it the
particular fungus is called ASP regillus
niga the Casual name for it is black
mold ASP regillus Niger lives everywhere
it wouldn't be a shock for me if there
was some you know on your hand right now
or on your desk it's very common so the
likelihood is it was either in the ear
already or it was on a fingernail or
under a fingernail and the patient
scratched their ear the reason that's
got out of control is anyone's
guess so for this I'm using a suction
probe to get the debris out of the ear
and really what I wanted to do was
remove the the bed of the fungus the
melum and that's why you'll see this
white clothy material with the sort of
Goo underneath it that's the very thick
welldeveloped rooting part of the fungus
on the eardrum which is risky to some
degree because that's the kind of
situation where you can see a
perforation and you usually what we tend
to find is that patients who have these
very welldeveloped fungal infections is
more often than not because they've used
a lot of antibiotic
eardrops the reason why it's bad to use
antibiotic eardrops when you don't need
it is because you're disrupting the
Natural Balance of of microorganisms in
your ear and if you kill off all the
good bacteria then the fungus has gone
hey this is a party and grown
unchallenged I couldn't get all of the
melum out because it was sort of round
the bend and it was in a very very
awkward position but uh I achieved most
of what I wanted to which was to expose
a nice healthy eardrum and then of
course that paved the way for the
antifungal drops to do their
job this advice cannot be said enough if
your ear isn't bothering you don't poke
it don't prod it don't treat it with
anything don't put anything in it and
just leave it be most people will you
know maybe have an ear wax blockage
maybe once or twice or three times in
their lives but it's it's not something
that you need to keep on top of
regularly because your ears are
self-cleaning and they will usually take
care of
themselves grease straps keep used
cooking oil from clogging up a
restaurant's pipes but who cleans the
grease traps themselves Maurice
Patterson and the folks at MMP
Environmental Solutions tackle the
grease head on my name is Maurice
Patterson I'm the owner and operator of
M&P Environmental Solutions we are a
commercial grease trap cleaning service
and waste management company and today
we will be cleaning a commercial grease
trap in a Mediterranean
restaurant the function of a grease trap
is to prevent any solids fast oil and
greases from dishwasher or dishwashing
sinks from entering your piping
system so the cleaning process typically
starts with me inspecting it making sure
it's functional typically you want to
clean your Grease trap about every 3
months I would say that it hasn't been
service most likely close to a year then
we unplug the grease straap and we start
to remove all the
components from that step we will
prepare them to be cleaned with the
pressure
washer so right here we're doing our
pump out we have the wand connected to
the high power vacuum pump we'll use the
wand to pump out the entire grease trap
so as you can see there's a lot of
greasing on top of the grease trrap and
you can get a glimpse of solids that
have floated to the top as well for
Mediterranean restaurants you're going
to get a lot of oils cheeses you're also
going to get a lot of rice the rice is
usually the main contents that sink to
the bottom of the greas trrap that
you're going to want to pump out
regularly I would describe it as yellow
grease yellow grease is typically grease
that's used to make fries things like
that there's actually two different
types of Grease known in the industry
you have brown Grease that's typically
grease that's scraped off from pots and
pans that traveled down into your
dishwasher and your sink down to your
grease trp and then you also have yellow
grease you can actually sell it certain
places they may recycle that grease and
turn it into biofuel things like that
it's considered Liquid Gold some
companies will I'll actually pay them
for it so they're incentivized to make
sure that it's not going down the
drain here what I'm using is a putty
knife I'm scraping just old food waste
that has collected on there
organic waste just turns black over time
it's oxidized and turns black it's a
health risk mainly because any type of
overflows from your grease strap may
come in contact with
food we use a pressure washer just to
make sure we're getting all the residual
solids cleaned
out I'm using steel wool just to do a
final scrub down make sure I'm getting
into all the nooks and crannies all the
tight
spaces I do this right before we do a
final spray down with the brush
washer so we dispose of the grease at a
water pollution control facility that
will accept the fast oil and grease and
there's not many places that do accept
it so it's limited did but you know we
dispose of it in an environmentally
responsible
way when grease goes down the drain with
the dish water it's typically hot so
grease or Oils when they're hot they're
liquefied when they cool down they
solidify in the drain that may cause
plugging which will in turn cause
backups overflows if it negatively
impacts the sewer system then they can
incur fines they will have to buy a new
grease trap or or pay Plumbing fees to
rectify the
problems clocked gutters can pose a
serious threat to a home's foundation so
it's crucial to clean them regularly
Broden Hill and The Gutter Guys
recommend at least two deep cleanings a
year to prevent damage caused by debris
I'm Broden and I own a business in
Connecticut called The Gutter Guys today
I'm going to show you how to clean
gutters with wet and dry
debris
[Music]
so when we clean a gutter with wet
debris nine times out of 10 we want to
clean it by hand the reason why is when
it's wet it typically is very muddy and
there's a lot of what we call shingle
dust or grit in the gutters and it's
literally a mud and when we blow them
when they are wet it makes a muddy mess
all over the house we want to clean them
by hand for that reason
so that is a gutter that is completely
jammed with leaves and debris and the
down spout was completely covered when
we released the debris out of the down
spout and got that gutter cleaned all of
that rain water that was in the gutter
just started to flow very heavily right
down the down spout as it
should so often times when we do a
gutter cleaning not only do we find
leaves but we find plants so big that we
actually call them trees sometimes
growing right out of a gutter we're
actually pulling out a big plant and you
can see the whole root system come right
out with
it certain types of trees give off these
little things that come off the tree and
will grow another tree and when those
land in the gutter it's a perfect
environment for that to grow it's a
classic sign that your gutters have not
been cleaned in years it also puts a
significant amount of weight from the
whole root system growing in the gutter
on the gutter which in turn will pull
that gutter off of the facia board which
is actually the board behind the gutter
that the gutter is mounted
to wet debris is usually just saturated
with water water will overflow at The
Gutter and get into your basement and
create cracks in your foundation once
water does find its way into your
basement it reeks half
here the water that's flowing out of the
down spout at the bottom is the end
result that we are looking for so that
water will flow down and out as it
properly
should when we see dry debris the reason
why that debris is dry is because there
has not been any rain in the past I
would say week or so so when we clean a
gutter that has dry debris of often
times we will use a hand blower and blow
those gutters out because it does a
really good job of just getting
everything out of the gutter whether it
be leaves or sticks or curly stuff that
comes off in the spring depending on the
pitch of the roof we will get on that
roof start our hand blower and walk
across that roof line hand blowing out
all of the debris out of that
gutter sometimes the debris is very
Compact and it's thick That's a classic
sign of maybe a couple years that
somebody had not had their gutters
cleaned we stick to one type of ladder
and that's an aluminum ladder the
aluminum ladder does conduct electricity
so it's very important we stay away from
power lines when we are moving aluminum
ladders we could get severely
electrocuted it's certainly deadly which
is why we Mark the power line areas with
flags before we start a gutter cleaning
because you're looking where you're
walking so you don't look up to see the
power lines so it's very important for
us to have a reminder that power lines
are there we will often drop a penny
down the down spout just to know that
that down spouts free and clear because
we can see and hear it go all the way
through and back out at the bottom and
we know that we're in good
shape the best advice I can give a
homeowner is to be proactive and not
reactive typically when you're reactive
it's too late damage has been done the
water may already be in your basement it
may already be in your home and and it's
just not a good way to maintain your
house water is seriously detrimental to
your house and the main cause of water
is from your gutters so if you keep the
gutters free and clear and you do
consistent cleaning whether it be two or
three times per year which we recommend
you will never have any issues with
water in your basement or ruining your
flower beds or rotting out the fascia
and sofits of your home just stay on top
of gutter cleaning
this is the inside of a restaurant
kitchen's exhaust duct where thick
layers of Grease can accumulate over
time and become a fire or health hazard
that's where Jay Lopez and his team of
experts at Kleenex step in to Target
these full kitchen deep
cleans my name is Jay Lopez and I'm the
owner of
Kleenex today I'm going to be walking
you through how we clean a kitchen
exhaust system in a restaurant the purp
purpose of a kitchen exhaust system is
to extract the fumes from a kitchen in a
commercial setting in order to remove
grease you have to understand Grease
what holds the oil together is the fat
and once the first layer it's up it
becomes a magnet and it attracts more
and more and
more everything is clean from top to
bottom you will start cleaning the fan
first we're using a high-end degreaser
with a little pottassium hydroxide and
sodium hydroxide those two chemicals
combined create miracles in destroying
the fat and the grease in our case we
time it somewhere between 10 to 15
minutes once we see that the grease
starts to melt at that point we know we
need to apply hot water and remove it
cuz anything longer at that point is
going to start to destroy the
metal once the fan has been cleaned the
next step would be the thought that's
the part that connects the fan to the
hood this level is considered extreme
that was a fire waiting to happen I
would say this is about a year worth of
Grease it all depends on the volume of
cooking if this is a moderate cooking
this is about a Year's worth of Grease
that's a
lot the dock is clean in a few different
steps during this process we use a tool
made by Guardian this tool is known as
the easy magnetic duct scraper it has
magnets set into the tool and a razor
blade on each
side once it's clinged to the dock it is
manually moved forward and backwards
until the grease is removed this forward
and backward method assures that the
grease buildup will be removed from both
sides it'll go from the yellow color all
the way into the black when it's in the
Black Level that's an extreme level that
means that the system has not been
properly
maintained in these types of designs
we'll use duck Spinners and duck brushes
duck spinner is designed to self rotate
within a protective cage and spray water
at high speed which this Lodge buildup
from the metal
duck we use a combination of a foaming
agent and a Degreaser the foam is is
used as a delivering agent and allows
the Degreaser to stay in contact with
the grease for a longer period if foone
would not used the Degreaser would drip
off the
grease The Next Step would be the put
and the filters see the filters are your
first line of defense what the filters
is doing is holding back heat and it's
holding back most of that grease when
the filters no longer hold the grease
and once that grease starts getting heat
and melting you have the potential of
that grease dropping into your food and
at that point it's a health issue I've
seen restaurants been shut down by the
health department for not cleaning their
Hood I've seen restaurants been shut
down by the fire marshal for not
maintaining their
hoods we take precaution and protecting
the area from contamination we use two
layers of plastic sheeting in order to
to protect the appliances from coming in
contact with any chemical the second
layer of plastic sheeting is wrapped
around the hood and then a funnel is
created the funnel is used to drain the
chemical grease and water into the
plastic
containers the plastic sheeting also
serves as a protective barrier in
preventing the chemical from coming in
contact with the food preparation
area one once we're completed and the
plastic sheeting is removed we'll
conduct a fresh water wipe down and
recommend to the client that they do the
same prior to preparing any
food according to NFPA 96 which is the
agency that regulates this industry the
frequency of cleanings depends on the
style of cooking you're conducting and
the frequency of cooking for example if
you cook with solid fuel solid fuel is
basically cook with charcoal those are
30-day mandatory cleanings because they
produce a lot more grease and the ambers
that come from the silent fuel can
ignite the grease if you're an
occasional cooking facility those would
be a
year a cliff may not seem like the type
of thing that needs routine cleaning but
the trails at Devil's whole state park
must be meticulously maintained to keep
visitors to the iagra region safe these
daring professionals dangle from Cliff
sides to get the job
done this Jagged sheet of rock is
hanging 200 ft above a walking trail
next to the Niagara
River it's already loose and if it falls
it could mean Serious injury to hikers
on the path
below that's where the Rope access team
comes in if they do their job just right
most of Niagara Falls 9 million yearly
visitors will never even know they were
here first jump of the
day am I scared am I scared I have a
healthy respect that's
all this Cliff is located at Devil's
whole state park roughly 4 miles north
of Niagara Falls team members like Andy
and Christian will scale the the cliff
and maintain the crew's gear later Jake
will clear dislodged rocks from the
trail those rocks were to fall naturally
there's nothing stopping them from
coming and just plowing through somebody
that's on the trail so very necessary
work what we do here and you can see
here all the rocks that come down they
are pretty sizable C some damage it's a
dangerous job dehydration injury and
inclement weather are just some of the
risks thunderstorms are forecast today
so the team is on high alert for signs
of lightning which would endanger the
crew we won't work in lightning that's
about
it we're going to have fun you know
usually when we show this to people they
say they didn't even know this existed
there are 12 members of today's crew
four supervisors including Andy and
eight
technicians today their goal is to clear
this entire section of the cliff their
day begins at 700 a.m. at the
maintenance shop where the team packs of
AR of gear into vehicles to take it to
the access point above the trail see the
fun thing about this is that I don't
actually jump with them every day so
today will be uh one of the days I jump
with them which is good cuz I've been
wanting to do this for a while these are
the guys who who do it every single day
and they're really really good at
it after a short 10-minute Drive the
team arrives at the access point and
begins gearing
up I guess we can start with the p
resistance
this is our climbing harness it's a
class three harness um and it's called
that because of the shoulder straps the
shoulder straps prevent climbers from
slipping out of the harness if they
accidentally turn upside down and the
seat balances their body weight so that
blood flow to their legs isn't
restricted Comfort is also of the utmost
importance as climbers can be suspended
for more than 2 hours at a
time this device here is our bar rack
this is what we use to repel it's a
pretty old school
device we have a lot of mud and and grit
and when the ropes get wet they swell so
there's not a lot of moving Parts it's
all friction so that's our descent
device all
right pretty much all ready to go here
no one cares about me everyone says Andy
just take care of
yourself so what they're talking about
is some some guys have a uh a ROP pandel
watching their line and then some of us
are on what we call an ASAP which is
this this is your backup device and so
I'm just fuling control of all of my my
my descent so I can actually step over
the edge
now first jump of the
day am I scared yes am I scared I have a
healthy respect that's
all the crew is really close you know we
joke around a lot but when it is time to
actually go over the edge and do work
you know we kind of call that game time
because it is you know you need to take
it seriously because there's a lot of
risks involved this program that we're
part of is been going on since about the
1930s and about the whole time they've
been using pipe Poes there's a lot of
utility with this this is made out of
solid fiberglass here so if it gets into
the the cliff this can Flex a lot um you
can use this to position yourself on the
wall and then you can use this to you
know gently remove debris you know you
can grab stuff with the hook gently pull
it out it can fit into cracks and then
you can get leverage that
way one of the things that makes
removing these rocks especially
challenging is that these Cliffs undergo
something called differential erosion
which means that areas of the cliff
erode at different rates layers of shale
rock located lower on the cliff side
wear away more quickly than the layer of
dolomite rock at the top that leaves
large unstable chunks of rock sometimes
the size of an SUV hanging at the
Cliff's Edge the crew uses a controlled
swing to gain access to material beneath
overhangs to do this they push
themselves away from the wall with their
feet to maintain that controlled
[Music]
movement these are softball shin pads
and they work really really well for
what we do you try not to knee the wall
but sometimes for stability purposes you
know you you can't really help it we all
try to wear steel toe or some sort of
composite toe the rocks are hard you
know you can't always Dodge a rock when
you're moving so you know having
something like that to keep yourself
safe is is 100% is
necessary so all the Rocks they're
knocking down are essentially coming
right to the trail and then some and
they're going right to the niagar river
which we have right de below
us it's 10: a.m. the crew is only about
2/3 of the way through their climb when
the one thing they're worried about
happens a
storm copy look like we might have a
wall yeah I'm going to head back let's
head back the crew hears Thunder and
spots lightning as they are on the cliff
side they need to stop working
immediately that will end their progress
for
today so today we actually had to cut it
short we have metal pipe PS in our hand
we got a lot of metal gear on us so we
just try to get out of there as quickly
as as we could anything that's going to
pose a hazard to the employees then we
just stopped the crew had only been
working on the 200t cliff side for for
less than an hour when the storm began
on a typical day it could take the crew
up to 3 hours to clear a whole section
when they're able to resume they'll
finish removing rocks from the lower
section of the cliff and then stabilize
the slope side with wire meshing this is
the the primary um part of our work here
that we're going to try and clear this
all out so we can essentially have an
open hiking trail here again and it's
going to take a good bit of work and a
good bit of time to get this cleared out
to be safe for us to open it again
back at the shop the crew does paperwork
and washes their gear there's actually a
lot of paperwork required with all this
stuff and then also just keeping their
gear
clean you can kind of see from my shirt
I'm I'm filthy from one junk today and
you know if this is how I look our gear
is even
worse so subie water helps break it and
like lift and dirt um using a toothbrush
too to get in there and and then using
an air compressor to spray any of the
soap and and uh dirt that's in there and
then we have a lubricant too when it's
dry to get in there and it's uh prevents
rust and
corrosion after the Rope access team has
made some progress it's time to start
clearing the rocks from the walking
paths below this is where the gorge crew
comes
[Music]
in we take care of about seven trails in
total within the gorge it's and then two
up top on the top side now we are in the
process of cleaning the trail and
rebuilding it we've already come down
cleared the loose debris off the trail
and then started staging to get ready
for the bigger jobs ahead one of those
jobs includes a specialized
stabilization technique to ensure the
slope side is
secure so down here to fix these Trails
we use game of baskets it's a 6t x 3T
Cube that is made of wire meshing and
what you do is you dig them down place
them within the trail or wherever you
need them and then you add Rock to the
inside so that the rock weighs it down a
job like this can take a week or two but
if we have a good day where we're really
rocking and getting stuff done it can be
a maybe a 3 to 4 day job at this mound
right here if all andr on Deck I'd like
to see hopefully by the end of the
summer uh we get a majority of it taken
out and then we have put in some uh
stabilization techniques to help build
the trail back up so I could definitely
see us working into the fall and if I
had to make a guess it'll probably be
open next
summer I think if you're going to do
this kind of work at the core you have
to enjoy working Outdoors you get see
special things that people don't see
plants and animals like the
landscape the work that you do it's
really hard but then you're helping keep
the park safe you make a meaningful
difference if you're just a park user
you might not even realize we were ever
there and that's kind of the
point peeling dirt from 100-year-old
cloysters is delicate work conservator
Emily Cummins demonstrates the
painstaking job of cleaning medieval
cloysters by hand i'm Emily cumins I am
the assistant objects conservator at the
Toledo Museum of Art in Toledo
Ohio I'll be walking you through how we
use a gel pus to deep clean the columns
capitals and archways in our medieval
cloy gallery which dates range from the
12th century to the 15th
century so this is the first time that
these arcades have been deep cleaned
since their accession at the to Museum
of Art almost a 100 years worth of dirt
and grime is accumulated on the surface
the Cloyster Gallery at the TMA is
composed of multiple pieces of various
cloysters they're all from Southern
France although the elements of the cloy
have been dry cleaned over time they
really hold on to the dirt and oily
Grime in the surface in those network of
pores in the upper
layers so we decided to start on the
columns because they are generally
smoother than the capitals for instance
which have um carvings that are more
three-dimensional that stick out more
into space and are therefore a little
bit more difficult to apply an even
layer of gel to first the jelling agent
is mixed with water without any other
clean ingredients added this is done so
that the jelling agent can really
hydrate as much as it needs to so we
don't have clumps in the final gel now
once the water and the gelling agent sit
together for 10 to 12 hours then we'll
add the rest of our cleaning
ingredients now in the gel we have two
cleaning ingredients one surfactant and
one soap the surfactant helps break the
interfacial tension between the grime
and the stone and the soap helps
dissolve all of the oils that are in the
grime we also use a plasticizer which
allows the dried film to be a little bit
more flexible and easier to peel off and
then finally we have a small amount of a
drying agent which helps set the film on
the surface of the stone to minimize the
amount of Dripping that we have because
we are fighting against
gravity Stone I think generally appears
to be a really robust material but it's
actually really marble and limestone in
particular the gel when it's applied to
the surface sort of uses capillary
action the water in the gel impregnated
with those cleaning ingredients is
forced into the pores of the stone and
helps break the bond between the grime
and the stone and it's sort of a
cyclical process so as more water gets
pushed into the stone that grimy water
gets pushed out and all of the dirt and
grime gets trapped in that gel film so
we apply the gel with a br brush to the
stone in a relatively thick layer as the
water evaporates from the gel the layer
shrinks so the gel is over 90% water and
so we are getting some dimensional
shrinkage and so the wet application
needs to be a little less than a qu of
an inch thick which is rather thick but
a thicker wet application will lead to
an easier dry
removal so the gel is checked
periodically as it dries to make sure
that it's drying evenly if we need to
move the fans we go ahead and do that to
make sure that the gel is sufficiently
dry for us to peel we really just check
it with our hands sort of testing the
temperature and seeing if it's um a dry
hard film or wet jelly
film so once the gel film is fully dry
we can start the mechanical removal
process to take away all of that dirt
and grime that's collected in the
gel but generally speaking we'll use
bamboo skewers to actually sort of poke
a little hole into the gel underneath it
so that we and our participants can
really start the peeling process and
it's really important that when we peel
the gel we use what's called a Shear
pull so taking a loose flap of gel and
folding it back 90° and peeling it off
that way so that it's less abrasive to
the stone once the gel is dry what we're
seeing is all of that dirt and grime
which has accumulated in the stone over
time trapped onto the surface and really
trapped within that gel so when we
remove the gel we are removing almost a
hundred years of dirt and grime with
it so after the broad sections of the
dried gel film are removed we check all
of the surfaces with ultraviolet light
we use handheld UV flashlights to check
the surfaces to see if there's any
residual ual gel film the gel feses
under UV light so that we can really
easily spot any leftover residue and
really go in strategically and remove
those
sections so once all of the surfaces are
checked with ultraviolet light and all
of that gel film is removed the final
step to really make sure that the
surfaces are cleared from all of that
cleaning solution is to use wet cloths
to actually wipe down all surfaces this
will also rehydrate any remaining gel on
the surface so that it becomes really
noticeable to the naked eye so that
anything that we missed with the UV
lights can then be
removed it's been very rewarding to see
the volunteers come together to have a
sense of community and ownership over
this really beloved space at the too
Museum of
Art the Tokyo Metro is internationally
renowned for its cleanliness even with
millions of daily commuters we went
behind the scenes to see how workers
keep it looking
pristine this is takayuki a cleaning
supervisor at the rail yard in AA he's
worked for Tokyo Metro for almost 41
years and it's his job to make sure the
trains are cleaned
thoroughly the Tokyo Metro system is
famous for being one of the cleanest
Subway systems in the
world it transports an average of about
6 million people daily and maintaining
that reputation takes both an extensive
amount of operational organization and a
ton of Manpower the cleaning staff's
approach is straightforward but
uncompromising whatever Tokyo Metro's
millions of daily passengers touch must
be cleaned today they're cleaning the
train cars at the ISA Rail Yard which
they do every 15
days the cleaners take careful measures
to ensure each nook and cranny is
cleaned then we'll head to the ginai CH
station located in one of the busiest
shopping areas in Tokyo Japan where they
clean the station top to
bottom there are 41 trains on the Tokyo
metro chioda line the team cleans 3 to
four trains a day once a train comes
into the rail yard cleaners start by
picking up any Trash they see it takes
four workers to clean the exterior it's
all done by hand and cleaners start by
hosing it down with water and then using
brushes to scrub it with
soap
if the stain does not come off with a
brush and soap then they use a pad to
scrub it
off next they rinse off all the
soap meanwhile other staffers clean the
interior it takes 10 workers and they
start at the top of the car and work
their way down to the
[Music]
bottom
the first step is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed then
they clean the luggage racks and then
the wall area they use racks and dusters
to clean each
part cleaners then tackle the floors and
start by mopping they also use sticks to
clean crevices near the entrance of each
door twice a year they wax the floors of
each train car they remove all the old
wax with a polisher and then they let it
dry once it's dry they apply two coats
of wax it takes about an hour and a half
from the time the wax is removed to the
time the new wax
dries
alt together it takes workers a little
over an hour to clean the trains inside
and out once the cleaning is complete
the kuki begins his
inspection
for
once the kuki approves the cleaning the
trains return to service ready to
transport millions of passengers all
over
again inside the ginai CH station chako
and Kenji work to clean the station
daily
Kazo has been working for Tokyo Metro
since he was 18 he got his train license
at 20 and drove trains until he was 57
he leads the team responsible for the
cleaning and security for this station
and a few others there are nine Tokyo
Metro train lines and 18 stations that
provide service to the greater Tokyo
[Music]
area
the escalator handrails are a high touch
surface within the station and Chicago
takes Extra Care to wipe the belt with
wet washcloths she wides the escalators
up and down until they are all
clean
Chicago is also responsible for the
dirtiest job of the day cleaning the two
restrooms in the ginai chy station the
main cleanings happen once a day she has
been doing this work for the past 10
years
[Music]
the first thing Chago does is check for
any large pieces of trash if there are
none she sets up a fan and leaves it on
throughout the cleaning process
efficiency is one of the key parts of
her job and the fan allows the bathroom
to dry quickly so as not to disrupt any
customers who may need to use
it
[Music]
Chicago sticks the ozone machine hose
down the toilet and turns it
on then she scrubs each toilet by hand
to make sure it's clean for the next
customer she also cleans the walls it's
important that she's using the right
tools for each space so as not to
cross-contaminate areas she uses a red
dust cloth to clean areas from the knees
down down which is called the
contamination Zone and a green one for
clean zones which are areas above the
knees such as mirrors and
sinks
ch par is also responsible for cleaning
the barrier between the platform and the
train
doors the top part is cleaned daily
while the lower part is cleaned once a
week the staff makes sure the station
platforms and walkways are clean for
customers they do cleanings with brooms
every day but they also use a machine to
clean the floors twice a month the
machine works by sprinkling water onto
the floor scrubbing with a brush and
then collecting the dirty water with a
squeegee this way there is no water left
behind and no slippery
floors Kenji also goes around daily with
a shoulder vacuum and manually vacuums
up any trash and dust he comes across
especially in hard-to-reach
areas
[Music]
Japan has a long history with cleaning
and cleanliness that persists
today
for
this bubbling mess is the result of a
blocked septic system Dominic Rosales
from Juice's septic and grease pumping
walks us through the dirty job of
clearing out clogged septic tanks I'm
Dominic Rosales I work for a
family-owned and operated Septic company
here in the Hill Country of Texas we
specialize in cleaning and maintaining
both septic and grease tra on
residential and Commercial properties
I'm going to show you how we fully
unclog and pump out a septic
system a septic tank contains everything
that exits the house through any
Wastewater pipe or drain line that
includes the sinks toilets showers
bathtubs and then what happens is over
the years sludge tends to build up and
that requires the tank to be completely
cleaned out to prevent solids from
flowing into the drain lines of the
septic system
system so here we have a septic tank
that's being clogged up by a huge
quantity of baby wipes the baby wipes
have been sitting in the septic tank for
over 7 years which was the last time the
septic tank was serviced so whenever you
look at a package that says flushable
wipes what they mean is flushable into
city sewer now I understand this can be
misleading because it does say flushable
but you need to realize that it's not
biodegradable and will remain in your
septic tank until the next septic tank
cleaning
so the first thing I look for when I
pull up to a property are the vent pipes
located on the roof those usually align
with the sewer pipes under the house
which lead to the cleanout and then the
septic tank so when we probe and hit the
tank we're able to get a rough estimate
of how deep the actual tank is and that
Echo will let us know that we're in the
right spot and that we have located the
tank and then we can start to
dig so when I open up this septic tank
lid the first thing I notice is a huge
clump of baby wipes when I'm digging up
a septic tank the first side I'm digging
up is the inlet side which contains a
majority of the sludge and that's
usually where the clog is located so the
other side of the septic tank is the
outlet side that side contains mostly
dirty water it rarely contains
solids I use my hose to try and vacuum
out the baby wipes but they're just too
thick so I have to bring out the
three-prong rake I then use the three
prong rake to pull out all the baby
wipes inside of the septic tank bag them
up and then dispose of them at the local
Wastewater Plant along with the septic
waste which we pull from the septic tank
we're pumping out the septic tank until
we're able to see the bottom then we'll
rinse the bottom of the septic tank with
the water hose to ensure that it's left
clean for the customer so once we've
reached the bottom of the septic tank
we're going to ask the customer to flush
the toilet to ensure that everything is
exiting the house and entering the
septic tank people that are on septic
systems need to keep in mind mind that
everything that enters the septic tank
is going to be there until it's cleaned
out besides the water so if that's
grease Plastics paper whatever is not
being able to be broken down by bacteria
is going to stay in the tank
permanently we recommend pumping out
setic tanks every 3 to 5 years or based
off the sludge level inside of your tank
if your septic tank does clog there is a
chance that if you do keep running water
and keep flushing everything you're
flushing is not able to exit the home so
it can begin to start coming out of your
toilets or your showers usually it's the
thing that has the most capacity which
is usually the bathtub if somebody has
that this purple dye isn't toothpaste
but it could help prevent plaque and
improve Dental Health F Donald a dental
hygienist uses guided biofilm therapy to
clean her patient teeth and she says
it's more effective than traditional
methods today I'm going to show you how
guy bofilm therapy or gbt works when we
professionally clean a patient's mouth
from start to
finish my job as a dental hygienist is
to detect and treat but most importantly
prevent periodontal disease biofilms are
highly organized microscopic communities
of bacteria um but it's responsible for
bleeding gums for bad breath for some
dental infections for some of the
insightly deposits that we see on our
teeth and and of course it's linked to
some more serious systemic diseases as
well so here we can see plaque um and
calculus deposits but but more
concerning is the color of the gums
which are red and and they're also puffy
and swollen that would lead us to
believe either gingivitis or even
perodontal disease could be present here
one of the problems with biofilm is that
you can't see it and you can't feel it
so I use a die called biofilm disclosure
which is an organic colored
dye so when the dyes apply to the teeth
which have bofilm on them it changes the
color of the biofilm and it's a really
clever two-tone dye so it means that it
stains um early biofilm which is less
than 3 days old pink and it stains
mature bofilm which is more than 3 days
old
blue the patient is shown in the mirror
the stained bofilm biofilms are
microscopic whereas the plaque is a
bofilm that's matured and it's large
enough to be seen with the naked eye I
did really what we want is to disrupt
Dental bofilm before it has the chance
to mature into
plaque so this is where we start the the
cleaning process and it is completely
different to the old-fashioned methods
of of curage and hand scaling so here
I'm using a tool called airflow Max
which acts like a warm jet wash for
inside the mouth um it uses a
combination of warm water and Tiny
soluble and antimic mobial powder
airflow Max will remove 100% of the
bofilm from the teeth and all of the
surrounding tissues including underneath
the guns where it's dark and warm and
the bofilm really likes to
hide I'm I'm also using the airflow Max
not just to take the bofilm away but it
it takes the St veins away as well so
the mouth looks and feels super clean
afterwards it's very comfortable for the
patient it's gentle it's efficient it's
very safe with no abrasion or damage to
the tooth surface at
[Music]
all after we've disrupted all of the
biofil and we've removed all of the
stain
uh pas on no pain is um is used at this
stage um and it uses ultrasonic
vibrations to remove any remaining hard
calculus it shaves the calculus off very
gently so it's very different to the
oldfashioned methods of scraping the
teeth which would take calculus away but
would also scratch the tooth
[Music]
surface
page seven of the gbt process um is is
our quality control stage really so here
I would spend a few moments checking
around the whole mouth to ensure that
all the deposits have been removed and
all the biofilms being disrupted um so
at this stage I would hand the mirror
back to my patients so they can see the
before and after results of their guided
bofilm therapy treatment I usually ask
my patients to run their tongue over the
teeth at this stage to feel how silky
smooth they are and now that the biofil
and calculus has gone so learning good
oral hygiene habits um is like learning
to swim you have to be shown um so ask
your dental hygienist to teach you how
to clean your teeth properly spend the
most time and concentrate the most
efforts on the areas that you can't see
that's where you'll find the most
biofilm so in between the back teeth
underneath the gum line around the base
of restorations oh I love my job I love
it so much um because I get to put
smiles on people's faces every single
day what other job in the world gets to
do
that this filthy mattress hasn't been
cleaned in 7 years rather than replace
it John Bristol from Super Fresh
demonstrates how to deep clean it to
increase its
longevity my name is John Bristol and
I'm from chinada and Tobago I'm the
director of Superfresh and today I'm
going to show you how we clean the very
dirty mattresses as well as the average
dirty
ones so a typical process of cleaning a
mattress is we spray on an enzyme based
cleaner and that will break down the
dirt and the body a and you know the
little incidents and we give that
chemical some time to Wick after that
there's some agitation also known as
scrubbing and in the final stage of the
process we use the extractor and that
would spray in a solution of Clean Water
fabric shampoo and deodorizer and vacuum
at the same time so it rinses away
everything so there isn't any harsh
chemicals left to interfere with
anyone's skin or anything
afterwards there's going to be a lot of
dust build up over time um there's going
to be hair if there are a lot of kids in
the home you're going you going to find
urine even if the client doesn't know
sometimes like you know some people eat
on their beds and stuff so they find
Crumbs from various cool
stuff all right so I actually had no
idea what to expect when come in to do
this job and I'm still not entirely sure
what caused it it may have been some
flooding in the area but I'm not sure so
that was probably more than 5 years for
sure so right here I am spraying on the
enzyme based cleaner on the mattress and
I'm looking to see the areas where I may
have to apply another quotes as we go
along what I use right now it's a
synthetic enzyme I could use it for
everything but there are some STS that
would require like additional chemicals
if you really want to get them removed
visually but the most important thing
for most clients is getting the actual
thing that caus the stain out so we say
there may not be a visual Improvement
but you can be sure that you're getting
all the nasties
up they are usually just regular buildup
so just regular dust and dirt that
accumulate over the years some clients
don't use like a full three-piece sheet
set a lot of clients don't have matches
protectors either using heat is
beneficial because heat acts almost like
a universal catalyst so heat would help
your chemicals to work faster so it
would help the enzyme cleaner to break
down the stuff faster and it also help
the fabric shampoo to latch onto the
dirt particles faster so it helps make
the cleaning process more efficient
unfortunately there's no way to know for
sure that you get like 100% of it but
you want to know that you're picking up
as much as
possible this mattress was especially
dirty so it's either like a lot of years
probably more than seven or so or a lot
of use but I don't think it's any one
thing but just like a combination of
factors that leavs it to be that I found
that you could use a variable speed
polisher and a scrubbing brush
attachment the brush is rotating at
about 600 RPM um we use the softest
brush available because some Fabrics are
really delicate and we use that to help
break down the larger debris and stuff
on the surface of the fabric so it helps
break down the larger pieces of debris
cuz sometimes they have buildup that is
really really bad and it's actually like
kicked up the general process for moving
stains is just isolate where the stain
is and I may double apply the enzyme
based cleaner to it or I may spend a
little longer scrubbing
it I believe for this one the client
told us it was probably about 2 years
and it wasn't too bad it was just like a
light not creamish color but we know the
original color was white so we sprayed
it one time and we did the scrubbing
I mean you'll always have the extremes
some would be much much darker brown
some would be much more spotty but the
average person is you know just a little
cream just a little off-white from where
it should be for mattresses you're
usually going to get those kind of
colors because even below the surface
they still have a lot of debris your
dead skin cells your dirt and your dust
building up so even if the top surface
doesn't accurately represent what is
hidden inside there you're going to find
it once we do the
extraction
[Music]
after a certain amount of years your
mattress significantly increases in
weight simply due to like the dust and
dead skin cells that collect so one is
going to be more uncomfortable to if
you're using it regularly some of that
is going to be entering the air so
you're going to have like a lower
Quality Air inside the home it may
attract mites if there's a lot of
moisture around just overall is not
going to be best for your well-being
like for people that are asmatic the
buildup of dust could be a problem for
people with sensitive skin the any
buildup on matches over time could pose
a threat in the future in terms of like
having flare ups if you're taking all
the preventative measures I don't think
you should need the service more than
like once a year get it cleaned and then
get a mattress protector because you can
always wash that every Fortnight or
every month and you're in a much better
position than paying me I don't mind but
in a much better position for your own
wellbeing this leather handbag is
covered in green mold and almost looks
beyond repair but Charlotte Stark from
the handbag Clinic uses her expertise to
get the leather looking fresh and clean
I am Charlotte STI co-founder and CEO of
handbag clinic today we're going to be
looking at mold removal on a
handbag this bag was actually at the
back of a wardrobe um and a pipe burst
behind the Wardrobe which created the
perfect area for mold to be
spawned our Artisan will always start by
assessing the type of mold that it is
and making sure it's safe for them to
work on from there we will use a range
of tools to begin scraping the kind of
bulk of that mold
off
they will select the tool that will be
most successful in removing that but
also avoiding any scuffs or scratches to
that leather
underneath in some areas we can use a
metal tool because the leather is a
little bit harder wearing in those
places and the mold is less attached to
the
bag we will go in with the wooden tool
um when we are getting a bit closer to
that leather because we obviously don't
want to scratch or damage that leather
underneath and we then go in with a
brush to remove any excess H that is
dried on the top as
well once we have removed as much dry
mold as we possibly can we then will
start with the mold removal this bag was
so heavily saturated we needed to make
sure we killed the mold that was going
all the way through that skin a leather
skin is absorbent in the same way that
our skin is absorbent so we needed to
make sure we kill it all the way through
to make sure that wouldn't come back at
a later stage The Artisan will spray the
mold removal Solution Direct onto the
bag this is something that we do not
recommend that anybody tries at home any
product going on a lever should always
go on with cl first usually because
spraying direct if you don't have the
correct training can lead to actually
damaging the leather further it's
important that a bag that's saturated
with mold is handled by professionals so
that they are able to really kill the
base of that mold to make sure it
doesn't come back spread to to your
other items in your wardrobe and to make
sure that the bag's not damaged in the
process as
well
once we've completed the mold removal
and killed the actual cause of the mold
we will then move on to cleaning the bag
to remove any additional chemicals and
to hygienically clean the bag getting it
ready to be returned to its client The
Artisan is now applying our specialist
inhouse cleaner this removes any
additional chemicals that are left on
the bag making sure that we've
hygienically cleaned the bag throughout
as well we are turning our leather
cleaner into a foam this it just gives a
very even coating throughout the item it
also creates a really nice LA to make
sure it really gets into all of the skin
and cleans it thoroughly this bag has
already been through so much cleaning by
this point so we are simply just wiping
away any of those excess chemicals and
excess dir on the
[Music]
back once once this process is complete
this item is ready to go back to the
client this client had huge sentimental
attachment to this bag really loved it
and didn't think it was savable and
because we managed to save it when they
got it back they actually rang our
office and were crying with happiness
down the phone that we'd saved their bag
with the cleaning process mold is tricky
because you've got to make sure you kill
those enzymes that are creating the mold
so they do need very different products
even if a bag has a small amount of mold
it's important that you seek help from a
professional because you need to kill
the source if you don't kill the sauce
it will just spread back throughout that
handbag it also May spread other items
in your wardrobe this deteriorating
headstone belongs to a World War II
veteran and it's in desperate need of
cleaning Trey zippa created the
nonprofit by Memorial Day to do just
that so I get a lot of questions about
why are these Stones so dirty dirty this
is not dirt these are living organisms
these are plants the more polished the
stone the less surface area there is for
the biological organisms to adhere to
the stone and so the reason why we use
this quary ammonium compound is this
kills them so these things are natural
in nature you're going to find in the
South especially it's not just growing
on rooftops it's also growing on our
headstones my name is Trey Zipperer I'm
the founder of B Memorial Day a
nonprofit organization dedicated to the
cleaning of all veteran headstones by
Memorial Day in
perpetuity so this is a ground level
grave marker issued by the federal
government via the national cemetery
Administration it's a white marble
material Natural Stone it was a Gunners
mate GM third class US Navy I don't
think it's respectful to have a
veteran's headstone dirty in the least
and so we're going to clean this
headstone of this American hero who gave
his all who sacrificed unimaginable
Horrors for three and A2 years as a
prisoner of war the first thing I like
to do is I use a a uh a desk broom to
get all of the sand and and debris off
of the stone so we take our water squirt
bottle um I like the one with a little
bit bigger base on it I give it a Cody
of water is again these these stones are
porous so it's going to soak in this
clean water which is not going to get
down in any chemical down inside the
stone we use a cleaning agent that
contains an active ingredient known as a
quater ammonium compound and it is known
and respected throughout historic
preservationist as the safest most
effective way to clean Natural Stone
this brush uh is made with bris from
tampo so tampo from the agave plant is a
natural bristle that won't harm the
Natural Stone and then I want to give it
a good coating of the D2 biological
solution which is going to go to work on
this Stone very quickly you're going to
see this Stone starting to turn a bit of
an orange color and then it's going to
continue working on the stone for the
next few weeks and that stone will
become brighter and whiter and whiter uh
and you have to clean them about every 2
to 3 years this does a wonderful job of
getting all the growth killed on the
stone the next step is to let that soak
for about 10 minutes when I'm looking at
a headstone in a cemetery I want that
stone to be impeccably clean it doesn't
matter if it's almost clean it needs to
be clean I think the reason why some
veteran headstones become more soy oiled
or more covered in biological growth is
because of the polishing of the stone
the more polished the stone the less
surface area there is for the biological
organisms to adhere to the stone and
after about 10 minutes it's not that
hard to get the material off the stone
with a a soft bristle natural bristle
brush
then you can get into the etchings with
a toothbrush to get into the real nooks
and crannies of things
sometimes
and the final step of honoring a veteran
of our past is to place an American flag
at their grave this is known as a grave
flag this particular grave has already
had an American Legion flag holder
placed at the grave and there's a spot
in the back of them for the flag stick
to just stick right down into
it my vision of B Memorial Day is this
one day in the near future we'll have a
volunteer assigned to every veteran
grave in America no matter where that
veteran is buried no matter what
cemetery they're
in so to tell you a little bit about why
this happens these are living organisms
these are plants growing on the stone
whether they're algae or lyans or mold
uh mildew and so the reason why we use
this quary ammonium compound is this
kills them so these things are natural
in nature you're going to find in the
South especially we have this black mold
on all of our our concrete tile roofs
and it's not just growing on roof Toops
it's also growing on our
headstones I think it's important that
we don't lose the stories of our veteran
Heroes of the past because they truly
are forgotten their stories are are
disappearing
because when they pass away and the
people who knew them pass away their
stories are pretty much gone
forever so now we're uh going to start
on the etchings I start with the cross
at the top and work my way down just
each letter uh these are etched into the
marble as compared to the early veteran
headstones were B known as bass relief
where the letters were basically
sticking out they removed the material
around the letters so the letters became
kind of like three-dimensional the
material that grows inside these Stones
it's a combination of things fixed in
there and also there's little Ledges so
to speak where when the wind blows the
pollen Falls all different types of
things will just get wedged and just
build up in these
etchings
grave Flags measure 8 in by 12 in but I
would rather have a flag than no flag so
if you can't find an 8 by 12 that
doesn't mean you can't place a flag at
the grave the person at a Podium
speaking for example the American flag
is to their right so in this case we
have uh a headstone of American Veteran
so as the Veteran's looking at you the
flag needs to be to his or her right you
want to get as close to the stone as you
can without marring the stone with your
Mallet because when the weat eaters and
other types of Maintenance equipment
comes through you don't want them
hitting your flag
holder the way that I research the
veterans buried beneath the veteran
headstones that I clean uh is by using
the internet first and I go to certain
sources that I know uh contain content
such as findagrave.com there's a several
different websites like that and by
looking into those different
databases and different family trees on
ancestry.com you can start to put
together the story of a veteran and
every now and then you just get
something that's amazing and insightful
that you didn't
anticipate this is a application for
headstone or marker uh for a uh deceased
American Veteran uh the family members
would have to complete this application
in order to choose what style of Veteran
headstone that they wanted for their
loved one and this particular
application is for Robert uh S Lewis
prepared by his father and this is where
the story of his sacrifice uh became
apparent this man was a sergeant
Sergeant shadman was a top turret Gunner
fire in the cockpit could not see if he
got out I saw Sergeant shadman reaching
for a parachute I do not believe he
could have gotten out alive because the
plane broke apart where he was last seen
when they were attacked they were flying
at 24,000 ft Sergeant shadman was up in
the top turret uh he was a Gunner and he
was trying to get out of that top turret
as the plane was tumbling to the ground
his death's date says September 12th
1944 but there's evidence to suggest
that he did in fact get out of that
aircraft and he did reach the ground
alive because there's a hospital
admission record of him in September
1944 we don't know what day that he died
but his mother uh applied for his
veteran headstone with a death date of
September 23rd
in your local cemeteries there are Local
Heroes whose graves are in really bad
condition and it's pretty sad that a man
or a woman gives their life for our
country and then they're forgotten in
the cemetery and their headstone can't
even be read because they're so much
biological filth on it there are people
in America who care about veteran Graves
they just don't know what's happening
out here so I want to bring this story
to them so that they know that in your
local cemeteries there are Local Heroes
whose graves are in really bad condition
so if this is something that speaks to
your heart I encourage you to get out in
your local Cemetery see for yourself if
there's veteran headstones in need of
cleaning in your local area and take the
initiative to do something about it when
lint and dead skin cells clog up an
iPhone's charging port they can impact
the phone's ability to function julus
kavus from Phoneix craft uses special
tools to fish out debris and get head
phones working like new hello I'm Julius
and I'm the owner of phone fix craft so
today I'm going to show you how I clean
and repair damaged iPhone my job is
actually phone repairs including micro
soldering and data recovery stuff like
that and the cleaning is just it's not
that it's a huge part of our business
it's just fixed phones that we see that
they need they need some
cleaning so the first step uh you have
to remove the those two bottom screws
which every iPhone has we open up the
screen the phone had a broken screen and
the and the owner of this phone used
used it for a good while with that
broken screen so the all the internals
of the phone were exposed to to whatever
was in customer's pocket so uh this
actually a fire hazard so so we try to
remove every loose bit from from the
inside of the
fs but once it's loose I would use
compressed air like a like a
gun the dirtiest Parts would be the
charging port on on all kind of phones
not only iPhones but actually doesn't
look dirty if you just look at it with
die and the microscope I have here is
it's my most loved tool it's going to
come come with me when I die I would
just uh clean every phone every speaker
every earpiece and every charging port
under this this microscope this tool we
use for charging boort cleaning is
something similar to a metal toothpick
uh it's just a little bit thinner and
then then sharper so now I'm going to
clean years worth of pocket length and
dust from thisch charging port
experiencing charging
issues the charging ports would be
usually filled with the like pocket L
from your from your jeans and then
whatever is in your pocket really if you
had a cookie there then you would have
some crumbs or something like that you
can see you know what what color threads
trousers or pants I'm not sure in in
United States the trousers or pants so
what you see here it's actually the
contents of of a charging port of what
we usually would find there so it's a
it's just a pocket L really pocket lint
and and
dust I would use the same tool that they
use for cleaning charging ports to clean
the uh really heavy clogged speakers as
well we do get phones that are really
dirty and messed up but it's for us it's
just normal you know Medics are not not
surprised by injuries or something like
that is there so so for us it's uh
yeah so on this phone the
battery has already started to swell and
uh and customer agreed to get it
replaced we removed the battery uh we
attached the new pull tabs to to a new
battery we just need to apply a new
display adhesive before putting
everything back
together so once the screen is pressed
back into the frame uh we just need to
put the last two screws in and it's it's
ready to be cleaned before giving it
back to the
customer
you just have to solve solve a puzzle
you know to get the thing working and
this is especially rewarding if some uh
few other shops deemed it unfixable and
then it comes to you and and you accept
the challenge and you actually get that
fixed it's uh it's nice it's uh that's
what they really love the abundance of
plants growing in this pool is
astounding given that it's an indoor
pool we return to the pool guy miles
Laflin to see how he restores it to a
swimmable State hi I'm miles I'm going
to show you how I professionally clean
an indoor pool which hasn't been used
for 6
years all right then had a DM come
through can I help sort out this pool
which actually looks more like a pond I
know I was half expecting to see a fish
swimming around in the bottom there was
plants growing in there like pond plants
they thought maybe like like when when
they were cutting the grass on the doors
open maybe little bits blew in and like
seeds or whatever just went into the
water see bits start growing and stuff
so maybe like that but who knows we're
going to empty and clean out droing in
the submersible pump first and we'll be
back the next day nice and empty but not
nice and
clean time to get to work I'm going to
jump in have a look at the damage
first yeah so once the pole was empty um
we brushed them into a corner of with a
big brush um shoved them out into a
bucket and threw it on their compost
heat the main difference between
cleaning an indoor and an outdoor pool
is normally you don't get any indoor
pool obviously this one had plants
growing in it took about five five or
six years for this pool to get like that
but for an outdoor pool that' probably
only take maybe a year year and a half
for it to get like that
state
so before we emptied the pole this was
actually floating so when we emptied it
it sort of like the plants like started
attaching themselves to the
wall then Jet washing the walls on the
floor quickly have a guess at what pitch
is tied in on the floor I went for a
dolphin turns out it's a sea lion that's
pretty cool though
it's coming up nicely but there's still
some stains left over so what we're
going to do is mix up some acid in a
bucket of
water scrub that all over the floor and
walls then we're going to jet wash the
surround jump back in the pole rinse
that
down get the big Hoover Out start
hoovering up all the last little
bits
[Music]
um so that is a chlorine dispenser and
you can feel that up with the chlorine
tablets and it slowly dissolves the
tablets feeding chlorine into the
pool you could fill up the chlorine
feeder with the tablets but it won't
give your P instant chlorine you'd then
put in the granules to give it that
initial chlorine dose and then the
tablets will slowly disolve bringing up
the choring level as
well that is um well some people think
it's me adding color to the
pole is that what makes the pole look
blue is what some people me message me
um but actually it's
alide and that is to prevent um the
growth of
algae uh so that is a
jelly and it's a water
clarifier also it removes phosphates
from the pole um and helps with chemical
efficiency what it does is help it like
a layer pick up small particles
therefore making the pole bit
clearer but when you initially put salt
in a pole a freshly filled pool it will
take around a week for the salt to be
generated into chlorine itself and the
process is called
electrolysis
it looked as if it had just been
finished from like new build the tiles
were like nice and blue nice and white
tiles very clean
looking um a 100 times better than what
it did when I turned up this was all
within maybe half a day's work I I've
seen green indoor pools but never an
indoor pool with anything growing other
than a little bit of algae The
diamontologist Gabby Davis is using a
pck in the crevices of these diamond
earrings to dig out the builtup grime
she'll need a specialized microscope and
a high pressure steamer to restore the
jewelry my name is Gabby I'm a jewelry
specialist in certified diamontologist
at Jared the gallery of Jewelry so today
I'm going to show you how I clean a few
pairs of earrings and get them going
from dark and dull to bright shiny and
just like new
again so this particular pair the
Solitaire earrings will take the
earrings over to our digital gym scope
where I can get an up close look at them
these
had a good bit more than your average
amount of buildup within not only just
the setting but actually the backs as
well with this pair I use a very sharply
pointed needle to remove a lot of that
excess buildup so typically with
earrings a lot of what you see is
shampoos and conditioner and in this one
it does appear as though there was some
ear wax and then after that and I've
removed as much as I can with the needle
I take it over to our
ultrasonic where I'm going to go ahead
and let these soak in here for probably
about a minute or so the liquid that's
in there it's a mild alkaline type
solution it's just designed to break up
anything that's built up upon the piece
now I'm going to go ahead and take it
over to our high pressure steamer where
I can remove any bits of debris that are
left over after letting it soak in the
ultrasonic and then after that my
favorite part is getting just a nice
close-up look at them after they've been
clean so this particular pair of
solitire earrings are definitely a
well-loved pair of earrings uh so what I
did was started by removing all of this
ear wax and hair product buildup that is
trapped inside of not only the backing
of the earrings but the setting and all
all the way down the post of the
earrings they were absolutely
covered so this pair of earrings that
this guest brought in were in white gold
with three little diamonds set on them
it just looks like your typical shampoo
and conditioner buildup that has been
caught in all the little openings of the
earrings so luckily metal and of course
diamonds being the hardest natural
natural substance on Earth I don't have
to worry too much about causing any
damage when using this needle something
that I do like to do is make sure that I
am going through at every possible
angle for the most part earrings
especially stud earrings are a staple in
just about everyone's jewelry box and
when they're worn every single day like
this for a years or months on end
eventually all of the stuff that we
encounter is going to get caught up on
there and it is going to make them dirty
without routine maintenance and
cleanings on them they definitely all
could reach this
point this is a cluster style earring
gives you a nice big look this earring
here actually hadn't been cleaned in I
believe she said a little over a year
and not only that but after she lost the
other earring This One Singular one had
just kind of been sitting collecting
dust allowing all of that buildup to
just sort of cake together so you can
see on the top of this one here there is
a lot of ear wax and product that's
built up covering up those stones
leaving a film on them now something
that did make that does make this
setting a little bit more difficult than
a simple solid hair setting is that this
setting here has a lot of detail work up
underneath where it can be more
difficult for me to actually get the
tweezers in there to remove a lot of
this stuff so for the most part I'm
really going to be counting on the
ultrasonic in the steamer more so than
on Solitaire earrings or another
Style
these airpods are so coated in ear wax
that it's impacting the speaker sound
quality Julius kavus from Phoneix craft
knows how to clean the airpods and get
them sounding as good as
need today I'm going to show you how to
clean dirty airpods from start to
finish we offer all kind of phone
repairs uh we specialize in iPhone
repairs mainly what what is portable and
smart we can repair it so when people
bring in their airpods the main problem
they have is low volume either on boat
or just on one side of the airpods
usually they come like in the condition
that the customers are going to throw
them away and they just come to me as a
last resort so I'm going to show you
three different pairs of airpods in
three different
conditions this pair of airpods of
course they are not clean cleaned uh of
course the main main Brown thing is is
the air wax and it's a piece of bacon or
sausage or or carrot nobody nobody
really knows but uh I just uh pour a
drop of pure alcohol and leave them for
a couple of seconds just to soak in and
and I use toothpick to to kind of
release the the whatever is in there
probably airbox or or something like
that
I soften that with the with this short
brush I just trim them down to to make
them
harder then I just use vacuum cleaner to
to suck everything out
[Music]
out and then and then repeat repeat
repeat the same process again and again
until it's uh until it's clean really
there's two sets of mesh on in every
airport is the one the steel one that
you see in front and there is one a
little bit smaller pitch one behind it
so we can see the second clean clean
second mesh behind it in in those few
open holes the actual mesh is is pretty
clean most of the holes are still open
and the so this pair actually looks very
bad but it's still quite loud and and
usable
yeah this look at the war these airports
they were still working you can see you
can see some uh open holes there so the
the sound was still coming through it
was super super quiet but it was still
coming through that one open open hole
in that mesh it's it makes a difference
really it looks like they were lying
around for for a good while somewhere
you know in the corner cuz uh like looks
like mold or something like that it's
yeah they they were not the cleanest
ones that's for
sure I can see it seen some better days
you can see the actual plastic it was
probably uh chewed with by you know a
small dog or cat or or something like
that you know because cu the plastic
itself like I never or maybe or maybe it
was shwed by the owner themselves you
know like uh
visually the the left left one might
look much worse than the right one and
it's just a matter of how
many how many those holes in the net are
still
open you can see the dark uh dark holes
you know where where it means that
there's nothing behind them that they
are not clogged so they are they are
open Sound can still go through them and
uh you know usually if they're still
like in in this one probably there's
like 20% of of goes are still still
open I believe the customer tried to
clean them by themselves and they did
their best so if you zoom in you can see
the actual the every single hole on that
net is clogged you can see something
there you know on the last pair of ones
I was using uh Mr muscle
window and glass stre streak free
shine every single one is clogged so I
believe that like this is completely
silent so it wasn't usable that's for
sure so when the airport is is clean and
the the mesh of the speaker it it looks
like nice nice dark gray color and you
can actually see well through the holes
you can see some you know the dark black
you know the inside of the of the airpod
the volume is back it's loud and clear
and uh they're usable again uh I don't
want to look like the I'm the pro of the
pros of the airpods cleaning I just I
would like to find a solution that you
know maybe even the DIY solution were
you know and keep them clean and tidy
and loud
next Julius will tackle an iPhone with a
charging port that's clogged with debris
he uses specialized tools to fish out
the dust and grime to get the phone
working as it should hi my name is
Julius kavas and I'm going to show you
how I clean every opening of an
iPhone well usually the charging port
gathers the biggest amount of dust and
and and pocket L because it just kind of
deepest opening and uh and whatever gets
in there it gets packed with the charger
every time you plug it in so in charging
ports it would usually be pocket lint
and and dust sometimes cookie crumbs or
I don't know Pizza
crumbs over the time you would start
getting this is charging uh later on you
have to keep the charger at a certain
angle to get the phone to charge Pro the
process of cleaning charging port is
very simple uh I use a dental pick same
kind of thing that dentist use goes at
an angle so when I look through the
microscope I can still see inside the
port when the dental pick is there the
charging is back to normal when you when
you plug in the charging cable you have
to feel and hear like a nice
click so in the speakers it would
usually be skin oil something greasy
mixed with dust and very similar to
earbags on the left it's just a
microphone on the right is speaker and
the
[Music]
microphone
with a short brush I kind of try to just
break down whatever is in there in the
the speaker mesh and then I use a a
regular vacuum cleaner to to suck the
rest of the liquid
out well on the mute switch it yeah it
would usually be dust and maybe moisture
kind of as well some skin grease or hand
cream something like that getting in
there and attracting that dust and yeah
often see uh mute switch is not working
stuck in hopefully in U in like a normal
ringer mode not in a silent one
customers never really ask to repair
their mute switch even though it doesn't
work and stuck in one position I'm not
sure whether they don't use it or
they're happy as it is but they are
happy to hear that it's fixed I use the
same Dental pick and uh and the little
brush and alcohol but really some that's
the safest one to clean so if somebody
needs to clean this at home just uh just
use a short brush toothbrush would do
and uh just brush it and then uh it
should be
perfect so in the earpiece uh it would
usually be skin oils mixed with dust or
or makeup really looks and feels s
similar to ear wax over the time the
earpiece volume just gets lower and
lower and just end up in this stage
where where you just have to use
handsfree or or earphones to to actually
make a call so to clean an earpiece I
use just a short short brush drop of
isopropyl alcohol and the vacuum cleaner
so I put a drop on of alcohol on the on
the speaker Grill and uh just kind of
break break everything down with the
with the brush and uh try to remove
everything what's left there with the
just a regular home vacuum cleaner so
yeah it's it makes a huge
difference customer customers can't
believe that they're like regular
Regular People phones they they can't
imagine who would be able to use it like
that but uh but they are regular people
phones like every other phone is like
this you know so uh the owner of the
phone they do have their own life they
do have their own problems and know
there are more bigger problems on in
people's lives than than their phones
you know this seemingly never ending
clump of dust could diminish the air
quality or even cause allergies for the
occupants of this home duct hero
specializes in removing this harmful
dust for a cleaner safer home today I'm
going to show you how I clean 47 years
of dust out of
[Music]
vents as soon as we walked in we see the
old vents the furnace how old it was
before even opening any of the vents up
I knew how bad it was going to be you
know he said 47 years of dust probably
over a hundred years to be
honest if you look at a vent and you see
dust on the actual vent that's a clear
sign that the ducts have probably never
been cleaned and they're pretty filthy
inside uh we like to start on the very
top of the house and work our way down
that tool that we're using uh we call it
whiskers um the whiskers are just made
out of rubber the end of it attached to
an air compressor and you have air just
coming out through the rod out the
little whisker
[Music]
things so what you're looking at right
now is just me pulling chunks of dust
out that have probably been in there for
over a 100 years there was too much dust
to be putting it in the vacuum um so I
literally went in there with my hands
and grabb grabbed probably like 5 lb of
dust isn't it gnarly like look at how
much dust that is it's just so sick
[Music]
honestly this is the back of the dryer
uh and you guys can pretty much see
there's an endless amount of L coming
out there's a few reasons why you should
get your dryer vent cleaned it's a huge
fire hazard and your clothes will dry
more efficiently it's well worth the
money to just pay to get it cleaned
every
[Music]
year the vacuum is on throughout the
whole process uh and what we're doing is
blowing all that that dust and debris
closer and closer to the
vacuum this house in particular had 18
vents most of the time I think probably
75% of the time the houses that we go to
have never been cleaned um people just
don't think about it you know that
getting your air ducts clean isn't like
a regular thought that comes to your
you know head the dust you typically see
in your fence is most of it is actually
uh human skin cells yeah it's pretty
[Music]
gnarly so right now we're done and
everything's pretty much good to go um
you're pretty much going to see a brand
new home honestly uh you're going to
feel much better uh your health is going
to be better I actually got a phone call
after that job and they said all all
their allergies went away it it's just a
huge health benefit honestly uh you
might not notice like the small stuff
but your body does this home's gutters
have become packed with leaves dirt and
Roots Mike Le Bruno demonstrates how he
cleans out the debris in preparation for
winter hi I'm Mike Le Bruno owner of All
Bright pressure washing and morning we
specialize in gutter cleaning and
pressure washing of homes and businesses
in southeast North
Carolina I'm going to show you how we
clean clogged gutters before
winter in the fall we're going to have a
lot of leaves and debris that fall so
it's important to check your gutters
before a snowstorm if we have snow that
accumulates on a roof we can have some
water run off as temperatures rise that
snow will mou causing excessive
rainwater to flow into the gutter and
freeze and unfreeze potentially causing
water to expand back up into the
interior of your home underneath a roof
line we start by inspecting gutters by
removing any debris from the roof dry
debris consists of leaves dirt and
shingle grit which can cause excessive
weight inside of the gutter
too the pressure washer is a great tool
for cleaning out gutters but if it's too
compacted we will first need to resort
to handpicking this we want to pick out
as many clumps and clogs wet or dry
debris as we can wet debris is just a
little bit muddier and we have water
added with it which is excessive weight
inside of the gutter stressing it out if
we find a big clog such as wet compacted
debris in some cases we have to take the
down SP apart we will start at the
bottom by removing rivets or screws to
get closer to our clog or
backup once we're done handpicking all
the debris we can we want to perform our
flush test this is where we will take a
pressure washer and run water in the top
of the gutter towards the downspout for
at least 10 to 20 seconds we want to
remove any remaining debris that we did
not get from handpicking and we want to
see good clear flow of water diverting
away from the home and Foundation we
will start at the top of the gutter and
then move to the down spout to ensure we
have no remaining debris and everything
is Flowing
correctly if we see clear water and good
flow and hear a hollow
sound there are no clogs present if
there is a clog present we want to tap
on that down spout and determine where
the clog is we want to run water through
the top of the down spout and have
someone at the bottom checking to make
sure that debris is starting to flow
through here this is all pine straw
that's been collecting for at least a
couple years we are using a tap Shake
method along with running water in the
top of the gutter to break up the debris
and flush out all of the pine straw a
good way to tell that your gutters are
flowing properly is there will be no
water running over the top of the gutter
and you will see clear water at the
bottom of the down spout depending on
the type of tree and location of
landscaping around your home will
determine how often you should clean
your gutters out and what type of debris
may fall in them a good practice would
be to trim back trees as needed and
plant future trees further away from the
home this rooftop hasn't been cleaned in
over 28 years and is now covered in
organic debris Sid Partridge of
Partridge exterior cleaning isn't afraid
to climb on top of the house to remove
the
buildup hi my name is Sid I run an
exterior cleaning business in the UK and
today I'm going to be taking you through
cleaning a very Mossy roof so this roof
hasn't been clean for the 28 years that
the homeowners have lived
here here I'm beginning to scrape the
roof so I'm trying to remove as much
Moss as possible this is what I'll be
doing for the bulk of the day and this
is the hardest part of the job I have
the tool that I use it's basically a
flat Metal Blade uh angled to one side
which means I can get the edge of the
tile which usually carries a lot of the
Moss and scrape the bulk surface of the
tile at the same time I use sort of a
side to side motion and it is very
taxing on the body so it takes a long
time to build up the endurance and
strength to do it so on this roof you'll
see a lot of brown and green this is the
marul you see a lot of white spots
people think think is bird droppings but
this is white Lin Moss is terrible for
roofing and roof materials especially in
the UK as we get a lot of damp weather
over here so it just tends to grow and
fester more and it will grow in between
the cracks of the tiles now when you
have hot weather turn into cold weather
the mus will freeze and expand and then
end up cracking the roof tiles which can
create holes leaks and things like that
in the roof so this part of the job
where I'm on the scaffolding was the
hardest so I use a 40 ft extendable pole
with the scraper attached on the end and
I was almost at Max extension so the
scraper itself is quite heavy and the
pole itself is quite heavy so having
that out at a near horizontal level for
a couple of hours is very difficult and
as soon as this was done I was relieved
and happy to move on to the next part so
what I'm cleaning here is a four
bedroomed house it's got big flat
concrete tiles so these are some of the
best tiles to come across to clean the
surface area of them and because they're
completely flat it's very easy to get
the Moss off you do not get roofs better
than this so it's rare that you'll
actually get away with using a broom to
clean a roof as usually the Moss is very
very stuck on and it's typically just
used for cleaning up however on this job
the Moss was coming off easy so in
certain sections it can just be easier
just to try and sweep off a majority and
then sort of fine tune it with a
scraper so the typical cleaning
chemicals that I use in my roof cleaning
work is a chemical called a bioside uh
what this essentially will do is destroy
any of the organic growth left on the
roof and it has a residual cleaning
effect once I'm gone as well so there's
no rinse in it after you leave it on the
roof to fully dry and soak into the
tiles this will get anything that we
can't get to by scraping so anything
that's left in the gaps any sort of
really stubborn stains and marks that
are left on the tiles also will slowly
degrade so the brush that I'm using here
is a basic waterfed pole that most
window cleaners would use that's all you
need it's got four jets in it which will
fire out the chemical mixed with the
water onto the roof and the brush is
just used to agitate that chemical which
will help it foam up up as you can see
this helps it stick to the roof more as
it's a natural surfactant so what I'm
doing here is I'm applying the bide
solution to the roof now this is diluted
at 25 to1 with water so for every 1 lit
of bioside I use 25 L of water to dilute
it ensuring I'm covering every square
inch of this roof making sure it's
completely soaked in a lot of mistakes
people make is not putting enough on and
they're left with a very patchy roof so
it's really important to get complete
coverage and make sure all of the tiny
little gaps are completely soaked so if
you don't fill all of the gaps on the
roof with the chemical then the mus will
regrow with a Vengeance the important
part is making sure anything organic on
this roof is completely absorbing this
chemical so once the bioside completely
soaks and dries in you would never even
know it was on there and your results
will start to come after a few weeks the
main thing is trusting in the chemical
because it definitely will do its
job so it's important to have your roof
cleaned because the build of M will over
time damage the tiles on the roof which
can lead to cracks damp leak all sorts
of issues in your home that you really
don't want happening and if the problem
is not treated early enough then it can
lead to very expensive roof repairs in
the future as far as time scale on how
often should my roof be cleaned it is
pretty much a one-time deal for the
majority of the process as long as it's
being kept on top of and in future it
would just be a light chemical treatment
just to keep anything up Bay so the
first step is getting it done and then
it's a case of maintaining it when
abandoned pools can become slimy
bacteria harboring messes miles Laflin
once again shows us how to make even the
dirtiest of PS pristine hi I'm miles and
I'm going to show you how I
professionally clean the pool from start
to
finish this Pole's not looking too good
going to get the submersible pump out
straight away pump the water out and and
then come back the next
day so here we are the next day it's
empty but there's like a blanket of
algae all over the pool I'm going to
shovel it all up put it in
buckets basically the green sludges
after a pool's been left for a long time
without any chlorine or any sanitizer in
the pool you you'll get algae build up
most of them don't smell that bad but
when it's when when sludge is really
thick on the bottom and you like disturb
it cuz obviously it's not been Disturbed
for a long time the smell that comes out
is
crazy basically when we had the pool
empty we realized how many frogs there
were I'd never seen so many frogs in a
pool before in my life uh like every
scoop every shovel fold there was maybe
one or two frogs on on it so we had to
get them out put them on the side of the
pool and let them run off into the
bushes
[Music]
uh so we used hydrochloric acid uh mixed
with water so it was dilute it down get
out the old C K4 start pressure washing
the pool
down it's all coming up pretty
well
[Music]
at the bottom of the pool there's a main
um there had been some work done around
the pool like the slabbing and that um
obviously there's a lot of leaves gone
into the pool so a lot of Mark at the
bottom and just built up and solidified
so that to be broken up nothing special
it's just a screw like an old
Screwdriver from the van uh helped to
get into it break it up um
and then ho it
[Music]
out
the dirtiest Parts on the pool are going
to be the filters basically they have
the water runs through the filters
continuously or on a timer blue tank is
the filter with sand in and that keeps
the pool water clean what it does is
catches all the dirt and just stuff
that's floating around in the pool so I
and then once a week once every two
weeks whenever I go and do a maintenance
you do a back wash and that gets rid of
all the dirt and anything that's been
floating around in the pool new sand in
cut it
[Applause]
open got do five bags of sand for this
24in
filter slip the lid back
on so when I do the chemicals they all
look the same chlorine as well they're
all just like sort of white powder but
basically I'm just balancing the
chemicals on the on the swimming pools
when I'm doing a maintenance a few bags
of salt needed 3 25 kilo
[Applause]
bags basically what happens when you
pour it in in goes through the
system and runs through a salt cell
which is just the chlorine generator so
as it's running through the salt cell it
uses a process called electrolysis I
think I said it
right basically just tur it into
chlorine for the pool get the brush out
brush it all around so it's not just
sitting on the
floor and that's that job
done um this was definitely the worst
pool I've worked on in terms of how
dirty it was and how much algae there
was and smell the smell was just
ridiculous it was unbearable at some
some sometimes it didn't take me all day
didn't take too long I know it looks
like a lot of mess but it went pretty
well a lot of people say to me you know
don't you ever just feel like just
jumping in the pool I mean on a really
hot day I do but other than that I'm not
really that bothered about
it poor drain maintenance can lead to
blockages which can then cause flooding
and water damage handyman Alex pic shows
us how he goes about cleaning dirt
leaves and Roots out of drains to get
the water flowing again hi I'm Alex pic
and I clean drains today we're going to
look at uh a few drains and I'm going to
show you how to clean When a drain is
clogged the obvious problem is that it
backs up and water doesn't drain um
which can cause flooding
which can lead to the drain backing up
further down um its run where it's even
harder to to get a clog out of so
regular maintenance of of grains is
really important to avoid those types of
things here we've got a basin drain the
water runs through the grape on the top
falls down into this Basin and the water
that falls in brings with it any of the
dirt or sand or whatever else it picks
up with it into that Basin so the first
step I do is I pop off the great top I
see that it very backed up with the soil
and sand so I start digging just trying
to expose as much of the drain as I can
I see that there's the exit pipe and
around it is a lot of roots uh mixed in
the S so I start to kind of break away
at those eventually getting down and P
out the roots from the pipe I get
further down into the Basin and finally
hit the bottom where the roots are all
coiled and just pull out those roots all
in a few big pieces and then I give the
drain a quick scrape out and clean and
then pop the lid back on and that's good
to
[Music]
go so French drains are typically at the
bottom of a slope driveway and the
reason for that is if a driveway is on a
slope and the house is at the end of the
slope water will continue on the slope
and end up in the house so the French
drains are put there as a way to divert
the water away from house first I'm just
going to take off the top I already can
see that there's quite a lot of debris
in here so the first thing I'm going to
do is just get my shovel and start
digging it out there's all types of
different creatures living in here some
worms some bus the debris is made up
mostly of soil and sand pine needles so
everything that's good for blocking the
grain is in
there then I'm going to start cleaning
the pipe that that exits this grain and
obviously this is important because no
matter how clean the drain is we're
relying on that pipe to bring out the
water
and I don't stop doing that until either
I can sort of see light through the end
of that pipe or until like I'm pretty
certain by shoving something in there
that it is now cleaned out and then I
get out the pressure washer give the
whole chamber and the top of it a clean
which just allows for better flow and a
nicer appearance as well after that I
pop the grates back on and we're looking
at a clean French drain
it's important to keep an eye on the
level of debris in French drains um they
can fill up quite quickly even in the
dryer months it's easy just to look in
and see okay if there's a little bit of
of stuff in here I can no longer see the
conrete base of the of the grain it's
probably F to open it up and just see
how deep this is and give it a quick sco
out these Chambers are fairly simple to
clean and it's quite easy just to get a
shovel and instead scooping that degree
out this train didn't have any Roots
growing into it which is a good sign
that means that this debris hasn't
probably been there too too long it's
probably been there a couple years maybe
once all of that muck is scooped out of
there I took the opportunity while it
was all open and and free of degree to
actually give it a a good clean so I got
a pressure washer there and was able
just to uh clean off the sides of the
drain and that just allows for better
flow through the whole drain as the
water often comes in at the side not
actually right through the top so the
smoother of a surface for the water to
to go in just allows a better all
overflow for the drain I would say um
you know don't be afraid to to open your
drains and take a look in there it's not
so scary it's probably nothing you can
break in there um really they are quite
simple generally just chambers that fill
up with soil no harm in in opening them
up and starting to
Gig this W S6 Firebird survived a flood
in Kentucky but was left with a layer of
hard mud and dirt coating its interior
the detailers at WD detailing had to use
a number of methods to dislodge the
caked on mud before the car was able to
run
again I'm RJ I'm one half of WD
detailing and today we're going to be
showing you how we clean quite possibly
the muddiest WS6 Firebird ever it was
involved in a really bad flood in
Kentucky the car was absolutely covered
basically head to toe in caked on mud to
the point to where the mud had dried and
it was starting to crack almost like a
desert
floor I can only assume that it was
involved in very fast moving water it
picked up sediment from somewhere nearby
and then it dried out
so the first step is removing pretty
much anything except for the dashboard
and the steering wheel and the steering
column because that was a little bit
more involved than we really had time
for using the vacuum to remove any
residual water in the back of the trunk
going into the detail I knew a lot of
this vehicle was going to be sold for
parts because there was only x amount
made and only a certain amount of parts
available it wouldn't make sense to scr
that car especially with so many parts
still being functional to change some of
the ways that we were going to be
cleaning the vehicle and using some
methods that we wouldn't use in a normal
detail and we've never done this before
but we literally took a pressure washer
and sprayed out the whole interior of
the vehicle in order to remove all the
mud so the reason why we wouldn't do
that in a normal detail job is it would
definitely damage some of the electrical
components of the vehicle if you didn't
give the car ample time to dry so if
this was a normal vehicle that we did
that in we would have to disconnect the
battery and then make sure that it dried
out for over 5 or 6
days with a car in this condition to
clean the carpet was again different
than most vehicles that we see on a
daily basis so we probably spent about
45 minutes just pressure washing gallons
of water into the carpet in order to try
and flush as much mud out of it as
possible well not only that we had to
flip it over and spray out mud on the
other side and then we actually had to
let it drain overnight to try and dry
out as much as we could before we put it
back in the next day to then continue to
clean it inside the car so once the
carpet's dry we then place it back into
the vehicle and we use carpet soap you
spray it onto the carpet and then I
actually use the extractor to add more
water in order to create a soapier
solution and then you agitate it using a
brush that connects to a drill to
release some of the dirt and grime or
the stains that are contained within the
carpet fibers bring them to the top so
so then you can suck it away with the
extractor in the extractor we only use
water if you spray the soap onto the
carpet and if you only have water in
your extractor when you see through the
head of the extractor that there's no
more foam there's no more bubbles or
soap that's coming out of the carpet you
know you've not only removed the
contaminants that were in the carpet but
also any residue from a leftover
soap when we were cleaning the leather
we had the pressure wash the majority of
the mud away first in order to even
reveal the leather to follow a normal
type of detailing methods there was too
much mud on the surface to really remove
it in any other way so that's not
typically how we would clean leather
seats but drastic cases call for drastic
measures we then used an all-purpose
cleaner in a tornador it's basically
compressed air that feeds into a
reservoir that holds an allpurpose
cleaner and then it uses that compressed
air to pick up the solution and blast it
into the material that you're trying to
clean we'll use it when we know that the
leather has seen a lot of age and we
don't want to potentially damage it
further and then I went ahead and used a
leather brush in order to agitate that
further to remove as much mud and
sediment as
possible these would have to dry for
another couple days in a heated storage
facility with the exterior we went ahead
and just did a pretty basic wash so we
had to make sure that we just blew out
all the mud from all the cracks and
crevices there the foam Cannon is is my
personal favorite part when it comes to
washing the exterior of a vehicle foam
and soap is the same thing it's actually
like shaving cream you spray it onto
your hand and as you lather it up it
becomes more foamy it helps break down
some of the grime the grease the
sediment on the vehicle and then lifts
it to the top and that way as you're
washing there's both lubrication as well
as cleaning properties that help you
remove the dirt and grime as efficiently
and safely as possible cleaning the
windows most people ask what solution
you're using what window cleaner are you
using but in reality it's the the type
of towel that you use and how many Tils
you use and how clean they are so
windows are very prone to streaking
especially when they've been splattered
with mud like they were in this vehicle
so to start out we just use your
standard shop towels in order to remove
the bulk of the grime and then we use
another type of towel that's called GSM
so it has a higher G per square meter of
microfiber and all that means is that
there's more fibers on the towel and the
more GRS per square meter the fluffier
the towel and the more microfiber
strands there are to wipe away any of
the
streaks they actually were able to get
that car running again so it still
functions but with a good conscious they
can't sell that car to another
owner when you finish it and you look
back at the result you know we we laugh
because I don't know how it came out so
well but somehow it
does there are beautiful old tiles
hidden under all this Gunk but it will
take a lot of elbow grease to reveal
them whether it's revamping an old space
or bringing a classic floor back to life
watch as three professionals tackle age
neglect and misuse that have produced
some of the dirtiest and stickiest flaw
Kate deer the CEO of fwell walks us
through how she deep cleans a bank floor
made in 1908 it hasn't been touched in 7
years and she's revamping the space into
a wedding venue she found the tile under
the carpet during an asbestos inspection
and decided to deep clean it so it could
be part of the new space the carpet is
very thick and therefore heavy so the
first thing she does is get the carpet
off and let the tile breathe the carpet
glue was the thickest she'd ever
encountered and completely covered the
tile underneath the moisture and heat
from the steam are some of the only
things that would seep through the glue
to loosen it after she hits it with the
steamer she scrapes it up and starts
sanding the top layer where the glue
stained the tile with a yellow
Haze she adds Zep floor stripper which
liquefies the glue so she's able to
scrape it up with a
blade when areas of the carpet glue
become really tough to remove she puts
down a marble polish to help buff out
those
sections the floor is old and uneven so
her team needs to use a bristle brush
attachment to get the steam
in then the team seals the tole to
protect it for the
[Music]
future Costa iano the owner of Pinnacle
Stone Restoration walks us through how
his team deep cleans tazzo floors that
are over 100 years old parts of the Tazo
floors were hidden under carpet and
discovered as the room was being
renovated the most difficult part of
this clean is carpet and glue removal he
removes the carpet with electric
scraping machines and the carpet glue
with handheld
scrapers gusta removes the glue by hand
because it keeps the temperature low
which helps the glue come out more
easily from the
torazo grinding the tazzo floors helps
to flatten and even out the
surface then he moves onto the honing
process which cleans and polishes off
the scratches left behind by the
grinding process he starts polishing
using a 1,500 grit Diamond pad followed
by 3,000 grit after that he uses another
system that has much finer pads which
make the tazzo harder and more
durable then it's time to seal Costa
uses a sealer that seeps into the tzo
and protects it from stains burnishing
the floors helps the sealer bring the
tzo to its highest
[Music]
Sheen
Courtney Lee and his team at Truman's
hardwood floor ref finishing tackled
dark muddy looking
floors they're covered with thick wax
layers resulting from DIY attempts at
revitalizing Wood
Floors the acrylic waxes from products
that are meant for short-term Solutions
are extremely soft and don't harden up
or cure they sit on top of the floors
instead of soaking in allowing dirt soil
and any Airborne contaminants to bond to
them Courtney's team of of floor
technicians specializes in wax removal
from Hardwood
Floors floor ref finishing requires
sanding off existing Coatings but it's
difficult to do with these layers of wax
sitting on top because the wax will
likely clug up the Sanders the team
comes in to emulsify the wax which takes
it back to a liquid form and allows them
to extract it from the
floors buildup like this usually happens
over the course of 5 to 20 years they
spray the floors with an emulsifier and
let it sit for some time depending on
the severity and amount of wax they do
this section by section they follow up
with extraction tools which remove the
wax from the floors into the
machine depending on how much wax there
is they repeat this two to three times
the buffer runs at a low speed during
this process there is a soft pad and a
mesh screen on the bottom which comes in
different grids the screen scratches off
the old polyurethane so the team can
apply new polyurethane this is what
SEALs and protects the hardwood floors
and is typically the final layer before
the wax a splash guard is usually
attached to the buffer to keep the wax
from slinging onto the walls and
baseboards in some cases like here corny
will scrape off the wax by hand he does
this when there is too much buildup on
the floor he'll scrape up as much as
possible to prevent the wax from
clogging up the Vacuums in their
machines and then remove the residual as
normal
once Courtney removes the wax the floor
is back to its bare original
state in some cases depending on what
the homone is want to do he'll apply a
new layer of polyurethane to finish the
[Music]
job
these gravestones are so overgrown with
organic matter that the epitaphs are no
longer legible healing headstones is a
business in Maine that works to clean
and restore headstones like these as a
way to honor the deceased I'm Ryan with
hilling headstones I'm going to walk you
through how I scrape scrub and deep
clean moss covered
headstones I start by assessing the
stone and make sure especially if it's
older to if it can handle a deep
cleaning the dirtiest parts are the very
base at the ground or also deep in the
letters the letters seem to hold on to
the most dirt and grime because they're
cut into the stone most of the newer
stones are made of either marble or
Granite they have more of a glossy
finish the stones before the 20s they
don't have if they did have gloss it's
not there anymore so I think that's why
they get stained way worse and it's way
deeper into the stone the first thing I
do is spray down the stone with water to
make the moss removal easier I use a
hand pump sprayer to wet the headstones
and also to spray them
off I'll start scraping the Moss top to
bottom because that's the easiest method
and you can see on the bottom layers of
moss it turns into almost a concrete
like material which makes it even harder
to get off and remove it I use a special
scraper it's kind of the plastic and
rubber fill at the same time so it's
made for
headstones
I'll use the corner of the scraper to
get into the small crevices and remove
any other
debris now when you're using the scraper
you have to be careful of the condition
of the stone some of them they can have
what's called sugaring where it's almost
as you touch it it'll turn into a powder
the same thing with cracks and the same
thing with you know stability with a
scraper you're not really trying to get
all the Moss you're just trying to get
the top layer off without damaging the
stone you want to remove as much Moss as
possible possible so it's easier when
you start scrubbing the
stone the black is mold and Moss kind of
build up it can also be green sometimes
you'll see orange but that's more they
have the metal rods holding the stone
and that's where water's gotten on the
inside and it the rust starts to run out
and that can stain them as well
sometimes you can scrape the Moss off
and you can find mold underneath which
has Stained it black or green into the
stone I'd say the moss on the stone has
been built up for minimum 5 years
environment and climate can both have an
effect on the growth that's on the
stone the finish of the stone can affect
kind of how much grows on it what grows
on it the rougher finishes can hold
water and it holds algae and stuff that
builds up which kind of just eventually
will take over the stone with a smooth
surface even like the rain can wash away
the growth or anything it starts to
build up up there before it ever takes a
[Music]
hold once all the moss and debris off
the stone I spray down the stone with D2
cleaner after I let the spray cleaning
solution set for about 10 minutes I'll
follow that up with a soft bristle brush
I found that using a circular pattern is
the best
method the technique can vary depending
on the stone design and the Engravings
on the front of the stone I'll sometimes
use a toothbrush to get down into the
smaller crevices it just helps to more
thoroughly get all the debris and out of
the small
places I'll use a wooden pick to go
inside the letters and some of the
engraving if it's a deep small area that
the brush can't really get
into to get it back to its original
Stater as close as you can sometimes you
have to do certain parts of the process
over and
[Music]
over I'll do a final spray off to make
sure all the debris is off the stone I
finished the cleaning with a protective
coating of the cleaner cuz it continues
to keep anything from growing or
building up on the stone I would
recommend checking a stone at least once
every 6 months minimum to make sure
nothing has started building up before
it gets to an excessive
[Music]
level it's rewarding to be able to help
these families and also honor those
whose graves are left
unmaintained
the dust that accumulates inside air
vents doesn't just prevent the flow of
fresh air into a home it can also pose
severe health risks when it's time for a
routine cleaning some may turn to
professionals like Cur home CEO Daniel
felt to get the job done my name is
Daniel felt and I am the owner of of
Ciro home today we're going to go
through the process of deep cleaning air
ducts the purpose of an air duct is
essentially to provide fresh clean air
to your
home we provide air doct cleaning and
routine Home maintenance services where
we visit our clients homes once a
quarter do everything you're supposed to
be doing as a perfect homeowner but a
lot of people don't have the time or
neglect to do when we clean the air
ducts we go through and we clean the
entire system so we start in the upper
level and we work our way all the way
through the entire home depending on who
and what is living in the home the
debris that we find inside of air do
consists of a lot of different items
such as skin cells dust dander pet
debris pet hair anything that you would
see when you maybe wipe your feet off on
a rug when you walk inside a home can be
found inside of an
air this air duct has not been clean for
probably 50 plus years Additionally the
person that lived in this home has also
smoked and had pets so this is a very
severe air duct that can actually SM
smell it it has an old house smell built
up over time if it's a really light
color often we're finding sawdust or
sheetrock dust that is from construction
debris as we get in darker colors
sometimes smoking inside the home is
going to leave more of a yellow color
and as it gets darker a lot of times
we're more concerned about a humidity
issue that can eventually turn into a
dark colored mold you're getting into
more hazardous material in there once
the air duct cover is removed we're
going to allow the air compressor hose
to be put into the air duct before we're
turning on that hose we're going to put
a clear Dome over the cover and we're
going to attach our HEPA vacuum to the
Dome once those items are in place we're
going to turn the air compressor on and
that allows the hose with a reverse
blasting ball to propel itself forward
into the air duct the clear Dome that's
used is crucial because it creates a
sealed environment so that we're getting
all the dust and debris out of the home
and we're not creating a mess inside the
home but it's also crucial cuz it
creates a really nice suction area so
all of the power from the air compressor
and the vacuum are working together to
pull and push the debris outside we can
twist and turn that hose so we can go
around any Corner once we get to the end
trunk line we can feel that in the air
compressor hose and we're going to
slowly pull that back at about 1T per
second as we're doing that we can see
all the dust and debris that is being
removed from the air duct come through
that clear Dome and go into the Hep of
vacuum once we've completed the cleaning
find that a little bit of dust and
debris has come all the way to the end
of the air duct and it's really
important to take your vacuum and clean
out that extra debris that's
come often times that's where you're
going to find real Treasures such as
bugs toys dog toys bones items like that
that have been placed really far into
the air duct and all of our equipment
has pulled it
out in order to clean the dust and
debris that's found on the inside or
outside of vents you want to remove the
vent first and brush that off with the
vacuum and you're you're going to get a
majority of dust and debris off then we
put the bent cover back on and replace
the screws back to the original format
and make sure the area is nice and clean
and clear of
debris all the air in your home is
circulating through your furnace on a
regular basis and by having a clean
clear furnace filter it's going to catch
all the dust and debris that is
circulating throughout depending on the
style of furnace filter that you have
you may have one that needs to be
cleaned on a regular basis and you can
do this by using a HEPA vacuum and brush
locate the furnace filter inside your
furnace and remove that door and pull
that furnace filter out the next thing
you want to do is take your vacuum and
place that over the furnace filter to
make sure you're cleaning that really
nice and
[Music]
thoroughly a dryer vent is allowing the
exhaust from a dryer to be pushed
outside of the home the reason why is
because over time lint builds up inside
that dryer vent
to properly clean a dryer vent usually
you just need a air compressor and you
can use a reverse blasting ball or whip
to place inside the dryer vent we're
going to find that exhaust on the
outside of the home and we're going to
place the air compressor hose inside the
dryer vent and we're going to turn that
on that will Propel itself into the
dryer and dislodge all the lint that's
built up over time there's heat that's
being pushed through that dryer vent and
if the drier vent does not have proper
air flow it's very easy for that lint to
become flammable and start on fire we
recommend having your dry ENT clean on
an annual basis to prevent the buildup
of the lint and decrease the chance of a
fire happening in your home depending on
your current health such as if you have
really bad allergies or not that can
play a really large Factor on the risk
of living in a home with the dirty air
ducts we've had all kinds of different
results we've had people that have told
us that they slept through the night for
the first time after they had their air
ducts clean because the air quality was
improved that
[Music]
much this fence is completely covered in
mildew and ALDI and removing it will
require specialized equipment AJ Joiner
from Advanced pressure washing LLC
demonstrates how he cleans the dirty
exterior of a client's home without
damaging it my name is AJ jiner owner of
advanced pressure washing LLC today
we're going to show you how we clean the
exterior of a client's dirty home step
by
step we in general we offer exterior
cleaning but the main services in the
residential field are house washing goer
cleanout uh concrete cleaning those are
the main ticket items that we solicit to
the residential
[Music]
CL the condition of the fence
structurally is great but as you can see
it's covered in build do an algae wood
is very particular because if you uh use
too much pressure you're going to cause
a lot of damage to the surface so to
treat it we just use water we actually
use moderate pressure we make sure
always to go with the grain this keeps
us from furing SL damaging the
[Music]
wood the driveway is terrible covered in
mil algae the chemicals we normally use
is called sodium hypochloride 12.5% or
better known as pull shock SL industrial
bleach uh we normally do with that down
to a 50/50 ratio in our buckets this
kills a mil algae that top layer when we
pre-treat it kills it almost
instantly this is called a whisper wash
Big Boy Surface Cleaner that metal
tubing uh actually rotates a round on a
swivel that's the item that that I use
to actually clean
[Music]
concrete
from there we'll actually go around
washing the trim of around the brick and
other areas the Surface Cleaner couldn't
reach uh and then we will post treat
with a detergent again to get any
organic stains that are left
[Music]
behind uh after we do the driveway will
then do the uh front patio and sidewalk
uh also sometimes if the client wants
we'll also do the curves along the
[Music]
drive
the house is in pretty good condition
but there was a few spots that we
noticed that were pretty bad with heavy
and thick mildew analy uh on a house we
use roughly about 10% sodium
hypochloride uh mixed with about 90%
water so the black on the brick is
actually mil just really thick mil do an
algae this is caused by moisture uh and
shade allowing for such thig buildo
algae to
[Music]
grow when we wash a house's exterior we
wash the roof the outside the gutters
beside the home the windows the doors
anything that on the side or
attached to the home
[Music]
itself so we're finished we finally got
the job done uh so roughly this job took
us about uh 4 and 1/2 hours everything
looks amazing the client was beyond
happy with the job that we have done you
clearly see everything is transformed
into a new clean State my personal
suggestion instead of trying to do it
yourself is always hire a professional
because you're dealing with some very
strong and dangerous chemicals uh and it
can become dangerous when in the hands
of someone not experience boat covers
exist to keep dust and debris from
dirting a boat's interior but after some
time the covers themselves also need
cleaning Mike Sadowski from Chets
cleaning shows us how he tackles such a
specialized cleaning I'm Mike Sadowski
with chat's cleaning and we are out of
Madison Heights Michigan and we clean
just about everything except for walls
and windows today we're going to be
cleaning a dirty boat
[Music]
cover the simple reason for the boat
cover is just to keep the inside of the
boat not looking like the cover did so
that way the cover takes the brunt of
the uh elements rather than the
boat the material the boat covers a
umbrella material it's a solution dyed
acrylic so it has great stain resist
properties and it's pretty friendly for
the sun which is how it can survive out
there this one was primarily animal
issues flying overhead and uh some mold
that was built up from use I would guess
it was probably about 5 years out in the
[Music]
elements the chemicals that we use it's
called dot there's a dlor granules in
there which is a chlorine and then there
is a surfactant so a detergent in there
allows us to get the soil off along with
the mold and mildew dot is very chemical
friendly in terms of it's not going to
burn my skin at all it's virtually
odorless we use dwell time to allow the
solution to break down any of the soils
mold mildew that's in there needs at
least a half an hour but I can let it
sit overnight at
times once that's had time to do what it
needs to do we go ahead and use
agitation so a scrub brush either by
hand or mechanical the yellow machine
it's called a simex it's an orbital
scrubber so the scrub pads at the bottom
are just going in a circular motion
while the head turns in a different
direction what it's doing is pulling
apart the fibers slightly the way
they're woven and it allows the soil and
embedded mold and Milo to release a
little bit easier rather than still
being tightly woven with the
fibers
the high pressure water is what really
breaks apart everything that's down in
there it's a mild detergent that we use
in rug washing that is going through the
power washing gun so it's not just water
it's soap and water coming out at the
same
time I'm using the broom to push water
off of the boat cover a lot of times
whether it's the boat cover or rugs it's
very hard to see staining that's
remaining when the water is puddled on
there so I'm just pushing it off so that
way I'm able to see what's going on and
make sure that I didn't miss any areas
while I was uh power
washing the bath that it goes into I was
just using it to help rinse out all of
the detergent and the products that I
had put onto the boat cover cuz whatever
I use I want to make sure I get
[Music]
off I put it through our rinse ringer so
that was just squeegeeing out some of
the water and hitting it with another
High Press system to get another power
washing job going
getting it as clean as possible from
there we went ahead and hung it and
dried it with bow covers I typically
don't get them when they look clean and
where rugs and upholstery I would tell
you it should be cleaned regularly no
matter what the appearance B covers I go
a little bit different they are cleaned
as needed if it gets real bad and you
want it clean that would be the time if
it's a generic cover it might not even
be worth cleaning you just let it live
its life and replace it other times they
might outweigh the benefit of trying to
find material and get a new one made and
just have it clean to buy them a few
more years the biggest thing that I've
ran into whether it's from sun damage or
aggressive cleaning you actually cause
that Som brella to not become as
repellent and Som brella does sell a
product to reapply that repellency or
the projected to it so depending on the
scenario people want to look to get that
done also to make sure it stays in good
shape
spilling red wine on a white carpet can
feel irreversible but the professionals
at Hubert steam cleaning in North
Carolina can work their magic to make
even the toughest of stains
disappear Hubbert steam cleaning
specializes in getting tough stains out
of carpet like red wine here a customer
dropped an entire bottle onto her Berber
carpet it's pretty much a killer for
most carpets or most cleaners if you
don't know how to properly attack it the
first time the first step is identifying
the type of carpet he's working on this
determines how he approaches removing
the stain this one is tightly knit and
the stain has completely soaked through
it it's harder to get it from between
those vies because they're so tightly W
he sprays the rug with a free treatment
which consists of a protein remover and
lets it sit for about 35 to 40 minutes
this counteracts the acidity of the wine
and makes it
dissipate then he brings out the bonser
steam
cleaner the trick is managing the heat
correctly if it's too high it can leave
brown stains behind if it's too low then
the stain will just sit on top of the
carpet instead of coming all the way out
this causes wicking which is when
moisture from spills and cleaning agents
moves up the carpet fibers from the
backing of the carpet leading to
recurring stains that are difficult to
remove but when all the steps are done
right the steam cleaner will be able to
extract all the
wine these roofs have been taken over by
Moss but Spencer CL from Northwest for a
wash has the tools and the skills to dig
out the debris without causing any
damage my name is Spencer clay and I
specialize in deep cleaning and removing
layers of moss off of
roofs the area that you live in in the
climate definitely plays a huge factor
into the amount of moss frow on roofs up
here in the Pacific Northwest we have a
lot of moss because there's a lot of
rain there's not a lot of sunlight and
there's a lot of trees and stuff that
provide all that material for the stuff
to grow
on there's probably hundreds or
thousands of species but generally if
it's green or black black or something
living up there it needs to be
removed so here this gutter guard sponge
was completely grown in compacted with
mold Moss so we need to get it out put
in some new gutter guards so that the
gutters could be flowing and working as
they
should the purpose of the gutter guard
is to keep stuff out of the gutters this
sponge got so grown in compacted and
stuff that we needed to remove it and
put in new gutter guards Moss can get up
in between any crack or crevice that you
have up on the roof and the gutters it
either grows bigger and bigger and
bigger and the water can get up in there
as well too or in the winter too when it
freezes it can freeze and expand you
know really break that seal that your
house or roof typically
has so Moss really loves growing
especially on rofs that have a lower
pitch when it has a higher pitch it has
a harder time grabbing onto a hold of
the roof but if it's a lower pitch and
it's a lot less steep there can be quite
a bit more Moss cuz it's it has a lot
easier time of getting in between the
cracks there and generally you're going
to see a lot more moss growth on the
Northern side you know when there's when
there's a lack of sunlight so that's
that's really one of the biggest
factors Moss has the easiest time of
growing in between asphalt single roofs
the Moss can really get up in there grow
expand and break the seal of the shingle
for the roof and water can get up in
there more Moss organic material and it
can cause mold and water can get up in
there and damage the
roof I'll generally start any cleaning
process with the leaf blower and the
brush getting all that organic Material
off before I start treading
it so when you see like this level of
moss like up on a roof there's almost no
way around you got to get that Moss off
there you got to brush it off because
even if you treat it it's still there's
so much organic material up there that
the Moss is going to have a really easy
time just regrowing once you get rid of
it it's going to be so much easier to
treat the roof keep it from coming
back I'll use a stiffer nylon brush we
really want to be careful when we're
brushing if you brush too hard you can
definitely damage the shingles but if
you're doing it the right way you're
doing it gently you can just get rid of
that Moss like by just gently kind of
flicking it off you can Leaf blow it off
later so every roof is different it
really depends on how established the
Moss is how much Moss what type of moss
if there's a lot of trees that really
affects the amount of pressure that I
use when I'm brushing it
off here I'm using a stick cuz the Moss
is so growing in that the brush can't
even really get in between the cracks
and I'll generally alternate you know
between the stick and the brush
depending on the Moss level depending on
what gets it off the quickest
I'll follow the leaf blowing with
another hand brushing and this will get
everything else that the leaf blower
didn't take care of it'll get it loose
and we can blow it off
later once all the Moss is gone and the
roof is clean we can begin the treatment
process when you're treating a roof our
main purpose is to raise the alkalinity
so raise the ph and you can do that with
laundry detergent you can do that with
the Zinc powder and also baking soda you
could use sodium hypochlorite which is
that's like bleach and with the
treatment it's usually combination of
different chemicals that I use that
raises the ph and then makes it really
hard for the Moss to get established and
come back in the
future when you see me spraying up there
that's usually the sodium hoc chlorate
basically bleach killing everything up
there and then the Moss preventative
powder when I apply the treatment powder
Up on the Roof I really want to be
hitting the Peaks really hard because
that's going to you know it's going to
flow down the roof eventually Ledges
gaps seams places around the windows as
well you want to put a little bit extra
sometimes down there the size of the
roof really deter the amount of powder
and treatment I'm going to need to put
up on the roof when you put the
treatment powder on you can leave it on
there you don't really need to touch it
the rain is going to take care of the
rest for you it's going to wash down
over the next couple weeks most
cleanings that I do are roofs that are
at least 5 10 years old because Moss is
so damaging I always recommend
homeowners get their roofs clean and
treated every year to uphold the
integrity and longevity of their
roof this heavily soiled threepiece
microfiber furniture set has never been
cleaned before John Bristol and his team
at Superfresh will work to extract all
of the dirt and restore the sofa to its
original brown color my name is John
Bristol and I am the owner of Super
Fresh detailing and sanitation and we
operate within Trinidad and Tobago in
today's video I will be cleaning a
three-piece microfiber C set for this
particular set the client was actually
considering replacing it completely and
getting a new one but they decided since
they were aware of the cleaning services
that they would give it a try to see if
they could delay the purchase just for a
few more months although this set looks
like it may be a leather set what you're
actually seeing is a lot of buildup on
the surface itself it is actually a
microfiber couch which means we're able
to use our regular process to get it
cleaned this couch has never been
cleaned since it was bought in my
experience the microfiber sets are
usually dirtier than other cotton or
synthetic fibers depending on the age of
the sofa and where it's located the
buildup on it would consist of different
things humid environments typically
leave persons with a lot more sweat on
their skin which in turn ends up on the
couch this is one of the dirtiest
couches I've encountered currently looks
dark brown with some areas being black
due to how solil the couch was I spray
on the simple green Degreaser which
works to break down the dirton oils and
then wait 10 minutes for it to work
before I start scrubbing I generally
apply the pre-spray evenly placing extra
emphas on the areas that are more soiled
I'm careful not to apply too much to
avoid overring the fabric and to reduce
the chances of splatter once I start
scrubbing now that that 10-minute period
has passed I can start
scrubbing scrubbing is that mechanical
action that helps break down the larger
pieces of debris and makes everything
ready for extraction later on using a
variable speed polisher with a brush
attachment I begin scrubbing starting at
the CR sures and working my way to the
flatter portions of the surface in this
case I have to make multiple passes with
the machine as well as scrubbing and
spraying after scrubbing once I see that
the soes have sufficiently been broken
down I move on to the actual
extraction here our equipment sprays in
a solution of Clean Water fabric shampoo
and deodorizer and Vacuums at the same
time this means that the debris that is
on the surface of the couch is rinsed
away with every pass of our
machine taking the couch panel by panel
I start at the edges where the crevices
are and work my way over the smoother
areas I'm also careful to make multiple
passes where the couch was most soiled
after cleaning the love seat and
Consulting the owner I can now move on
to the rest of the
set because of the condition of the
waste water I'll make extra passes on
this SC set to ensure that we to get all
of the dirt out the most difficult thing
about cleaning this couch in particular
is the amount of time that it's taking
this couch took between 5 and 6 hours to
clean now that I'm finished cleaning
this set is going to be damp to the
touch however it's only going to be
about 3 to 4 hours for it to be fully
dry and ready to use again a yearly
cleaning would ensure that the dust dird
sweats as well as other contaminants
don't have the opportunity to
significantly build up on your sofa and
affect the air quality and overall
hygiene in your home after the process
of cleaning this couch the natural light
brown has been
restored the clients were really
satisfied with the end result and they
were able to delay purchasing an entire
new set for a while this traditional
Persian rug has been accumulating dirt
for 10 years Ali Rosati from Rosati rugs
shows us how he cleans the valuable
family air without causing damage this
is is a rare Persian rug that's
appraised at an estimated
$112,500 and it's about to get its first
cleaning in more than two decades it's a
delicate job and not just because this
antique is so valuable it's also a
family heirloom and the clients are
trusting the team at rosatti rugs to
deep clean it carefully the goal is to
remove the accumulation of dirt and
stains without harming the rug's
coloring Ali Rosati inspects the fibers
carefully to determine how the rug was
originally dyed this key detail will
determine how he'll complete the job
without causing any damage so his
clients can continue to pass down this
treasure for Generations so my client's
aunt had this rug for about 20 years and
she was very hesitant to have it clean
because she was afraid that it would get
ruined I know this is a 1940s rug
because they used vegetable D in
comparison to a 1960s Tes like this one
here there's a specific specific process
to cleaning vegetable dye rugs I know
that I can use a deep wash because the
dyes won't run this is the pool that we
have the rugs clean and we have a drain
right here it's built on an angle so
that when we put a rug on either side
the water will just go right through
directly into the
drain one of Al's team members Begins
the cleaning process by applying
Browning treatment to the stains this
works to remove tannin type stains like
urine fruit juice beer or soil as well
as general discoloration due to
age this 1940s shik mashi rug has
collected stains from various family
gatherings throughout the years but
that's not all that makes this tb's rug
unique what makes it so special is not
only the technique of weave and the fine
weaving on the back but also the design
and the color combinations that are used
as well after letting the Browning
treatment sit for 15 minutes he hoses
down the rug and applies
shampoo next he agitates the fibers with
a scrubber which loosens up the
accumulated dirt and brings it to the
surface so the scrubber or the buffer is
used to help scrub and expand the use of
the shampoo throughout the rug and it
does it in a fast and efficient way so
if you were to actually hand do this Not
only would you get tired physically but
wouldn't be as
effective Ary estimates that the
original Weaver made only a few hundred
of these rugs decades ago the coloring
also dates back to a time when Master
Weavers used different techniques this
rug is made with vegetable dyed wool
which means the coloring came from
natural materials like plants fruits or
tree bar this method is more labor
intensive which adds to the rug's value
Chrome dyes come from chemicals that are
used and boiled to create certain colors
Chrome dyes were used to decrease the
cost of rug weaving so in terms of price
point they are less in comparison to
rugs that have vegetable dyes
Incorporated in them as you can see this
type of a red tone is so bright you only
see that in Chrome dyes but with
vegetable dyes they're a little bit more
subtle in
comparison the transition from vegetable
dyes to Chrome dyes in the mid 20th
century brought about a new era in rug
making Chrome dyes offered a wider and
more affordable range of Hues which
revolutionized the industry but the
legacy of those early Persian rug makers
is still visible today in rugs like this
which is why it's so important to
preserve it the team member rinses the
rug and pushes a squeeze s across each
section to remove excess water this step
several times throughout the cleaning
process to remove as much water as
possible he runs the scrubber across the
rug again to loosen any remaining dirt
and then uses the extractor to lift the
stains and remove
moisture the extractor actually has two
purposes you can one just use it as a
vacuum you just place it on the rug and
you start pulling it towards your
direction and it starts extracting the
water out so that the rug gets to dry
faster also it has another feature where
if you press on the lever not only will
it extract water but it'll expel hot
water at the same time and those are
great for taking away stains because you
could do that multiple times on a
certain
area all the rugs are heated to a high
temperature of I'd say about 90° on
average and they're hung right here the
rug must be completely dry before moving
on to the next step if not the excess
moisture can lead to mold and M you two
factors that can deteriorate the fibers
in the rug we'll go inside of the
drawing room and we'll examine it and
touch the pile of the rug the fringes
and the other aspects of the rug to see
if it's still moist or not if we feel it
is we'll keep it in there the room is
dry to a very high temperature and just
having all the fans and dehumidifiers
usually having a rug in there for about
a day would completely dry it out
the quality of Wee on tabid rugs is
based on something called Raj which
counts the number of linear knots every
7 cm which is roughly 2 and 1/2 in the
higher the rid the higher the quality
which also makes a rug more valuable so
in today's market I would estimate this
value around $122,500 you have these
lines that are showing on the back side
of the rug and when you look at those
lines you'll be able to actually count
count how many knots are in between each
line and so this specific rug is 50 r on
a lower quality tibr you'll have a 20
rag this is actually a lower quality
tiis you can see how big the knots are
in comparison to this rug here these
knots are a lot more tight this is
around that 20 rag that I had mentioned
earlier and then you have the 50 R which
is a more higher quality R would be very
exceptional and then you'll have like 80
or 90 rad which are extremely rare to
find and those type of rugs take close
to 10 years to make but this type of a
caliber I'd say in terms of Rarity on a
scale of one to 10 it would be a seven
so when you look at the different color
combinations and designs that are used
in this rug it seems like there's a lot
of religious symbolism going on and that
makes sense because she mashi was a
religious man within his region and the
predominant use of green is of Islamic
religious significance because green was
the prophet Muhammad's favorite color
I've grown up with Persian rugs in my
home and there's a lot of deep cultural
significance to Persian rugs and the
history behind it so I feel very akin to
my culture being in this
industry the rug looks magnificent
it's much brighter than it was before
and the majority of the stains have been
removed there are a lot of other people
in this industry that really don't put
their heart into it they just clock in
and clock out but each rug is a portion
of a person's home and I take that
responsibility to heart that when they
bring their rug to me they're bringing a
part of their home into my life
for me to take care
[Music]
of